forget in fashion The cgc Knockout phase
has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real hey one second oh
my God
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends it's the cgc round of 64. who
will take the next step to Toronto
[Music]
I was muted Robert that's how early we
are for the broadcast here welcome back
everyone to the chess.com Global
Championship my name is Olivia Rosman
I'm joined today by Robert Hess if you
were here for yesterday's coverage we
might look a little bit familiar and a
bonus we will have the profit none other
than Grandmaster Daniel naredinski
joining a little bit later as well uh
super super exciting stuff in The
Knockouts thus far with some brackets in
fact all brackets being destroyed as of
yesterday but we will be getting into
the fantasy contest a little bit later
let's go over some Logistics of the
event so first things first
excuse me we have the format do you uh
are just getting here a little bit late
you know that this is a single
elimination knockout players will play
four games three or four games it's a
best of four in Rapid 15 minute with two
second bonus time and it's obviously
first uh to two and a half
should it be 2-2 in the Rapids then they
will play an Armageddon with a bidding
system to determine how many minutes
they get on the clock to play with the
black pieces and draw odds I don't think
we're ever going to get a more Savage
one than Vichy seven minutes Robert I
was gonna say Levy that's the thing we
learned best yesterday is that seven
minutes is too few to play an Armageddon
game vishwanathan the legendary world
champion eliminated based on well his
bet was not good enough and Pavel
pankartov made him pay yes he did
speaking of uh Bible we have the field
here we don't have pival listed but it's
just a description 64 players although
actually now it's quite a bit less we
are not exactly done with the round of
64 but probably about 46 players
remaining 32 qualified 32 were um
invited obviously preceding we've got
well we did have we're gonna have to
update this graphic we used to have a
handful of world champions uh but
actually many were eliminated in
yesterday's group F matchups but we have
Hikaru Duda Wesley so you'll see them
there Carolina
let's take a look specifically uh at
today's matchup and today's uh I guess
focus of the morning broadcast we've got
the entirety of group E but some of
these matches will start a little bit
later and that is when actually uh
Daniel aritzky will slot in for myself
we've got arjunari guy see though
kicking off the morning round with David
paravian and Tamar rajabov taking on
holifan then we have a group b matchup
which is chakra
vladislav kovalev janipomishi Muhammad
muradli and Peter swidler versus Alexis
Robert I feel like that's a match you
would see in uh some Tata steel 1995 or
something you know these guys yeah it's
like a candidates zonal between Fiddler
and shirov it's great to see fire on the
board come back it's Fiddler he's
playing in the Champions 960 event in St
Louis he was just commenting the sink
full cup so he's had his hands full and
he will have his hands full with one of
the most aggressive players of all time
absolutely uh let's take a look at our
prizes
price is obviously a million dollars
you've heard Daniel nerideski there say
it in the in the b-roll uh and yes the
prizes are enormous 5 000 just for
making it to the round of 64. you could
play the worst chess of your life and
still walk away with a nice paycheck but
10 is what it goes up to to making it to
the round of 32 and beyond that it just
gets higher and higher with a total of
two hundred thousand dollars going to
the champion and it even gets a little
fancy asterisk next to it that tells you
it's the largest first place prize in
Pro chess this year so there you go look
at that
um I think we have
um the brackets in in an overall format
here for you just to see what's going to
happen so the winners of yan yeponushi
and Muhammad muradli will take on Peter
Fiddler uh the winner I should say of
Peter Fiddler and Alexa shirov Arjun
Erie guys see David paravian the winner
will take on the winner of Tamo rajaba
versus hoefan Robert who did you uh pick
to emerge out of this group uh it's very
hard to go against Yani promise you but
do you think it's going to be against
Eric icy yes I have yawn against our
generic icy in the finals of this
particular group and I don't even
remember who I picked I struggled with
this one the most of all because Jana
palmshi he has been well in the words of
uh mugatu he's so hot right now he's the
hottest player on the planet he's won
the candidates twice in a row seems like
every event he plays in he does well but
Arjun aragaisi by performance rating
he's right up there he's now into the
2730s he's a teenager we've known about
him for years now he's showing his stuff
in classical chess as well at the
Olympiad and other events but he can't
even look past his first round opponent
Levy That's How Strong this field is
David paravian made about twenty
thousand dollars in the rapid Chess
Championship he played every single week
he made eight Kos he was a force to be
reckoned with so I don't think Arjun is
thinking oh let me go and play yawn in
this brackets final no he's thinking how
do I get past David today
yes absolutely but he he might also very
much be thinking uh not of just playing
young in the final and it's a hard stop
and he'll be satisfied our generic ice
is a silent killer like honestly he is
so confident and yet so calm and
collected in all of his interviews I do
think that will be the final match-up
but we still have intriguing chests to
be played a couple of last logistical
things for all of you we originally had
a perfect bracket contest where if you
submitted a
perfect bracket then you would have
received a hundred thousand dollar price
that is no longer possible because a
couple of chess players decided to beat
a couple of other chess players so you
have to blame those chess players uh of
course the biggest one being Pavel
pencrado who probably
messed up I don't know something like 80
to 85 percent of brackets and yesterday
uh or rather two days ago uh Eric Hanson
defeated La Quang Liam and that was
obviously a very significant result as
well but we do still have a fantasy
contest and the top 20 finishers based
on percentage of accuracy will win
certain merch prizes and maybe if we
convince the higher-ups they will still
Grant some other you know cash prizes as
well maybe we'll we'll do our best
um but that's all about our bracket
contest definitely make sure to get
involved and I think last but not least
we have a little bio of hoefan uh she's
uh
currently 28 years of age she is
Robert is it like being a president in
chess like if you were the world
champion do they call you a world
champion forever or does she just get a
is she Professor like what what is the
title that hoefan receives uh with her
accomplished career on and off the board
it's a great question because we've seen
Vladimir krumnick vishnathan on it and I
feel like we always say former Champion
uh but I think we can just call him
champs for life because hoefan is just
that she's a professor uh she had a road
scholarship she's doing so many things
off the chessboard but it's great to see
her back Levy I mean she's playing in
the Chinese chess League she's uh you
know trying to get back at the board
when she can and this matchup the job of
uh who are you fun what is this like
Bill 2013 or something like this feels
like a great matchup that we've seen in
years past these are two players who
maybe uh you know some would say their
primes are behind them but I think that
today they're gonna showcase excellent
chess
yeah absolutely absolutely having said
that rajaba is an extremely active
player uh their game has been
oh are we following oh you were
following a different game you got me
spooked there that was just that was
just the chess board that wasn't their
game getting aboard and you can see
they're both kind of going through their
pre-game routine if chess had an
announcement system like Bruce Buffer
weighing in at 175 pounds you know
they're both kind of like getting into
game shape and whatnot
um as I was saying though I mean rajab
is he is the favorite in this matchup he
is extremely extremely active as of late
um I think he's uh back in his uh in his
native Baku currently where he probably
has some sort of decadent chess Palace
it seems it seems like the more plain
the room behind you the better you play
we saw that with no idea back yesterday
rojab of almost has absolutely nothing
behind him
well the job of is somebody who everyone
has cast aside when he played the
candidates like oh you haven't won a
game since 2019 it's like I barely
played since 2019 except for a
tournament here and there and so I think
the job of we know how strong he is we
know the kind of offbeat openings that
he made even more popular and just the
aggressive play he used to have at the
end of the canvas Levy and you were
covering that action as well he was able
to score five out of seven in the back
half of the tournament he'd be dingling
around with black clearly the guy can
still play top level chess
yeah I think it for this game we're
either gonna see C5 or E6 uh it seems
the The Meta at all levels now is to
play a Queen's Gambit decline type of
setup uh I'm very fascinated the players
are thinking this much in the first move
or two and that probably has to do with
the fact that the ready is one of the
most annoying openings to face because
you truly have no idea what your
opponent is trying to play look at how
you find she knows Theory okay she's not
she's not remembering Theory she's
deciding what she's going to play
because she doesn't know is her job of
looking for D4 is he looking for E3 at
some point uh or I don't know if she's
battling connection issues but I I
really don't think that's the case no
connection seems fine right now she
might just be doing that because every
time two top players sit at the board
they can play anything right these
players have been uh competing at this
high level for so long that they've
faced every opening Under the Sun so as
you said when you see C4 is there going
to be an early D4 is there going to be
G3 and a fin keto over here and she in
fact plays B6 so you're right Levy you
called it she was just trying to figure
out what move order does she want and
she's feeling catering her Bishop first
that's a very unique move order uh now
white has a couple of approaches white
can play D4 but that kind of will play
into Black's plan of E6 Bishop B4 and
give black just a very comfortable kind
of Queen's Indian style position because
black really doesn't necessarily want
the Knight on C3 sorry white doesn't
want the Knight on C3 uh but rajaba of
unconcerned will he play A3 here or will
he play Just
he will not care about the pin I'm very
okay he doesn't care he does it on G3
just a few and keto saying you know I
understand that you're gonna put Bishop
B4 Knight E4 these kind of things and
you often want to follow that up with F5
it's one of those big ideas for black to
control the E4 Square I think ephon
should go for it uh she can also play
for D5 this is a standard move in most
positions it does shut down your Bishop
which is why I don't love it but it's a
very solid approach
in some ways this is just obviously
white has done nothing wrong but in some
ways this setup doesn't make a whole lot
of sense by white because the move order
that white employs to play a queen's
Indian would have had a bishop on G2
instead of a knight on C3 and when the
bishop went to B4 white would have put
something on D2 that's what white would
have done they would have gone Bishop D2
or Knight T2 this is not bad by any
stretch of the imagination but it's not
the main idea because white has less
chances for Advantage I'm actually very
surprised she didn't put a knight on e4
but she couldn't do it basically at any
point
and the big question and she answers
that question immediately is well will
she do just that huh so this is funny
Levy right this is like something that
newer players and even quite experienced
players who are in the intermediate
phase then what in the world's Bishop to
E4 you were just talking about Knight E4
both moves are options 94 is more uh
powerful when there's a pin on the C3
Knight but Bishop E4 the point is that
you can now develop your knight to C6 I
think it was like D5 and you still
that's wrong this is right here we go we
still have tension between the Bishops
on the light Square diagonal yeah Bishop
E4 just probably looks absurd to 99 of
viewers like it seems much more natural
to put a knight on e4 and then attack a
weak Pawn on C3 but Bishop E4 is a very
it's a very strong move uh and white
often times in these positions will play
Bishop H3 I've even I've even seen this
before I've played like this I think
against Emilio Cordova like in some
games some years ago and then I tried to
move my knight so that we don't trade
light squared Bishops because if white
trades light scores white doesn't really
get a whole lot of anything but if white
can push E4 then white is very happy and
yeah we that's why we see her job of
thinking yeah Bishop H3 rookie one
Knight D2 is saying and then push E4
that's a way to just control the entire
Center and white would love to get the
pair of Bishops against two knights so
Bishop H3 if you do actually take on F3
white is quite happy even with the
ruined Pawn structure so rajava puts his
Bishop on A3 we'll see yifon either
slide The Rook over or play the move D6
but D6 gives white sometimes this option
of C5 and this is where things get messy
Levy I mean the pawn of C4 is supposed
to be a Target and it doesn't solve all
your problems to push the pawn to C5 but
it may make rajaba feel a little bit
more comfortable later in the game
by the way Bishop H3 on the board uh
yeah very very confused there why
machine was like somewhat unhappy with
uh with the move
that was played that was a D6 move I
guess it preferred some sort of rookie
eight but
it just seems very natural D6 and then
put a knight on D7 you know C7 C5 I feel
like this is the way black used to play
chess in the Queen's Indian maybe 20 30
years ago like before uh engine just
decided that the Queen's Indian is
garbage for black and completely refuted
it from from existence I just feel like
that this is how they used to grind down
players with the white pieces like they
would just play you know these these
positions against the double pause they
say what two Bishops who cares two
Bishops what else you know and
I but it's not the case anymore chess
has sort of moved on from the Queen's
Indian
yeah no you're and that's exactly what
people want C5 bring the Knight over to
A5 and just go after the C4 Pawn uh but
somehow with the bishop 183 Knight D2
which attacks the bishop also protects
the pawn C4 and white is just storming
forward with E4 so uh these players
are moving more slowly than you know we
typically see so why don't we go to the
opening of Arjun and uh
probably in here because they're just
getting underway and oh great timing for
that Levy H4 is the choice of our
generic IC yes this this has uh this has
an amazing history uh this H4 move it
was uh Joe Bava London so it was
probably it was probably D4 Knight F6
I wonder Robert can we go back can we
see how they got here I don't think
every guy see set out to play this I
think it was G6 on the second move yeah
yeah yeah yeah because I I every guy she
would not have played Knight C3 if the
move D5 had happened but um this is a
nice advantageous move order it's one of
the best weapons for intermediate and
beginner players in my opinion the
problem is that at the high level
I think Robert you you are more than
familiar with the theory here it's sort
of been totally neutralized but there's
these weird move orders Queen D2 and you
can like mess around with your opponent
in otherwise completely equal positions
yes these top players especially the top
top players they've stood this so
thoroughly and David paravian he is a
2600 plus Grandmaster you don't see him
necessarily in the round Robins like
Tata steel and all those events but he
played in all 25 rapid Chess
Championship events he played in the RCC
finals he earned his way here to the
global Championship so he studies chess
often he plays regularly he's really
good at rapid format so I bring that to
everyone's attention because he is
familiar with many different types of
openings and you see the Evo barf the
side saying that black is slightly
better ignore that for now both players
it's early stages Levy one of the common
plans F3 G4 let's make uh use of the
fact that this Pawn is a hook on H5
because White's King will likely go in
Castle queenside but that said black is
ready because C5 isn't played Black is
ready for an attack of his own
yeah exactly right I actually think I
had this exact position against Nicholas
theodoro a few months ago so criari as
he's known now he's a grand master in
fact he got his Grandmaster Norm by
beating me not in that game but in a
separate one I've had many many meetings
over the board with Theodore root seems
over the last year uh we had this
position and I think he played Knight C6
and we we very quickly traded a lot of
the pieces like the position here can
liquidate quite quickly uh if if white
is not careful so I'm I'm I am a little
bit perplexed by the opening choice just
because I thought that there was nothing
left here it felt like for a while that
the top players just took all the fruit
off the tree and no fruit was growing
anymore if black kind of knew the
opening and there there was going to be
absolutely no problems but uh that's why
it's always interesting with a really
strong player like every guy she shows
up with an opening that we thought was
dead because maybe he's going to
introduce some new idea or it will be a
hole in part of Young's repertoire yeah
and pravin he took quite a bit of time
to come up with the solution of
capturing on D4 first then playing
Knight C6 this is all good stuff but
Eric icy he has a simple plan and he I
think he senses the paravian doesn't
feel comfortable because paravian is a
bit of a system player now that's often
used in a derogatory way that oh he can
only play this that and the other thing
we've seen Maxine Buster Le Graf in many
ways the system player and yet he became
2800 plus so it's not an insult at all
it means he's very well versed at maybe
a more narrow repertoire so perovian
here he's not twirling his hair out so
it I think for now he's feeling quite
fine he's feeling all right he's looking
like a fashion model he's got the he's
got the sweater popping Eric I see
chilling in his hoodie you know what's
an interesting fact about
is the fact that his fide rapid rating
is his highest rating so his classical
to something like 2570 2580 but his fide
rapid is 26.50 it's actually his best
format which is rare I think I mean
rapid and Blitz fluctuate more the
rating change factor is double what it
is in classical chess but
still that's very impressive now Eric I
see you'll notice
is not going G4 yet but I do have to
tell you Robert your plan looks really
good the only reason he's not rushing it
is because his Knight in the center will
is destabilized by the Black Knight on
C6 but if he takes that Knight with his
bishop and plays G4
because not right away but in the future
it could be very unpleasant for black
and look at Arjun I mean the guy is just
chilling right here he's had a lot of
experience which is a strange thing to
say for a teenager but he's won the
junior speed Chess Championship which
means we'll see him in the main event
later this year and that's gonna be
awesome seeing our generic icy duke it
out with the likes of anishikiri and
karwana and those guys but he also has
shown that he is a tremendous force in
classical chess so there's no weakness
in Arjun eragisi's game at least in the
terms of time controls and as you said
about pravin he is actually better
relative to his classical strength at
rapid and he also studies very hard and
I know he's friends with some of those
top Russian Grandmasters like dubov and
so you know we'll see how that pays off
for him but he is deep in the think tank
right now I feel like
um Arjun just invokes fear in his
opponents these days because the guy
just seems Unstoppable yeah he does he
he definitely does I will also say Eric
icy suffers from the opposite effect a
lot of young talented Indian players
only play classical chess and they do
not play rapid in Blitz they don't play
a whole lot of those events and so Eric
ic's rapid rating is 24.50 which is
obviously not his playing strength his
playing strength is obviously probably
300 points higher than that but for a
while there was a lot of talented Indian
players who were 26 2700 In classical
but 1800 rapid
so it's kind of like the chat you know a
thousand points higher rated on their
puzzle rating it's except for these for
these guys who was in the slightly
different rating category
you it's funny because Fida is changing
the rules for that I'm sure you saw that
and it's because of all these players
you know when Prague Nanda was 1800 in
Rapid and beating people in the uh
Todd's still India wrapping Blitz events
kind of like all right it's not fair
that drawing
um probably played his sister who's a
very strong player International Master
vaishali they drew and she lost rating
because his rapid rating was so low I
guess and and that's why they changed it
because she was like I don't want to
lose points to my little brother like
uh well paravian I mean he doesn't want
to lose any points in this event and
he's really deep in the think tank Levy
he doesn't know what to do because you
made mention of Bishop takes C6 that is
arjun's idea because what black would
like to do is increase pressure here in
the center and go for a potential Queen
side attack uh the move Knight B4 I
think a lot of people would go for that
just simply attacking this Pawn on C2
but then this bishop can drop back to A4
where it defends that pawn and then the
Knight will be kicked out of B4 on the
next turn so it's like a one move threat
that looks very appealing but as soon as
white parries that threat it's kind of
like what was the point of that night
job the really interesting thing about
this position actually uh after let me
just make sure I I have the right spot
here yeah Bishop B5 this is why paravian
is thinking because actually in the
database up until that move black is
doing okay like this whole plan of
Bishop F5 seems to be quite quite stable
for black but believe it or not the
position that we are currently in why
does scoring very very well and the last
time it was played over the board at a
high level was Rahman of antipof and
that was last year in the Russian higher
league and white won that game uh then
you go back in 2021 this was played in
in late 2021 it was played in sethcus in
the tournament in in Spain and at 24 20
with white drew a 2630 with black so
that's it's not a lifetime
accomplishment but white is doing quite
well white is getting a good position
and this has only been reached a few
times and if it's in any indication
already Eric icy has spent no time
whatsoever and I don't think he doesn't
know the next five to seven moves in
multiple branches like I'm pretty sure
he knows everything this is a really bad
spot for David in game one it's horrible
and one thing I wanna one tactical point
I'll show this uh line briefly here if
we can bring an analysis board is the
move Rook C8 looks like the most logical
way to defend this Knight there's often
this trick where after it takes takes
Bishop A6 this Rook gets trapped but you
can see and this is what I was going to
mention this is not a good decision here
because you can the point is that if you
go like this The Rook is trapped in the
corner with uh an inability to get out
the Bishops are covering the squares but
the big problem that white is facing
here is that this B2 Pawn is loose
you're not castled so even if you make a
move like Rook to B8 and we get this
position you're gonna drop B2 and you're
gonna drop C2 there's also checks that
you have to worry about over here so
you're actually getting yourself in huge
trouble in a position like this with a
rook conjoinance team and queen takes B2
and you can already see black is winning
yeah yeah yep it's very very ridiculous
it looks like you're winning the
exchange but in reality the position
gets completely reversed uh let's check
in on uh on hoi fun if we can okay just
want to see what it when that what ended
up happening in that opening and how the
time management is going
uh oh I I for a moment I thought the
clocks were similar okay so this game
wow this looks like a dream position for
black
yeah you mean the back of the Pawn's on
D5 and you have these permanent issues
on C3 and C4 and black maybe you can
play F5 at some point you like all that
yeah and also Black's Queen is a
permanent problem going to A4 the White
Queen sort of has to stay home like if
the White Queen goes to like E2 for
example Queen A4 might come in
very very unpleasant it seems having
said that these top players it's never
over just because their position is
unpleasant doesn't mean you win the game
at all and it's I that's probably my
biggest weakness as a player I just get
complacent and when it comes time to
actually pushing the issue and maybe
taking the initiative in the position I
I'm not so good at that we okay and I
mean she plays F6 so she she's kind of
slow playing it uh and we could have
similar thing we had yesterday in the
game between Jew and June and a niche
where it was deadlocked and nobody was
going to give her away and they just
kind of Shuffle and make a draw which
for her in game one effortless draw with
black fantastic she'll definitely take
that but I don't think she's playing for
a drone I'm not you know thinking that
used to that either but F6 Rook F7 Rook
f8 what's this Rook doing on C8 you know
why the Rook Wednesday will go back a
few moves break up analysis board and
show you why this Rook is on C8 because
uh in this game right around here she
played Rook C8 Rook C1 and the point was
that at some moment there was going to
be a capture on D4 and the C4 Pawn is
going to be in trouble so then rajao
closed the center with D5 and that's why
the Rook is here but it's no longer
needed so as we continue down the path
the game took this Rook would like to be
on the opening file and what's that file
gonna be the f file this Knight Will hop
back things like that and finally black
who controls the pawn breaks in the
position will happily push to F5
this is seriously unpleasant the more I
look at it maybe white has a plan to
counteract an F5 at some point with F4
himself especially if she plays Knight
G7 because Knight G7 will remove the
knight from the F4 Square controlling it
at least
but
other than that I am really not sure I
feel like this the position here is uh
is only in in Black's favor basically if
black wants to push they can if not I
don't exactly know how white is going to
push the position and that is the
biggest struggle I find that when I play
games like look at this the eval is zero
so if rajabov knew with certainty is
zero he'd probably feel more at ease but
when you're playing a game practically
speaking it is so uncomfortable to be
like I see four different options for my
opponent and precisely none for myself
because what is White's plan I can't
think of even a single one honestly yep
honestly I don't know Rook F1 F4 doesn't
make any doesn't make
to be honest like you can convince
yourself that it's a decent plan the
thing is if white can play F4 and then
F5 like in torpedo chess
which is a legitimate variant by the way
available only at chess.com variants
everybody should check it out uh Rook F1
F5 would be sick
the problem is that uh that's not
possible but you know Robert the more I
look at that
I'm starting to convince myself it's not
so bad
how is black gonna deal with Rook F1
that's a good question because the
rook's not doing anything on E1 so Rook
F1 trying to play for F4 the evil Bar
says yeah neutral move I like it and you
actually have come up with the plan so
especially if this Knight does hop back
to G7 the F4 push is available and this
configuration of pieces I'll put them in
green because they're actually pretty
decent protecting C4 and E4 so it's not
like bringing a rook to E8 will be
threatening in the slightest so F4 does
become available now it's a double-edged
sword you push your F Pawn your king
becomes a little bit less safe but I
don't see an attack brewing for black so
I think that ephon should have to figure
out how to meet this kind of idea about
rajabov he plays Knight to B3 so is he
giving up the C4 Pawn I mean I think you
can get away with capturing it wow if he
can successfully get away with getting
rid of that pawn that would be
incredible
that would be that would be huge is he
trying for like Knights I'll just put
this quick on board and go back like is
he trying for something like this to
provoke B5 because after it takes takes
it's like Knight A5 and Knight C6 and
things of this nature
I think there's
definitely possibility for him to create
counter play with with the Knight that
he just sent out because otherwise
you just lose upon the the good thing
for White is you have another one you
have another Pawn that would happily
take the rank of the currency for Pawn
uh and maybe black is just totally
unable to to capture which really makes
me wonder then
what is the best move here for black if
you can't is it something like Queen A4
and try to get back on if it was it
Knight B7 and
I don't want to play an ip7 but
but it does have serious Merit I mean
you're just avoiding the trade and then
you can play on the king side but it's
such a weird position because Black's
pieces while they're putting pressure on
C4 and she does in fact take the pawn
wow they would be offside if you're
playing Knight B7 moves so Knight takes
A5 Bishop takes D3 will be played and
there's no useful night jump to you know
gain the tempo so you could take back so
what we'd likely see there is the trade
of all minor pieces and I guess ifan's
claiming I'm not worse here
the real question is what does White's
move right this second is it Queen A6 is
it Queen B5
is it
neither of those moves is it C4 okay
it's Queen A6 and the computer isn't uh
it's fine this position is I I mean the
bar likes to go low depth bounce and
then it kind of regroups but yeah
exactly Queen A5 Rook B7 all these
different ideas
you know Robert if this is a Blitz game
you just play like Queen H3 F5 yeah
right and go for checkmate oh but it
doesn't I mean you lose your D6 Pawn so
I think black's best move is F6 to F7
like close your seventh Rank and it
makes your king feel a little bit safer
but at the same time it's like white has
pieces to attack with you can bring your
Bishop to H6 it's a one move threat
doesn't exactly threaten Checkmate so
yes if on she's hanging in there very
well and on the clock as well as on the
board just oh should we go to the uh
yeah other game I just noticed that it
looks like Arjun is trying to Checkmate
his opponent so we're gonna switch games
here go to the one between Arjun
aragaisy and David paravian and there is
a oh okay okay we just have to quickly
go through the last two years Knight
takes E5 yeah giving up this Pawn on D5
for the pawn E5 and Arjun says yeah I
don't want your Pawn Yeah
let's go bring all my pieces into the
party and go from the switch yeah this
is so brutal like I said every guy say
Obviously familiar with the ideas and
this is really the problem of when you
get caught in preparation you spend all
this time Conjuring up with defense and
none of it happens it's it's the worst
feeling in the world you spend all this
time analyzing your opponent's responses
and none of them come true because they
know all of the moves in the position
it just sucks you know all the moves are
needed here for white to continuous
attack because black currently has a
couple pawns uh for the unsafe King so
how does he deliver the Checkmate that's
the big question for Arjun right now is
obviously his position looks menacing
he's going right after that King on G8
but where's the knockout
FG Bishop G4 Knight E4
is that is it that's my guess is that is
that right
it is good wow
yeah wow that's a bit of a problem and
Levy is saying that you can take the
Knight on e4 but you lose your queen on
d8 and after something like this well we
could see the evil Sky High for white by
the look of it Levy it doesn't seem
completely lost for black it obviously
looks not great but it doesn't look
totally hopeless yeah I was that was
actually going to be my concern here
like when I first suggested this I'm
like I win a queen I'm winning but you
can't end your thoughts after ah I'm up
a queen I'm winning because you're also
down two pawns a knight and a rook
actually you have less material
technically it's 10-9 for for the other
guy uh yeah I guess I guess Rook G1 H5
yeah yeah this King just can't get out
of here and you can always take this
Knight in C6 if that's gonna bother you
but you get rooked you on H5 and the
king is ruined so instead he puts H5
right away and uh oh that's an
inaccuracy I understand why he did it
he's just going straight for the king
but this king is being saved by the
queen coming over to a square like G7 uh
oh this could be bad news for all the
Indian fans and for origin Air Guys in
particular yeah absolutely this is this
is very very dangerous stuff because if
his attack burns out then he's just
going to be down material with nothing
to show for it uh if the Queens get off
the board this is a much better position
for black it's a completely winning
position for black frankly uh because
the structure is so solid black has
really done nothing wrong black is just
sort of relaxing and uh White is just
going bananas and throwing everything
forward so White's got to give mate
white white has absolutely no
alternative there's no bailout here I
really wonder what the best move here is
um it's probably still FG but I don't
know
yeah you could take on G6 just to open
up more Lines by the way I'm only first
known since David profit is two minutes
and two seconds so uh if he is able to
play quickly maybe he's a chance to
survive but if every single defensive
move takes him a while to calculate
he'll have no shot and F takes G played
by Arjun best move suggested by you oh
my goodness
that's Savage HG is an idea after Bishop
takes D1 this is the issue with the
position is that one inaccuracy will not
sink the ship black has absolutely zero
time to react
and
I yeah this is very stressful probably
Knight E5 just to defend this bishop
over here it also defends the G6 square
but that's a difficult move to play
because after 95 there's E1 there's Rook
F1 you have so many things to calculate
so many things the calculator is Right
90 seconds now for black at some point
David is gonna start getting more and
more
um how to say it like animated on camera
it's going to start with hair Twirls
it's going to start with you now he's
talking to himself he's sort of like I
think he I think he understands that he
probably is not getting blown off the
board the problem is he has a minute
like you have to move you can't just
claim you're not losing you have to make
moves and every move you're risking
making something worse 95 wow I think
that was the best move it it looks like
it and he took too long to play it
that's the only issue with the move 95
took him a minute to play he's a great
bullet player by the way so there's the
two second increment he has a full Min
on the clock but he's also playing one
of the best speed chess players on the
sorry one of the best players on the
planet and then one particularly one of
the best speed chess he beat nihal sarin
in the speeches Championship Finals so
Arjun Air Guys he needs a little
introduction these days and look at him
on screen here he's just like chilling
just he's like ah okay yeah so some of
the some of these guys are just
unbelievably relied even over the board
he looks like that and it's it's just
fascinating he makes moves with like no
time on the clock super fast rookie one
is a great move keeping the tension
Knight F3 does look like a fork but it
probably loses after Rook G4 and then
Knight E1 and HG there's no checks by
some ridiculous
geometry
oh my gosh I guess 39 seconds yeah it's
tough even if we reverse the clocks I
still think white could win this game
right like the King on G8 is really uh
in a world of hurt here and the Rooks
are not doing anything for black I I
really don't see a move right now yes
the only thing is that if White had 40
seconds I think he would be much more
inclined to suffer in a tiny bit worse
end game he would just when you have 40
seconds your brain's like you got to
simplify time trouble makes you do
ridiculous things
um in this case man I mean best move
best move but he has 16 seconds like
every bus every best move has eaten 70
of his clock time I'm with you buddy I
mean it's just Queen F4 attacking Knight
wow Knight C6 all right he's he's
understanding the position better that's
why I spent all that time is so he could
find the resources needed just to
survive and he's doing that for now but
oh my gosh more pressure here there
everywhere
yes but no threats
yeah
it's confusing yeah but I don't think
white wants to lose the Knight well
Queen G4 yeah but see but see the guy
with no time is looking to simplify the
position
and see now this might come like I don't
know I don't know what the best move
here maybe it's Queen H6 Queen G7 Queen
D2 something like that like
something like that yeah
I think Arjun does need to find the best
moves right now he just needs to find
the tricky moves yep
yep you never trade Queens here I mean
it's also just not a good move but
regardless you just never take the Queen
ever unless you're winning a full piece
yeah you are and no chance our generic
guys he's thinking about that but yeah
you raise a good point that sometimes
you want to bring the queen in to lure
the black queen back so I could see
Queen H6 being the move Queen F3 Queen
D2 all sorts of moves here but if you're
not careful black will take on D3 play
Knight B4 and sort of Survive by
attacking in a way but with uh the King
on G8 here and H6 G6 on tap it's it's
looking still so difficult I mean how
how are you gonna play this position
with nine seconds on the clock it's just
it's uh it's rough to be honest with you
this is how I lose to David part of you
on entitled Tuesday I might have a
position that's balanced and I'm he
might be attacking me but I have nine
seconds and he has two and a half
minutes and I'm telling you it's a
disgusting feeling like it's just you
feel terrible but Robert you you get
into time trouble how would you survive
this position with nine seconds well I'm
just distracted by Providence hair
twirling he's I mean
he's in his his best shape there he is
just
picking his hair off of his head but how
do you survive a position like this uh
honestly what he's doing has been great
thus far he's creating threats of his
own so the queen trade is not you know
it's not going to be on the board but
it's like okay as Bishop takes D3
something I need to worry about is this
Knight going to come back to E5 if I
take on G6 and the bishop isn't on F5
can black push with F5 uh himself I'm
just gonna you know okay Queen G3 I
don't even have time to show anything
but Queen G3 makes sense going for G6
and here's Knight B4 going after this D3
Pawn he is creating counter threats here
and now he's over 10 seconds he's doing
so quickly yeah but HG Knight D3 king
queen F4
oh that's that's so filthy Robert has
Queen F4 I think can be one can be one
yeah that's right Queens yeah but I get
like Rook G3 with some g-pawn
because I want to go I'll just we'll
show that HG Queen F4 check is my idea
because if it takes we take on D3 and as
you see black gets the queen back with
interest so
yeah this is a big moment for Arjun here
you know Queen F4 is so gross I thought
I might still have a little something
after missing queen F4 but King D2 what
a move by origin era Gracie
he just lost immediately yeah
yeah
there's too many problems here wow King
D2 was incredible and and you see I I
don't I'm not sure part of the
unexpected it I I just yeah you see him
shaking his head it's just
that's it oh but it's not the forcing
Checkmate that I thought it was you can
even have to blunder here because the
queen covers the G1 Square so if they're
here and takes I thought this king would
have to like run back and take this Pawn
but you don't have Rook G1 I'm drawing a
lot of arrows I'll show it after the
game but with private every three
seconds what if white just starts with
A3
oh my gosh that would be such a nasty
move in your opponent's time trouble
yeah that's just not nice you might also
just have Rook H1 Rook h a queen C7
somehow
do you have quincy queen C7 and
rookie six maybe that's what I was
thinking about but I wasn't sure I
Checkmate the black king and it made me
a little nervous but yeah he does he
does not need to do that unless he
absolutely is sure he has made
he can also play Rook takes E6 right
away oh Robert Rook H1 Rook h8 Queen C7
King F6 rookie six king of King E6 Queen
F7 King D6 Knight B5
oh we will show all
Levy very intelligent intelligently
excuse me drag this Rook away so you get
this queen to F7 but rookies there has
to be a Checkmate right I mean rookie
six is much simpler but where's the so
rookie seven check uh King has to go to
GA because the Google up here is Queen
G5 made
uh just play a move that just Queen H
[Music]
[Laughter]
I guess Queen H3 and then you
you somehow aren't you know mated
I don't know
thank God I don't have to finish this
off can you imagine losing this with
white oh my God you would probably throw
the whole laptop against the computer
against the wall
you you were calling our generic I see a
very calm yeah if he loses this game
weighs 5 minutes to 3.5 seconds and a
winning attack yeah you just break
everything
what maybe maybe even Rook F7 wait no
it's Checkmate oh it's just made
one yeah probably in laughs he's like
yeah I can't play like this having four
seconds there's also checkmate with
Queen D6 like he walked into Checkmate
two different ways here oh yeah the king
F6 was just I like visually I did not
even like look at this move at all uh
oh all right well
this moment here right apparently it the
game was still uh possible to defend
here maybe you need to just bring his
Queen back I say just as if that's a
easy choice but you're gonna have this
captioning G6 anyway your king is gonna
be uh attacked regardless so yeah
okay and we're getting word that
hoefan's game against team overjobo has
also concluded that game finished in a
draw so yeah
Levy the other game maybe not quite as
exciting in terms of tactics uh but a
great result for yifon
yeah uh very very solid result and this
is quite a position by the way to uh
agree to a draw seems like there's still
a bit of Life honestly but okay draws a
very decent result in our generic I
could not have asked for a better start
I mean he spent four minutes basically
on the clock that game had felt like
truly he blitzed out a ton of
preparation he got a really solid
position and now he has
the opportunity to repeat the exact same
opening in the next game that he has
with white like when you find a weakness
you absolutely go and exploit it so
these are our current I guess scores
after just the first rapid game holifan
now will take the white pieces
um when uh when in in game two against
Timo rajabov and David paravion is going
to have to basically forget that game
ever happen Robert
yeah that's easier said than done it's
got to be a goldfish make Ted lasso
proud but right now Levy I think we're
gonna head to a quick break and we'll
return more here from these matches in
the opening round of the chess.com
Global championship
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
to anyone
all around the world the chess.com
Global Championship offers the dream of
playing against the best
and hey have we mentioned there's also a
million dollars at stake total pot is a
million dollars no that is not a typo
the prizes are unbelievably generous we
began with thousands of players now only
dozens remain there it is oh my God Eric
Hanson this is crazy Eric Hansen moves
on to the round of 32 in Armageddon
fashion
cgc knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real okay one second
boom
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends it's the cgc round of 64. who
will take the next step to Toronto
2022 chess.com Global Championship today
is our third day of action and we are
covering the games of the round of 64.
uh we just finished the first rapid game
of the best of four in two matchups the
matchup between Tema rajab and hoefan as
well as arjunary gaisi versus David
paravian but a little bit later in the
show we're gonna have janiponishu versus
Muhammad muradli from Azerbaijan we're
gonna have another a player from
Azerbaijan we've got a stacked
Azerbaijan card here we'll have Shakira
mizero taking on vladislav kovalev and
we also have Peter Fiddler taking on
Alexis shirov we have all of group E and
as we like to do in these knockout
rounds we like to sprinkle in a little
bit of dessert there group group b one
matchup from Group B and Group B will be
finishing I believe it is tomorrow and
if it's not tomorrow then it's later
today so
uh Robert what are your impressions so
far of the first two rapid games that we
saw
well you couldn't ask for a better start
from our generic geissi he gets an
opening that he knows extremely well and
he has David perovian on his back foot
so even more important than the win
perhaps is the way he won it's like
pravin probably felt like he had no
chance and that's a really good sign for
the higher rated player and in the
matchup that's starting right now we
have ifan and rajava getting into game
two I think that ifan should be thrilled
she put a very solid game with the black
pieces rajabov never had an ounce of an
advantage and so she gets white in game
two and we get an auntie Berlin yeah wow
no Berlin
I actually did anticipate that she that
uh rajaba would be playing Berlin but I
I didn't know I thought maybe maybe Raja
will have some sort of uh mildly offbeat
weapon in in the real Lopez that he
might kind of bust out but now he he
he's a kind of a very consistent guy
also kind of like Hikaru like Hikaru if
he's If You're Gonna Play rui and he
just wants to stabilize and play White
he will play Berlin he's not gonna
change anything because Berlin is
unbreakable but
this D3 C3 stuff has become Ultra trendy
oh D5 yeah this move is very popular
right now
it is and well when you say right now
that's the keywords in your sentence to
me because how much does yifon know like
is she keeping up with all the chess I
did mention she's playing in the Chinese
chess league but sometimes you you know
you have to play some obligations you
play the tournament but you haven't
really studied up so you know Shiba is
Knight D2 which is the principle of
reply but does she know the ins and outs
of these positions because some of the
top players have found themselves in a
world of trouble in venturing into these
variations
yeah especially venturing into D5 I
would imagine which is ultra Ultra Sharp
uh what is your I know basically nothing
here theoretically so what I I know the
general ideas but it's Knight bd2 the
main line yeah it's it's uh very popular
move here and black often takes on e4 so
there are two paths this kind of
variation can go down it can go down one
of those uh lines where it's just pretty
calm and you're just shuffling your
pieces trying to find the optimal
squares but D5 is so committal because
if this Knight on C6 is captured at some
moment then this Pawn on E5 will be
loose so oftentimes black will take on
e4 you know protect this Pawn on D6 and
just play a very standard way but you
don't have to be so concerned Bishop
takes C6 even though it doubles your
pawns because having the pair of Bishops
would be advantageous for black so
there's always little nuances that go
into this and Levy what do you make of
the fact that her job off is the one who
played D5 and now is thinking after
night V to D2 that's really strange
uh I mean if Knight bd2 is the most
common move he might he must just be
deciding which way to take the position
because a guy like rajabov knows and can
talk about the popular responses for
black after Knight pd2 for hours he
could be like oh yeah there was a game
recently here and there and a lot of
these top players don't just follow
their colleagues games they follow games
with 25 and 2600s because players at
that level are more than capable of
coming to the table with some very very
nice theoretical ideas in these random
open tournaments A5 okay so to my
untrained eye that move stops white from
playing the move B4 and it also frees up
the A7 Square for the bishop or the
Knight
but is that the is that is that theory
because that move looks super weird it
might be Theory but I can't remember if
this is the game between the job of is
White against Hikaru it looks kind of
similar in the sense that uh at some
point this bishop dropped back to A7 and
rajal stole the A5 pawn and won that
game uh I don't think it's the exact
same line though but either way this
Pawn A5 it's one of those moves that
does look appealing I get the reason why
and in that game with Hikaru this Knight
went back to A7 and then ventured back
towards C6 but javov
um you know different variation
different game but Queen E7 was his
choice and I tend to like these
positions for white I think it's just
the maneuvering is pretty natural and
you have no weaknesses to speak of
you are completely correct that
absolutely was the game rajab of
Nakamura from the candidates the move A5
was the move that Hikaru played he's
actually played it many times he's
played it five times uh and uh vidit
Gujarati has also played it a lot of
times so but you know what's amazing
about this line after the move A5 my
database shows
82 games right but not a single player
over 2500 played this until about five
six years ago
which is wild
wow and uh
yeah and one of the first kind of top
guys to play it was Vladimir kramnik hmm
okay
amazing no wonder it became trendy
kromnik plays in how everyone wants to
play it he's making fetch happen so uh
you know
and then we have Vladimir back he won
his first match in the global
Championship he defeated crunch mokumia
three nil it was a clean sweep so great
to see Vladimir back at the chessboard
or on the online chessboard yeah not not
quite the chess board but listen I think
world rapping in Blitz or something he
will definitely play he uh
he is a force to be reckoned with he he
gives me the vibe of a of a potentially
retired athlete who just shows up to the
basketball gym and is dunking shooting
threes posting up he got that you know
he got that retired man strength he's
not I guess he's not completely retired
from Over the board play but uh I think
who said it about kramnik that we've
been playing his opening ideas for
decades now somebody said that I might
have been Anand but I don't want to put
words into anybody's mouth but I mean
kramnik left such a lasting impact on
the world of Chess and evidently
continues to This Day 2017 was the first
time that this was played at an elite
level yeah no he's an absolute legend of
the game and it's true you know all
these top players they they gain so many
insights from chromic and oftentimes
it's not even what you see over the
board like let's say an opening is
played one time then people start
studying in and realize oh there's all
this underlying uh Theory and Concepts
that I can learn from and just the first
person to play it is the person who
gives it to everyone else so uh by the
way Bishop A4 was just played by hoefan
and it seems like a strange move but I
think she wants to play Knight C4 and a
turn ago actually done that there's
Knight A7 and this bishop is trapped
because if you go Bishop A4 there's B5
so I think it started with Bishop A4 so
she could bring her night out at some
point yeah and then maybe 93 Bishop E3
and so on we're gonna let them uh have a
moment here to digest the middle game we
have our second matchup which is David
paravian versus argenteric icy this one
is a okay a slav defense by is he gonna
play semi or is he gonna keep it open
with DC semi-sloff
and what's interesting is paravian spent
27 seconds to play Knight C3 so he was
in time trouble a game ago it's still
very early here he's got plenty of time
obviously and he's just trying to figure
out which variation to go down but I'm
looking at every move of he's like you
gotta keep Pace with Arjun and look at
Arjun playing this triangle variation
where the bishop on C8 is pretty much
useless for the time being white has a
lead in development but for in the long
term with the bishop hair that's where
black is trying to make his mark
yeah exactly I've played this a few
times myself with white it it looks
really nice visually but it's a very
tough position to crack open and the
thing is that you gave black the two
Bishops so black is always very happy
with moves like DC4 or C5 E5 just in in
some capacity some sort of Pawn breaks
uh and black could even turn this
completely around on white and play G5
G4 not not right now but it's definitely
an idea like white has Knight E4 here uh
black as Bishop before check to get out
of that situation yeah Queen E7
gonna have to put his foot down he's
like I'm not gonna get bullied because
that first game was
Arjun being a juggernaut that was one of
the most convincing games I think we've
seen it was
at least in in my two days of commentary
we saw nojarbeck win a very beautiful
game yesterday against Boris girlfriend
but Arjun used the clock and you know
clock is a piece so we'll see if para
Vienna can strike back in this game but
he's already down one minute
yeah and I think I really like the way
you frame that you know Arjun is a
juggernaut and he did bully paravian and
paravian he knows he's in a normal
position he probably recognizes I should
be a slight Edge but the problem at this
top levels you know if you don't
maximize immediately your opponent
neutralizes and then you have no
Advantage so when Providence looking at
this he goes okay is E5 about to happen
and if that's the case and some trades
will that help black C5 going to happen
he plays with A3 which is a good move by
the way uh does he want to play B4
probably not that playing to Black's
hands but it's a very calm move it
allows the bishop to retreat to A2 and
the event is attacked so I like the
starting move A3 from him but what is
his plan Levy you said you've played
these uh this type of position before
what is white supposed to do here
that's a really good question
uh I mean obviously if black is taken on
C4 you you always are considering the E4
E5 events the the thing about lazy moves
and kind of like Queen C2 bringing Rooks
to the center is that at some point
if you haven't set your pieces up the
right way quietly E4 is not going to
work and also black will successfully
Strike Back in the center with something
like E5 so David has to make sure that
he's setting up the right way here for
the long term uh of course black doesn't
have a knight on F6 so uh rotating the
bishop around and getting it behind the
queen and checkmating the guy on H7 is a
vague possibility maybe if you cut their
ratings in half in this case it's not
going to happen and you obviously see
every guy see already plays E5 so B4
paravian even plays the move E4 there's
E5 now E4 for white probably doesn't
even make as much sense what do you
think I mean I'd rather put a knight
there or something else yeah if he's the
type of position where a lot of people
would be tempted to capture on E5 but
after he takes D4 why couldn't play e
takes D4 I know we tend to hate isolated
pawns but it opens up the e-file and
Rooks where a win excuse me stare Downs
against Queens so e takes D4 not the
most threatening of options
um I would not play E4 that's for sure
from White's perspective I think I'll
just bring a rook towards the center
probably a rook to D1 Rook E1 is too
obvious you know I'm not going to take
if you play Rook E1 I'm not going to
take you on D4 because I see exactly
what you're planning and you want to
gain some time against this queen but I
think Rook D1 makes perfect sense
because maybe in the future you played
D5
Rook 81 or Rook fd1 what are you
thinking I think we're 81 just to leave
the E1 Square available to the F1 Rook
if black does in fact take on D4 but I
don't know if what is black what's
Black's next move I think that's the
question we should ask it's a great
question uh it might be Knight F6 and
then he just doesn't care about trading
uh his dark squared Bishop away on the
E5 Square
interesting I I'm not sure other than
that I'm really not sure what his next
move is because Knight F6 is also a
Temptation by Knight H4 because I can't
play it now but imagine Queen takes H4
is not possible so we'll just pretend
that's illegal I'm threatening Knight G6
and Knight F5 that's why this bishop on
C4 is so strong but of course I gave
away at night so I'm saying if you
cannot legally take this Knight on H4
then that would be a good move so anyway
94 was played and now Arjun
does he care
does he care about Knight takes D6
it's a great question
um my first instinct was to go King h8
and try to play for F5
but that might be way too way too much
and also I think white can play Knight
G3 there
which
gets to the F5 Square before you have a
chance to play F5 there's also Knight H4
like if I had a free move oh yeah you
really want to get an issue and now it
makes sense because it distracts the
queen from this bishop of course you
know I have to deal with this capture uh
Knight takes D4
possible here but I still like e takes
D4 and Rook D1
yeah eg4 looks very smart
but if Black is Black it's like two more
moves to consolidate he will never be
worse so
David's got to make some make some
questions get answered right now
I'm not sure though
and he does I'm not sure the hair
twirling starting earlier in this game
yeah I mean there's another option which
is to play like Rook 81 now or Knight
takes D6
and then Rook 81 just sort of
try to but Black's next move is Knight
F6 or Knight E5 and
getting the bishop out not only are you
getting the night out you're also
getting the bishop out I'm sinking lower
into my chair just trying to make this
work for black like I just don't know I
mean for for white
it's such a frustrating position because
black has no weaknesses that and it's
what you are indicating right that if
black just gets these two moves to get
all the pieces out where is White going
to seize an initiative from and the
answer might be nowhere and he does take
on D6 quickly and he can take on D4 he
can play your Rook D1 move both look
pretty tempting but as you also
mentioned Knight E5 will offer some more
trades
exactly I don't I don't know what's next
here for David what what is the
stockfish evaluation by the way I can't
quite see it it looks balanced but it
looks like it slightly prefers white
yeah 0.3 so a whole lot of nothing is
how yeah top jams with you know arjun's
like yeah that's nothing I'll equalize a
few moves
yep point three is kind of
it's a vanity number you just like ah
I'm paulus point three show it whereas
it's or as people in the chat would say
white is winning yes exactly wow he
blundered what a bad opening by origin
yeah
anyway uh is uh let's should we check in
on uh our other game Let's Do It Let's
see if that one's getting more excited
we're going with the hoi fun game
against uh Timor rajav and here we go
uh-oh uh oh is
potentially right
it feels like white is like it feels
like black got more moves in this game
than white did
well that's what happens when you play
Bishop A4 rookie one oh
wait
oh oh Bishop C5 wow I mean Bishop F2 oh
I was like what is that that's a free
Pawn but it's a trick takes yeah and
queen file check picking up this bishop
wow look at the listen they don't call
him Timor tactics or Jabba for nothing I
don't I think I just gave him that
nickname but uh
B5 look at that move you're actually I
mean you're completely right like the
bishop moved multiple times four times
oh my god let's move four times and it
moved four times in a like six move
window so
that's are three times in a five minute
window I should say so yeah now the
Knight is infiltrating Knight G3 is
annoying so that's why the Knight came
back to F1 covering F4 and G3 this
bishop can come to A6 but white can
Parry that with Bishop to C4 so it's not
like white is losing despite the minus
one evaluation I actually think this is
a type position where if you're not
really accurate and playing actively you
lose your entire advantage in a few
moves is Knight F4 the bus move here for
black
very well could be although I would be a
bit nervous to make that move because
you allow white to
take in the play Rook D1 and things like
that and then later in the game black
could just be worse because you have a
double Pawn
yeah it's really a question of does that
does does getting a black pawn there
from E5 to F4 restrict the F1 Knight
sufficiently to compensate for having
the double pawns or did you just rush
and were you not supposed to do that I
don't know
I don't know there might be some other
absurd ideas here like Rook to the sixth
Rank and rotating over to G6 that's a
frequent idea in some of these positions
like Rook D6 Rook A6
I don't know
the biggest problem that black has is
sort of what you were mentioning with
the pawn F4 is this Knight is dominant
but it's Pawn on C3 and look at that uh
rajab makes one very natural move
attacking the queen of his bishop and
his entire Advantage according to the
evaluation bar is gone like yeah but but
Bishop C4 like what is his plan after
Bishop C4
oh is there Bishop F2 there no there's
not because Knight E3 at the end but
yeah I think there's no this looks like
a tempting option on the show Bring up
the analysis board and Bishop takes F2
check would be good if not for this
Knight on F1 so Bishop F2
you can't take with the queen because
wait it says equal
what
this can't work so King takes Queen C5
Knight to E3
let F4 and Knight F4 oh it continues it
looks like it's uh wait oh Bishop takes
A6
oh white has this no but this also
doesn't look clear at all three pieces
for a queen yeah what what
[Laughter]
guess it's hard this is happening dude
this is all happening Bishop F2 yes
wow
oh Knight T3 oh
what's the material count black has one
Pawn for the piece this queen is gonna
look like uh Danny wrench of Robert Hass
against the chest bras in a second and
then the see-through Punk can be
captured the E4 Pawn is loose all of it
seems to be wow what an epic idea from
rajabov look at that just
computer-like play to be honest just
sacrificing a piece for Tempo on
restricting a queen to the corner of the
board
followed by just like a recapture of a
pawn and just winning a pawn and just
saying yeah my position's better wow
how much do you believe in it like I'm
into it right now but I'm always nervous
of these kind of sacrifices because I
feel like you know I make one just
casual looking move and then suddenly
I'm down a piece for just a couple Pawns
I really don't I don't like what where
White's Queen is going
I'm really bad at untangling from
positions like this with white but just
visually speaking I I
I would hate to play White here just
because
like how do you move what do you move
and how do you move will white have to
play King g3 at some point
yeah I think that's why the queen should
go to G1 just to put the Queens in the
same diagonal if you're going to be up a
piece for some pawns King G no Queen G1
King G3 and then a night move is
threatened so
if honest thinking here is why what
could possibly be the benefit of Queen
H1 over Queen G1
maybe King G1 King H2 which doesn't want
to go to G3 I I I'm really I'm not I'm
not I'm not sure that's funny that
that'll be a very sad Queen uh for a
bunch of moves and maybe bishop takes E4
is not the threat maybe there's okay
there is B take C3 as you mentioned
follow Queen takes C3 but there's Bishop
D2 at the end of those positions to save
The Rook could she possibly be
considering rookie too
oh
maybe I don't think so but
what else could you possibly spend time
on here
no I don't answer that like my my
instinct is Queen G1 it might be a
terrible Instinct but uh I'm just trying
to go like this and say I have a piece
let's go yeah but as we know it's much
easier to move your uh pieces of the
games you're spectating
oh absolutely no
I'm I'm trying to lose the game but I'm
going
and also your Rook D6 Rook G6 idea is
not out the window right it's a king on
G3 so no it's inviting that it's
anything but out the window at the end
of the day white does have more pieces
that can do things like white has six of
them two knights bishop and then Rook
two Rooks and the queen but uh
slowly pawns will fall
I really don't want to leave and go
check on the other game this game is
exciting all right she does play Queen
G1 I don't like the hesitancy I I would
have loved to see if she just blitzed it
out and was like yeah
yeah yeah you think you you think you're
gonna just sacrifice a piece
she's a problem three minutes yeah
that's that's tough and like I I don't
think she's come up with a move here she
knew Bishop oh Robert mm-hmm
and I'm looking at this position it's I
see the eval I think I'm more nervous
for black than I am for white like I
don't see a Checkmate I don't see a way
to gain back a ton of material Knight G4
is the next move which offers a queen
trade attacks this bishop puts pressure
on E5 I'm not saying that black is
actually worse but it's just the type of
position where down the line black is
the one who could be in more trouble
than white can we just uh
we shouldn't Pat ourselves on the back
here for finding Queen G1 King G3 I like
honestly I I'm very excited we we both
kind of agreed that you have to line the
Queens up so that that way you can trade
them off and it's better than putting
the queen in the corner King King G3 is
such a Savage move but somehow it came a
bit naturally they're like it's it's the
move that you're supposed to you you
have to play that move because you're
gonna get your king to safety but you
also need to trade Queens with black and
she found it and I think her job of is
probably like really like he has that
that facial expression on look at him
he's like yeah wait is that is that
really what's Happening Here the Kings
on G3 I can't do anything about it yeah
I mean if black plays F5 you just play
King H2 and
you're down a piece Bozo like you know
what I mean like like I I don't know I
don't know I don't know what the best
move is here for original like I would
play at five and then I would probably
go on to lose the game I it's just it's
a very very tough position I'm not sure
yeah he's probably thinking about do I
get to capture on C3 then I get three
pawns for the piece right so three pawns
is about uh the equivalent of a piece
and if you take on C3
um white can take back of course on
see-through as well you could consider
Knight G4 so there's so many different
variations to work out here uh because
sorry that was a me just didn't realize
click on the piece this kind of position
doesn't look great because my idea with
Bishop D2 you can just capture this on
D2 and you get a lot of pieces for uh
so what do you have here you have at the
end of this what is this a knight sorry
a a bishop for and three pawns for a
rook I can't count
yeah yeah yeah I should have been three
points for right too much black is
better so that's why you wouldn't
recapture on C3 for white but if you
make them like Knight G4 all of a sudden
we see the position says zeros anything
but just a dead draw a lot going on here
and the queen trade might be unavoidable
yeah but after Knight G4 what happens if
we trade queens and I take on B2 and
play a oh the oh there's a bishop
hanging in the center of the board yeah
I think I was gonna take this way
oh
oh that's a problem yeah I was gonna
take on F3 and play F6
right and just be extra solid but I'm
it's and you don't have this tactic with
Bishop G2 because Rook D2 check looks
like it wins back your piece but that's
what the Knight ng1 is doing protecting
the E2 Square so what an absurd position
I mean rajav just
came to came to fight in this game with
black
he did but I mean if I'm looking if I'm
reading into their body language
correctly like your fans like oh I'm
curious about this this is interesting
and my job is like wait what the heck
happened like this should be really good
for me yep
absolutely
he's uh he's probably very important I
mean look at his time he he had six and
a half minutes he's burned more than 50
of his clock time on this very move and
he's only getting closer to the webcam
yeah he's very concentrated right now
both players are uh great to see these
two slugging it out because in recent
years they haven't played that much and
when they do play look at the games we
get there's a king on G3 yep
oh there's a king on G3
I wonder if he'll play F5
but this King just runs away no
no F5 he does play F5 it is a very
natural move the problem is I I don't
know what's next
okay well I think we know what's next
for a white king H2 right I mean there's
nothing else there could be a night move
of some sort as well like where Knight
C2 Knight F1 Knight D1 something like
that but I would say the big issue is
that when Levy was highly
oh
she just gives back the night oh
how many Night Moves Knight takes night
takes night takes two different nights
but what's the material it's even
material H6 is loose E5 is isolated
and the King on G3 it's safe
yeah wow can we go back was that the
best move or was King H2 also possible
just keeping the piece and
let's see so after after F5
oops sorry I'm
I went too far ahead so after F5 Knight
F1 is apparently the best move but it
says
not too you know slightly say 0.3 for
white so the night and night move uh
backwards seems to have been an option
that would have left away a little bit
ahead but how can you blame her there's
no risk here and oh a mistake from her
job off and stuff yeah she's just better
yeah yeah what she's just yeah he's uh
it's very very tough to say work he was
supposed to move his Bishop I mean I
don't understand maybe he was supposed
to move it to like F5 to to keep the or
D5 and keep the G file open like King H7
Rook G8 oh that that seems exactly what
he should have done but she always had
Bishop G5
the thing is Rook D3 check doesn't even
win this Pawn because of Rook E3 so now
she's just up and pawn yep
that was an insane position man that was
uh that was an extremely complicated
position wow
and what rajaba was counting on now is
the fact that they're opposite colored
Bishops but they're Knights on the board
Rook you can't just say opposite color
Bishop draw no white also has two on
none here white is up a pawn overall but
it's like White's up two Pawns in the
king side and black is up one Pawn in
the center so that's the dynamic that we
have
yeah exactly right and she's playing for
a win I mean she's just of course
probably most likely result is is draw
but
she is definitely pushing pushing for
win here you wanna you wanna just very
briefly check in on paravian and then
Eric I see I feel like we've sort of let
them handle their business this round
but
here well
yeah probably maybe slightly better if
Bobby Fischer were around it you know
Fisher taimanov some Vibes here right
with this Pawn structure light Square
Bishop this King will need to Dart over
to the B5 square at some point but I
don't think
origin as any
ideas to let that happen
yeah he doesn't but of course white is
what white is for Choice there you
Bishop can control the Knight quite
nicely black can very quickly get into a
worse end game by just like lazily
moving the Knight to E6 and potentially
getting the pawn structure ruined but
yeah that one is probably going to be
relaxed let's go let's go see the uh the
Hui fun game for sure
uh I I also have the bad feeling
rajaba's experience is now going to kick
in and well that I mean it's always
kicked in but I just mean that he is
going to play fast and solid and
holy Fawn has to not be okay settling
for a draw
you know so her time right now is she's
up 90 seconds but that evaporates so
quickly especially as you're kind of
trying to find the right plan forward
you know if we saw magnets here with
white it's just the Magnus effect you
would just immediately be like oh time
for Magnus to go to work but in in this
case it's like it's a question of will
the job of hold right and if it was
magnus's it's a matter of not if it's a
matter of when Magnus is going to break
through so uh A4 apparently not
preferred there by slack official though
looks completely reasonable I don't know
starfish is doing some weight lifting
you know the more depth it gets the more
it changes mind but still hovering
around the same area we get the point he
wants to go after this eight two Pawn at
some point he also has given his Knight
access into C4 but E4 is such a
committal move Levy where uh you know
now you're bishop and pawn are Tethered
to each other in a way that you might
not want yeah exactly uh what maybe 91
or H5 I really want to play King F2 G4
it feels like when you get the bombs on
g h together that's a serious indication
that black has a problem
but
I guess white has some tactical problems
with Bishop B1 followed by E4 is already
a threat by the way she's about to go
under two minutes so yeah I I I listen I
said what I said because I know the
feeling
I mean I I've never been a world
champion I'm not a road scholar I I
don't exactly know what that feels like
but I do know what it feels like to be
better and have time rapidly winding
down she's only up 20 seconds now right
and you know rajabov he is he's a speedy
player right he is a lot of experience
King F2 player the advantage is
dwindling it doesn't mean that the game
will be to draw and I think honestly all
sides both sides are chances here
because with the time the way it is even
though she should never lose this game
blunders happen especially when there
are things happening on the middle and
the flanks yeah exactly and plus with
almost no time on the clock
Knights on the board gonna they're gonna
be forks blundered and and who knows
what else okay that time Advantage is
now 20 seconds
I wonder if C4 is an option here
C4 The Rook C5 A3 and just you know
try to
yeah you don't want a lot of Knight A5
to C4 you know don't allow this Knight
to start forking your pieces uh the E5
Pawn I guess is hanging so there's no
median night jump so maybe you can just
put a com A3 but she's down to a minute
yep she's now lower than rajabov
see this is the this this is why you
know they put us in for the uh
for the commentary because it's uh
because we we can we can predict the
future she's yeah she's getting she
might be getting in her own head
at some point soon I might recommend
just making the immediate draw you know
like C4 Bishop C3 take the pawn I don't
care if everything gets traded you make
a draw but I don't want we don't want to
lose if I'm me fun and E4 played she
gives up the Palm oh would you not
playing for more he could have just
grabbed the pawn on D4 with takes and
takes but now there's C5 coming there's
Knight C4 Knight D3 which I'm trying to
win this game that's crazy I mean that's
hilarious that he's playing for a win
down a pawn but it sort of makes sense
it makes sense he's seeing the trend of
the game and experience is kicking in
he's gonna try to make every move in
less than five seconds and
this is an extremely tactical end game
there is no Theory here whatsoever and
Knight D3 coming maybe
Knight C4 going after that A3 punch you
can take C7 but then down goes A3 and
that is why Timor put this Pawn in A4
that's a runner yep
and a track start uh that's but but of
course white is also close it takes why
two moves and suddenly the pawn is two
two moves away from queening so
Bishop C1 the good thing is White's
position is resilient
C5 this rook and lemon D1 but the Knight
and Bishop are coordinated in H5 H6
that's about to happen as well
yes Rook D1 is definitely a thing but
then but then H5 Bishop D3 H6 Bishop E2
H7 keep going
yeah wow
oh my gosh that is that is great that
night on C4 is a killer
what
oh he's giving up the E Pawn oh this is
terrifying for white
oh goodness she gotta take it though
right seven seconds on the clock Bishop
E3 up we're all great move I think
that's a really good move in time
trouble you'll take C5 next
will you what if black plays C4 well
then at least your Bishop gets around to
stop that a pawn okay I mean human move
feels like Bishop G5 I don't wanna yeah
I don't want to double my Pawns
so scared of this Pawn running uh me too
nice Knight C1 Knight B3 oh good call
really really good call the knight's
gonna hide an A1 oh that's so funny wow
and then and then white can play C3 C4
and the bishop will control the whole
diagonal
and Bishop E3 could be the next move
because if you take well good luck
getting this Knight on A1 light score
Bishop
yeah in in a in a in an Armageddon here
you always play for a flag but uh well
she has six seconds I mean she's got to
do something it should be three there it
is
and the King can even go out to F4 the
king will likely go back and remember
this is a light score Bishop an A2 Pawn
all white needs to do is two seconds two
seconds
back here
this is so stressful C4 now from black
probably maybe King E6 King D5 okay he
takes what oh she couldn't take those 94
as a four so she actually saw that wow
very sharp
she's pushing her Palms with this she
Pawns about to join
this is this is crazy this is G6
Bishop D4 yeah you got to play that move
Bishop D4 and G7 You Gotta Throw in G7
You Gotta Throw in G7 yep Bishop H7 okay
King H7 played
she has this is a great configuration
Bishop B2 only move
oh my gosh and the Knight and Bishop
can't really move very easily because
then the king gets in yeah King F2 but
then Bishop oh it's never even Bishop to
go yeah I guess she's gonna get back in
time and is she gonna be like almost
playing for a win there with King T2
Knight C2
I guess there's Bishop E6 King takes H6
right yes yes very very well done by
well oh just take this pawn and I guess
the Knight F5
what a game by these two yeah wow what a
game King B3 and play A1 you should play
A1 hoping for like some kind of pre-move
you know wow what a game what a hard
fought draw
they deserve a huge round of applause
like I I know the end position just
Bishop versus knight but that was so
tricky for both of them and Timor he as
you were calling Levy so uh you know you
were spot on he recognized the trend of
the game and that he could try to play
for win because she was she was kind of
wavering
yeah she I mean she definitely was she
had three minutes versus 120 but that
was a very complicated game very very
complicated game and uh
you know they they both clutched it out
toward the end uh here we see uh
Taylor's oldest time we see David
paravion with 20 seconds on the clock
three and a half minutes for his
opponent and his opponent has a horse
and uh David is like he he feels
compelled and he he feels like it is
necessary to win this game
uh but
okay I think fe4 actually alleviates
some of the pressure but I don't know
Robert I'm not totally convinced I'm
actually a bit worried that Rook C3
check could lead black with like a
slightly better ending
um so Rook season yeah Rook C4 yep yep
David blunder no he's he there's no way
he's surviving this he's about to lose a
pawn he's gonna be two passers white has
no Hope on the king side
and Eric icy looks absolutely thrilled
he is jumping out of his seat now that
David has blundered the pawn oh gosh my
blender piece I mean picture was hanging
Eric icy with a fist pump
you can see him cursing on camera there
funny because you said that and I
immediately looked like no way
the Knight D4 followed by Rook B3 rookie
three is I
feel like he'll play A5 but yeah Rook B3
is professional hey yeah I I would be
scared that somehow my knight in two
pawns wouldn't be good enough but in
this case I think there's no way the
bishop can stop them
uh wow breaking news Arjun eragisi is
great at chess
yeah
yeah and he's really gotta you know I
feel like if he wants to be respected at
the top level he's got to really relax
with these reactions
um yeah Regice he just looks completely
over the moon to win this game and
it's funny because if I would ever be
David parvion with black I would
probably just not play chess for a week
I would just celebrate and
you know yeah wow what a convincing game
by the way didn't we kind of predict
this we like this this is something that
we said if David is not able to put
together a winning plan fast he's gonna
get into time trouble and every guy sees
just
it's just too good he's so good at every
phase of the game
his phenomenal he just spots those
tactics when there's a hanging Pawn
available he'll go win it and that
sounds like of course all top players do
that but no they don't especially not in
speed chats right we miss things
top players miss things all the time and
so you know to find those little moments
that's what makes difference between a
provin and an arag I see in this match
yeah it's exactly right
King F5 Maybe
King G4 after Bishop E4 and just
that's it
that is it wow every guy see two nil
and that's I he's not gonna lose with
white let's put it this way so it would
take a massive massive comeback from
paravian to to win after two nothing
but it's possible
anything is possible but as you said not
probable at all Knight takes a four give
me another Pawn don't want this one as
well a G2 and chop over here
yeah parvian's just on she's not just
not happy not thrilled with his uh with
his play
how do you do that with his hair
yeah I I don't know man it's just one
strand now it you it was like multiple
at first and then I feel bad for the guy
the the poor guy is battling just a guy
who's probably gonna be 2 800 in a few
years like a top three candidate for
world champion you know after Magnus is
done with the era and just
and and his opponent is is a very very
good player but we just keep focusing on
his hair man right you know he's a hair
twirler but in all services he's such an
amazing player David paravian uh he's
performed all right G4 can't stop both
pawns G4 G3 Knight F3 and that's game
but for uh paravian
we were commenting his performance in
the rapid Chess Championship and this is
what's gonna happen he's gonna play
Bishop D5 oh wait he's at the Knight F3
and then done or this is gonna
yep it's Precision white king is just
too far and the bishop will be booted
yeah and that's it and he can't believe
it he's like no I had a slightly better
position he's such a strong Grandmaster
and Arjun just like taking a swig of
water I was like yep cool
game two in the books
it's frustrating as you said super
frustrating is he wearing a t-shirt
hoodie
yeah I think so what a Savage
oh my goodness I gotta evolve to that
point man I Gotta Wear tank top hoodies
that's what I that's what I need
um what an exciting what an exciting two
rounds thus far so uh Tamar rajabov and
hoefan have battled it out to two draws
and I know that might not sound exciting
but that second game was like The Hunger
Games literally every single piece was
looking for shelter uh under the Battle
of all the others but our generic I see
is proving today why uh both Robert and
I picked him to win uh not necessarily
the group because he has a very
Monumental task up ahead against Yani
promise you but at least this matchup I
mean you have to remember when we when
we make brackets it's
it's not a knock on any player to select
another player to win the match the fact
that over the last three to four years
in chess
our generic I say probably has the first
or the second highest rise he received
all his IM and GM Norms in the span of
like three or four months and since then
he hasn't stopped and every event that
he's invited to he gets wins against all
of the best players in the world and
he's on full display in in the first two
games here against David parvey on
Robert like opening middle game end game
and time management he's winning in
every single Department yeah honestly he
is a great example of why the ELO system
is outdated for chess because if you
look at the top 10 players in the world
our generic guys his name should be
there based on performance over the last
couple years but we have the system we
have maybe fide is listening they might
want to do something about that but
regardless we're in the midst of the
chess.com Global championship and two
great matches with two games to go
foreign
yes
so there could be a problem with
starting the next one
no it's not not even me but the players
might you know click out and try to come
back in
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
open to anyone
all around the world the chess.com
Global Championship offers the dream of
playing against the best
and hey have we mentioned there's also a
million dollars at stake the total pot
is a million dollars no that it's not a
typo the prizes are unbelievably
generous we began with thousands of
players now only dozens remains there it
is oh my God Eric Hanson this
Eric Hansen moves on to the round of 32
in Armageddon fashion The cgc Knockout
phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends it's the cgc round of 64. who
will take the next step to Toronto
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
the 2022 chess.com Global championship
and we just want to preview a match
that's going to be starting in about an
hour here between Peter swidler and
Alexis shirov this is a matchup as old
as time like honestly if I went to
chessgames.com right now and I looked at
the history and the amount of times that
these two individuals have played each
other it's probably a staggering amount
of Times Robert I don't know if you're
about to do that but uh aren't you
excited for this one I feel like this is
this is this is going to be a super
super fun match both these guys come to
fight they have watched Theory develop
for maybe 30 years 20 30 years they both
contributed massively to the game it's a
super exciting matchup so I did go to
chessgames.com and the first game these
two played according to the site is
1991.
so wow 30 years ago 31 years ago these
two played in the Arnold cup and Shira
have won that first game Sheriff also
won the second game in tilburg of all
places
wow uh yeah that's
crazy I mean honestly these guys are
these guys are legends it's a shame that
they were paired against each other in
this first round and one of them has to
knock the other out but uh can we pull
up the uh bracket for group E just to
kind of show what uh
The Scouting Report is and what the
future holds for the players in the
event the winner of Peter Fiddler versus
Alexis shirov will in all likelihood
have to take on Yani bomnishi now that
is not a knock against Muhammad muradli
who I believe is a strong Junior also
recently receiving Grandmaster title and
just like we've seen uh
you know and many many times my even my
dog is excited I don't know if you can
hear that but my dog is also excited for
that that potential matchup
um but yeah nepo and muradli will
definitely
I mean it's a tough one right Robert
we're a tough spot because at the end of
the day Jan has won two candidates in a
row it seems like every single time that
he plays he wins the tournament
how do you
you know I picked young to win the
entire event like what I I got to be
honest with the audience I can't lie
right I do appreciate your honesty
maradly did win the BL tournament the
open tournament so uh you know he has
some recent successes to his name he is
a junior player as you said and he's
about 25.50 so he's on the way up and
what I was just mentioning before the
break feeder ratings don't always
reflect current strength right in tennis
you have to win events and gain points
to have a higher ranking in chess it's
your historical performance and because
he's a junior there was a pandemic he
hasn't the opportunity to play in all
the events he probably is stronger than
his 2550 current rating that said Jana
pamshi is 2800 approximately has won the
candidates twice in a row so if you're
not named Magnus Carlson you're probably
not a big favorite or a favorite at all
against
Beyond the Palm machine I should say so
the matchup that I think everyone has
their eyes on is this Fiddler matchup we
can shirov just because it's a battle of
Legends and not just Legends of the past
these two both to this day are still
great chess players it's not like uh
they can't compete Fiddler I looked up
his recent over-the-board rapid
tournaments Levy he's performed at like
27.50 in his recent like over the last
couple years when he's played in Grand
chess tour events
uh
uh that 2750 is incredible I mean that's
that's awesome and Peter oftentimes
himself is like I don't want to play
this and that uh
is that that's not a repeat game right
they're just they're basically repeating
the same line minus Knight C3 right and
so I think the job of he took a lesson
from the internet's chess teacher that's
you and he did not bring his Knight to
C3 so early because of this E6 Bishop B4
stuff so instead he fan ketos quickly
and that eliminates some of Black's
options
yeah exactly there's no Knight C3 so now
if he plays D4 a little bit later uh
and he doesn't have the Knight on C3 by
the way for all that black just played
e76 in the first game but in this game
she's going for a double fee in keto
which is
that's exotic that is a very it's a very
good rapid and Blitz line
but I am not I mean I'm I'm just not
sure I mean every time I see it played
sometimes at like this GM level uh
it it can get very bad very quickly for
white if white is not careful
yeah this uh type position with the
double fiend it's just odd but it makes
sense because where was this bishop
going to go on its the f8 A3 diagonal
after E6 it was just been sitting on E7
so instead of fancheros and so D4 is
played unlike the previous position
where the previous game I should say
with the bishop 7 E4 this doesn't make
any sense whatsoever because the Knight
gets to go to see through and kick that
Bishop out immediately so it's just a
totally different Dynamic despite a
similar looking position and for ifan
she has to decide if she wants a castle
right now oftentimes if Knight C3 is
played it's met by the response Knight
to E4 so Yvonne she's doing a Hikaru
here staring off to the side trying to
remember uh or consider what she should
do here and Levy I mean it's a kind of a
big moment in the game for her coming up
because she'll have decided does she
want to play D5 does she want to play C5
now how exactly is she going to develop
an initiative
yeah e65 is one of the plans there's
also D6 and C5 I used I used to play the
double fan ghetto uh
uh quite a lot actually with and yes
there's this Knight E4 move I used to
play this a lot with black and it can be
fun but for a long time people were just
sort of punishing me for playing like
this white can play Bishop D2 Queen C2
and d45
and just you know try to expand into
your position it really also depends if
black plays F7 F5 wow for example of
just doing it like this I've never seen
this bishop G5 wow some new stuff to me
Queen C8 looks quite reasonable and
maybe Queen to B7 just trying to join
the bishop on the long diagonal uh F6 I
was about to say it's not out of the
question now I know Ben Feingold is
somewhere shaking his head but because
Black's typical plan is for F5 stopping
on F6 just to get the bishop out of
there and then playing F5 it does make
perfect sense there's no rush for F5 you
don't need to control the E4 score
anymore you have a bishop there uh that
can't be kicked very easily and if you
played Bishop to H3 well then G5 F5 G4
things like that are not going to be
super fun to me yeah Queen C8 Queen B7
like to to fight on the diagonal I I
actually kind of feel like rajapov is
bluffing like I I I
I've never seen this before right
there's a couple of ways to take
advantage
of the position for white because black
played a double fan ghetto and black has
a very strange Pawn structure but
somehow
no I mean I mean I don't know we're
gonna find out okay she plays F5
I don't Robert you made a made a point
G5 looked
and just that whole plan like now at
five uh dark squares are a bit weak she
I mean if we go backwards she could have
played G5 and then G4 and traded the
Bishops off by force right so she would
never have to worry about these Bishop
H3 and Knight moving around ideas but
she could have gone for that if she so
chose but I get why you don't play this
very easily in Rapid you don't expose
your king and create some problems over
there but F5 while it's thematic it does
seed control over some importance dark
squares
yes the question is what does rajaba do
to take advantage maybe H4 I like to
look at that
yeah H4 trying to play H5
um the attack and then play itself
you can also play A4 A5 might as well
just push on everyone B4 A4 and H4 there
you go
pick your poison and you know F5 it
makes a lot of sense you can't really
faulty fund for going for this move uh
but she is down in terms of development
and time right there's Knight on B8 rook
and eight the queen side's not playing
uh White has two pawns on the fourth
Rank and black only has one Pawn on her
fourth round which is the fifth rank so
it just feels like white has a little
bit better control but there's not clear
plans for either side I actually don't
see like I see some moves but I don't
see like an eight-step plan
Rook fd1 is also a strange move but I
guess he's trying to play D5 and maybe
he's trying to play Knight E1 uh other
than that I'm
I'm really not so sure Rook fd1 this
whole game is kind of confusing uh it
seems like both of them are just sort of
trying to make something happen but uh
she's gonna play Maybe D6 Knight D7
Knight F6 I would much rather have an I
don't need four if I was playing black
but I I get that the bishop stands there
and I get it's doing a good job uh have
parvion and ever guys he started by the
way they have not started yet no
oh they will start shortly I presume
yeah okay but
okay then that is did they finish much
later than these two
no but possible you know during the
break because when the players left they
got food or something but I'm asking and
verifying when that game will start I
think it's a slight stagger as well
um uh yeah so that does that does make
sense uh well in that case let's try to
predict Black's next move
let's see D6 Knight C6 Queen is seven
reasonable plans it A5 none of the
questions sometimes you just want to
gain space for yourself over here but
the reason why A5 is a bit risky is
because white might just play Rook C1
and C5 and and use this bishop to great
effect
so oh uh uh Queen E7 by the way I was
thinking Bishop C7 D6 traps the bishop
but you can take the Knight which is
really embarrassing uh that would be
kind of funny
um but uh
okay I think we have an opening in the
other game
all right let's check it out
catch the start of that one whoa oh
sorry it's a a picture I was like I saw
pawns on D5 and even this is the
position I saw but I didn't realize that
I was like how did this happen but of
course it just was blacks last one was
D5 so to go back in time just to get the
start here it was a Petrov and Levy when
you're playing a game that you have to
win
I'm not sure the Petrov is necessarily
the opening of choice yeah very strange
decision uh maybe he's just trying to be
solid and hope that every guy see pulls
up on karatev and just sort of you know
in a spot where he has to just draw
it just goes a little bit crazy in the
position but uh
if I'm gonna bet on a guy to be cool
calm and collected I think it's going to
be Eric icy uh but anything is possible
you mean the guy who doesn't react at
literally anything yeah nothing and his
interviews are also so funny they're so
they're so relaxed he's just like yeah
well you know I just yeah
27 30. so
let me go like this uh you know I might
need to revoke my own GM title I thought
that you could take a nice let's just
bring up an analysis board real quick I
know what you're gonna get yeah I was
like oh wait this looks like a huge
blunder and well I'll just show it on on
this board then takes Queen takes here
if I could play Bishop takes H7 check I
win you're Queen but Knight C3 Knight
takes E3 I forgot the Knight defended
the queen so like haha gotcha and then I
really got myself because this queen is
defended that's okay it happens uh maybe
the person playing with black also would
have forgotten you know
who just resign
yeah exactly oh God they just resigned
after Bishop takes H7 they're like oh my
God I plundered another attack like has
has it ever happened to you that someone
has resigned in a non-losing position
against you not not over the board but
uh yeah for sure
I think I think like in Blitz especially
when you attack I mean I usually should
never resign that's
uh I'm on both sides of the argument I
always make fun of people for not
resigning for a long time against me and
then I also make fun of you know
subscribers who reside way too early I
had a game against Timor grave like
13 years ago at this point uh but it was
I had Rook King and rook and he had King
and Knight and he resigned but his King
was on the side of the board but it was
still a draw and I think he really
resigned because he was completely
winning for like a large majority of the
game and then to have that position and
he's just frustrated and probably just
like stop thinking and yeah he was not
in a drawing position
you know what that reminds me of
do tell that reminds me of our game oh
yeah I thought I thought I thought for
sure you were gonna beat me with vs king
and Knight we had a we had a long
five-hour battle that ultimately ended
with you having King and Rook vs king
and Knight and I was like I know this is
a draw but luck is not on my side and I
think I offered a draw and you accepted
and I was like oh thank God yeah you
didn't know you should have beat me man
you should just
that game was ridiculous like in every
way possible but yeah you did offer a
draw and I was like yep nope that seems
like uh the right time but you are right
that if you're on the better side of a
draw or in your you know worse you
should not resign you shouldn't accept
the drug I should have played out 50
moves but I was hungry and you know I
knew you were gonna survive it so okay
okay now now Queen B5 they're very much
is Bishop H7 but I have to get pravin
credit here at least he's like mixed the
game up here it's not just a symmetrical
position where uh Arjun can make a draw
any which way now there's gonna be an
isolated Pawn on D5 white has the pair
of Bishops black has these Knights and
has the better Pawn structure so
I feel this I'm into this a little bit
this is yeah this is a good
I feel like there's
better ways to kill off lines in the
Petrov but who knows maybe paravian was
going to play Stafford Gambit
I don't know
Eric icy did play 3d4 in Stafford
Virginia
I was gonna ask you you think like all
these guys know the top engine lines
because you have to
you don't have to do anything it's don't
make me hate on this African but I know
how many Eric Rosen fans are out there
you're trying to get me into like a a
little quarrel with our boy Eric
the Stafford gaming is terrible it is
objectively a horrible opening
the craziest thing is I think it's might
it might even be objectively worse than
the England game but according to
stockfish but it's very close but so bad
in all the chat is about to you know go
hate on me I get it it's fine uh but you
know there's a there's a reason that I
can't possibly look at the Stafford
Gambit and do anything but shake my head
yeah uh
you know the funniest way to play
against the Stafford is just to play uh
D4 after Knight C6 and just be like
completely
it's the it's probably the best solution
I mean that reminds me maybe we'll just
make a video about it just uh then we'll
start some real beef with Eric
there we go
um yeah have you I I know I know you
teach like you I don't know if you still
Teach as much chess as you did but uh
uh have your students been influenced by
YouTube and they're like I play this
Gambit now you know because I watch Bozo
on camera me Eric whatever is that have
you have you experienced that with kids
or adults so I'm I'm not really teaching
very much these days so thankfully I
don't have to deal with it but uh
yeah no I mean I think
I think thankfully the people I was
coaching they end up listening to me
more than uh people on the internet so
that's good advice for everybody you
know trust you know talk to your friends
don't trust random Reddit threats right
it's like yes yeah that you you are
random red thread while we switch games
to the original uh if on game but I'm
just saying that for everyone out there
looking for some life advice that was
completely unsolicited just trying to
help you out
yes exactly your your coach your
personal trainer just like in the gym
they know you better so they know they
know how to point you in the right or
they don't you might have a terrible
coach but uh you know so those of you
with a good good coach send me a decent
coach you're probably getting pointed in
the right direction you know what's not
getting pointed in the right direction
Robert the evaluation bar here for yifon
yeah White's gonna play D6 and B4 and F4
I don't know yet in which order but in
some order or C5 by the way oh my God
choose which dark Square you want to put
a Pawn on and they're all good and you
can just tell by her body language that
she is she's like already thinking about
resigning essentially yep
I don't understand why she played G6 I
just really don't
um
like I I was sort of I was sort of very
confused when I saw it originally
because she had it's not like she was
blown off the board in the first game
she effortlessly Drew with black why not
just play E6 right I just this is just
such an offbeat system the double fan
Kettle and no Pawns in the center
it doesn't it just really doesn't work
we kind of see it happening now having
said that if she hadn't played F5 it
might have worked but then she had would
have had to play like really cagey chess
like G5 you know it's like not how the
top players like to play especially if
you're not a dynamic player you're not
inclined to this give report this
position he's gonna play G5 in two
seconds yeah he would have played G5
three moves ago even when brother would
have played a move one
yeah he's such a fun player but this is
where it went wrong F5 yeah my coach
Michelle used to say that mistakes come
in pairs and then Knight C6 so first F5
not the best and then Knight C6 is where
it started going wrong for it because
her Knight goes to A5 and could you ask
for a more natural thematic setup for
white and what's your knight doing over
here why do you have no space with your
pawns as black it's like everything went
wrong for her in this game and the one
time she gained space my job I was
trying oh huge mistake apparently based
on the evaluation rookie wants to show
logical move but apparently a huge
inaccuracy
what was wrong with B4 C5
nothing nothing yeah precisely nothing
what what why did he not do this
um maybe he felt bad for how little
space Yvonne had and was like okay
you'll gain a little something here but
no this is just overwhelming you could
play C6 you could take on B6 and land a
rook on C7 you could play D6 and F
as we were saying any dark Square Pawn
push is going to be a good one
yeah maybe maybe sometimes you just
don't uh really quite grasp how good
your position is you just want to
improve everything slowly uh but uh
no need maybe he's in like F4
something like F4 for black trying to
trap the bishop somehow F4 and H6 some
stuff like that
yeah I could see that happening right
you cut off the queen and Bishop on the
same diagonal uh of course now F4 can be
captured by the bishop but so Knight B7
was ifan's choice and now before there's
always A5 at least something to consider
because you're opening up the line for
your rope that gives black some counter
play maybe she didn't like that maybe he
thought his attack wasn't fast enough
and black was going to be able to play
five oh wait he's worse now
F4 is that why or Bishop H6 F4 yeah for
Bishop takes but Bishop takes Queen
takes
yeah but this is just not a good piece
this bishop on G2 right exactly yep she
takes me just by D6 and just protect her
E5 pawn and then bring her Queen over
maybe try to trade Queens
that was so strange I
yeah he just had to be a killer
but you know like I this is not the
candidates but even though he had an
excellent excellent run in the
candidates I think for the first half
include players even close to Timur like
uh Anish giri for example were talking
about like the Killer Instinct mentality
right like you have to smell blood and
just like that's it B4 C5 executed you
know D6 C6 breakthrough he's trying to
kind of play it slowly but
he's lost the benefit of the position
the one benefit the one advantage that
white had in this game in case anybody's
confused like why does white get such an
advantage from an equal position is time
you have time on your side to create an
attack and not only does white no longer
have that time white also just straight
up has worse quality pieces so ifan is
gonna exactly like you said he's gonna
play Queen G7 and
I that's it A5 Knight C5 and Black's
better probably like objectively
actually if Timor doesn't find a
concrete solution here he will be worse
and uh this bishop this is what happens
and this is what uh when players are
developing they're getting stronger
speak speaking of coaches teaching you
things that you look at the prospects of
your pieces and maybe there was no one
better at this in history than Bobby
Fischer he always seemed to know which
pieces he should trade because he could
visualize a position 15 moves from now
and see what would uh benefit him and so
right now this Knight on B7 then I was
in A5 was terrible now it's on V7 it's
going to go to C5 you'll push upon to A5
here and it's gonna be much better than
this bishop on G2 which has zero
prospects whatsoever so I think he found
now she shouldn't even think you know
how do I make a draw that's typically
what strong GMS do with black as make a
draw with black win with white at least
attempt to she's a great position Levy
yeah she does she has a amazing position
if she gets to play A5 and then Knight
C5 white will not even be able to play
A3 B4 that's kind of the major
concern that black would have with
putting the Knight on C5 is that it
would get booted but by then black would
have moved the a pawn far enough so it
would stop that advancement
now I guess white wants to break in the
center so White's plan is to double the
Rooks and then play F4 and when black
closes everything with E4 well sucks to
suck white has another F Pawn now I
don't know if sucks to suck are the
words that are going through timor's
mind and then they are probably more
sophisticated but the point still stands
I don't like Knight D6
well she's giving the job the option but
actually think taking is just losing for
white right if you get the uh
the situation we'll just put this here
I guess it's not it looks losing like
honestly when I look at this position I
think blacks just win the game
yeah but apparently it's better for
white yeah it looks really I mean I
guess white will play a four Bishop of
three and oh H4 H5 is always going to be
a problem yes but there's Knight F7
there's all sorts of stuff here right
like this just seems like a position
I'm I'm completely incorrect I'll accept
that I own that it's fine that's I think
for me being commentator I have to be
willing to be wrong and I am but when I
see Rook takes E5 and he finds doing the
same exact intuitive calculation she's
like take any five yeah I'm good as
black because this bishop is useless or
so it seems and I don't see an attack
against my king
yeah
is rookie five the only way that white
gets Advantage here
I would imagine have to be the case so
it's not just coming to F7 and this
Queen's
yeah there there it goes
wow wow that's so counterintuitive that
Rook takes E5 is good for white
because it's shocking
that that is so strange
you know even with that Eva I think in a
game between just strong players I think
black wins that position like
a large percentage of the time
I'm still confused how that's good for
white
I I probably white has a way of getting
all of the attack and the King safety
but
it's definitely it's definitely a tough
one uh for sure and and the thing is
in the long run the Knight on D6 is
if it doesn't if white doesn't end up
taking on E5 if the Knight doesn't
actually get to C4 I still am a little
bit hesitant about where it is because I
feel like white and H4 like B3 H4 maybe
bishop H3 H5 she just has to not fall
into the same trap like last time so
right now she's down two minutes last
time she started up 90 seconds so if
she's going to be down two minutes and
all of a sudden down four minutes
and Timur keeps enough pieces on the
board he's gonna quickly become the
favorite
he's trying to play C5 and I just looked
at the other game between Arjun aragaisy
and Dave Province go over there uh that
one is looking very level it's Bishops
of opposite color you know Province
giving it his all a levy I think is we
dissect the position on the board it
should be a draw pretty much with
emotionless margin
yeah yeah I I think so I don't think
it's
I don't think it's possible to
uh win this game with
frankly either color but
Never Say Never And also for the first
time we see Arjun does not hold a
commanding time Advantage which is
important
yeah and actually I think maybe the
start of this should be Queen takes E5
after Queen takes A7 plays C5 C4 as
quickly as possible like just try to get
yourself something to uh have an
advantage with and the past Pawn is
running quickly now it's not going
anywhere because black white will just
go over C1 and Bishop C3 and all that
but you need some kind of imbalance and
that's the best I can come up with here
yeah exactly it's Gotta it's got to come
down to the ponds
I I I I think of all the games this one
I don't know they're both kind of very
very stable right now I feel like both
games are
right at that moment where it's a mutual
chances for both sides
and ultimately it will come down to
probably the next five or seven moves to
determine whether one side slips up
gives the initiative to the other
I guess particularly for this game
paragon's not looking for the best moves
he's looking for the best chances to win
sometimes that is the best moves but in
some cases it's not yeah he's gonna take
risks because a draw is equivalent to a
loss here he's gotta win so if that
involves some kind of sacrifice that is
just a terrible decision it doesn't
matter because he needs to try something
otherwise Arjun will just make it easy
to draw so we'll keep an eye out on this
game it's not super exciting right now
let's go back to the other one uh
because yifon has just met the job of C5
push with the move D6 so dark Square
domination for black I mean she's
playing checkers while he's playing
chess usually that's an insult but here
it feels like a compliment because it's
a light score Bishop against all these
pawns the dark squares so Levy when you
look at this and how things are
developing here uh who's and whose
chances do you like more
I like White's chances uh sorry I like
Black's chances a lot more uh
uh I think H5 G5 Knight H6 G4 is like
gonna play itself you have to be a
little bit careful of course with your
C7 Pawn your A7 Pawn but your base of
operations there seems to be very well
protected if black and of course if
black can get the A7 Pawn to capture on
B6 that would be a dream situation but
although CB also doesn't look that
unreasonable what I'm very confused
about is why she looks so frustrated
she's like visibly shaking her head and
I don't understand why
she worried about Bishop H3 E6 because
that's not even concerning at all
because Knight G5
so clutch move
what is she so upset about I I just
don't know
and yeah like rajav might go astray as
well
yeah it's a position without real
Clarity here I mean black obviously
playing the dark squares at some point
Bishop H3 could be a huge problem for
black but with Knight G5 always
available it's not happening anytime
soon so your H5 move was very appealing
to me because you can play H4 and just
try to
barrel down on this G3 Pawn over here
and rookie seven I think just as a
preemptive type of move but maybe Queen
A3 Levy maybe that's something that
Timor is trying to aim for let me just
tickle your Pawn A7
yeah that might be why is she showing
signs of frustration but I I even wonder
if black can play something like
A5 and just sacked upon completely give
like a structural
solidity to the pawn on C7 and just
still go for an attack like I I I mean I
would do it in Blitz of course it's
completely different to do it here but
yeah I agree Queen A3 what is the plan
is the plan I think it's what you said
no I'm going to show that because it's
very instructive like let's say you get
a position even like this where white
steals a pawn this Knight if it gets to
C5 or D4 I mean it's just Devastation
for white but the point is that you are
up upon it's isolated blacks Rooks have
gained some activity this bishop is
terrible black just controls all the
dark squares and I think it's open files
to counter with and black should not
complain
I'm actually shocked wow that's actually
a major confidence boost for my chess
understanding I thought it was I thought
it was speculative but uh
uh that might wow A5 huh I I just I just
sort of thought the position was a bit
stronger there for black but okay well
well I am I'm proud of myself I can feel
good
you have to understand I'm not a 20 I'm
not a narrative I'm not 26 40. I'm not
expected to go 100 on this oh you never
want to play a move like Rick A8 though
it's not a bad move but it's just ah
ah no
although it kept the balance completely
yes yes she doesn't have to give up any
material for it and it's very clear what
she is lining up oh
no he got to give the pawn away
I mean well she also can play A5 now and
it's actually not losing a pawn anymore
so but then there might be CB and like
B5 and white oh yeah actually A5 cbcb B5
is that just crushing for I think she'll
throw in a ticks before but otherwise
yeah that would be a problem so Levy's
point is that after if you take back
here
oh she does but oh that's terrible no
you can't do that she really didn't want
to lose a pawn
yeah but this is
I mean she's such a strong player
obviously that doesn't need to be said
but strong players typically don't mind
giving a pawn if it means they get more
activity she is being a little bit too
material conscious and now she's much
much worse because this Rook can go to
C6 even if the Knight can take like
that's an automatic exchange sacrifice
to get a past Pawn but the Knight can't
even get there so yeah yeah I think
that's what I think that's what a lot of
people uh
don't understand here is it doesn't
really matter if the Black Knight can
stop Rook C6 it's not stopping anything
because you take and the pawn is two
squares from cleaning and now Bishop H3
is a completely different story the
bishop on H3 becomes just the Savage ah
it's disappointing she really didn't
want to lose a pawn and it's a really
nice lesson in material is not as
important as peace activity and well I
guess in this case it really is just
peace activity but also just sort of
future prospects she's kind of tied
herself down and now she's got a minute
left and
yeah she goes Rook E8 it's a rook C6 is
shot by some kind of E4 move an open VF
file I know but if she wanted to attack
she could have a long time ago uh just
parted with the pawns now she has to get
kind of desperate here and we saw it's
it's on the board but it's apparently
not the best move but we saw part of
young play like this as well against
Eric I see in the first game the first
rapid game
uh but the problem is he left himself no
time and okay she can play a couple of
really nice counter-attacking measures
but
she has five seconds at the end it's not
gonna work so she needs to play faster
yeah she's trying to get her Knight into
E5 and cause problems down the f file
take here so I I see the counter play if
I didn't have the evaluation bar for the
side screen I would say this feels like
it's a bit desperate but I can sense
that it could be a difficult time for
white I think Queen takes G3 here
covering the F2 Pawn because Knight E5
doesn't come with a threat if the
Queen's already on G3
yeah I wonder I mean queen G3 I agree
completely I wonder if fg3 Rook F1 but
maybe you don't want to weaken your king
queen G3 Queen D4
Queen E3 I guess
whoa
why why did you do that just look back
to C2 is he
F4
oh my gosh that actually might hurt
I wonder if F4 was a good move I mean it
seemed a little bit too much but
oh sorry
yeah still better for white yeah I guess
stockfish is a scumbag it's like yeah
sacrifice the rook and just win the end
game
wow so it's much better for white says
oh you know well over plus one so Rook
C7 check still keeping it in that
territory but it was Plus
two point something so Rook C7 check
don't give checks just because you can
and now she's Fair what to do with her
King yep but she has 30 seconds
I would be tempted to go on a dark
square but there's no Bishop check so
King Jade also makes sense
She Gotta Move though she's taking way
too much time yeah it's really way too
much time
way too much time I mean yeah rookie
seven and you know but okay if you're
playing rookie seven trading pieces
after you gave him a pawn that's
obviously not what you want take take F4
is probably quite strong
you need this Rook on C5 like
jump over multiple pieces uh yeah yeah
rookie seven and probably even Queen E3
is not unreasonable there because it's
really tough to defend the B6 Pawn
I don't like this position one bit for
uh for black but the good news for her
if there's any is that regalo is also
nearing one minute and that's when chaos
ensues so F4 played yep the first played
I I was a bit worried that you know
rajaba would look for a bit more of a
solid move
yeah and he would be a bit more
concerned but you know Queen C3 also E5
also just also just like Bishop H3 at
some point and the Knight has to get out
nah this is done if you get if you get
E5
yeah black is too slow here and I mean
honestly she lost this game because she
just respected her pawns a little bit
too much that's that's she hasn't lost
yet but she's gonna lose
I I think so yeah 10 seconds on the
clock unless for Java blunt or something
completely ridiculous his Pawn is also
going probably to E6 but also Queen C3
is super strong
rookie two
my sister I said she's gonna lose but
something about the waiver job is doing
this and how much time he's spending per
move I'm not completely convinced it's
over anymore
we're about to find out yeah yeah
there's Queen C3 King G8 don't even
think about it
King says that Quincy
oh he wants to eat
nope
he just want to play Bishop G4 when the
Knight came here yeah he has uh some Ed
move like right now
oh that's nasty but now the Rook is
defended on the back rank right still
but it's such a cool tactic to note yeah
going after
he still has oh no easy was check on D5
yeah his position is so strong
yeah she's trying to get like from H4
thing in but it's way too slow it feels
like
well they should have three Knight F5
and if the time situation was reversed I
wouldn't put a password to mess
something up
is it so wild oh
Easy System
a67 is crushing has to be right
yep
oh he plundered a piece oh my goodness
he Blended a piece
this Rook is hang with check
that's completely unreal
oh my goodness now it's completely
anyone's game and don't ignore the
evaluation bar yeah it's gonna go up and
down it's a seesaw
yeah both sides are now going to
completely panic because holifan's gonna
be like oh my God I'm winning
and Taylor's gonna be like oh my God I'm
losing he's trying to get Queen C8 Rook
C7 but I'm not even sure that works
great move Queen B7 hitting both D5 and
B6 93 check if you remember the queen of
C7 yep
yep and queen D3 Queen D5 oh my gosh
can't stop Queen defile onto the Rook D2
that's a seven four seconds gotta go two
more seconds
Queen F6 Queen d5's gotta be winning
Queen D5 King H through this queen oh
she just goes take the Rook
oh and she has Queen G7 she's completely
winning she's Queen G7 at the end
oh gosh cutting the Queen off
check queen of five five Queen F5
The Rock
oh my gosh
Oh What A Move what a what a move and
she he's gonna get that is that is Queen
E5 and that's it oh my gosh Robert
I can't take it
and look at both she hits her head he
shakes his head uh they're both kind of
laughing at what a wild Affair that one
was
that was unbelievable rajabov not only
lost the piece he then went on to lose
the Rook as well obviously it was
deliberate with the intention of playing
E7 and cutting everything off let's go
back to that position that was Unreal I
had a very bad feeling that was still
gonna happen you know why it happened
because she left herself with no time
and that like if she had even five more
seconds maybe she would have uh held her
cool but wow her job of losing the
bishop here was crazy loose pieces drop
off so instead of taking this Rook
because Queen takes E2 check and the
King can't escape the check so if you
bring your queen back here this queen
can just come back and win the pawn so
instead of all this he won the win so he
takes on A5 but he was playing to win
while also playing the lose Queen B7 was
a great choice
and all right we'll come back to this
one second and the other game still is
going on time trouble ensuing well three
seconds for paravian and I mean I mean
this is the end game
I don't think that provin has even the
slightest chance of winning here those
Pawn structure is better
yeah this one's over I don't know why we
this one's gonna end right now so uh
okay let's quickly summarize again
what went wrong and what went right and
that ridiculous scramble between
this match will be over so every guy
said we'll move on to the round of 32
um
I would I would I guess okay we still
have I I don't know what the plan I want
to look at that game I want to look at
that game more than I want to see the
conclusion of this one because this
one's over this one's
yeah it seems like uh here good setup
for origin if this King could walk up
the board because the white king is cut
then black would have some chances right
but uh that's a a long journey this Rook
can also come to C7 if the King goes up
goes to C6 and F6 and things like that
and well let's see what Robin has
because he only has five seconds do you
think he
yeah
yeah no
no no no no no no no no this one's over
Eric I see just Ultra convincing and you
know some players uh play more intensely
when they're close to the monitor Eric
guys he wants to be as far as possible I
don't even know is every guy say making
moves telepathically
he has a text to speech on
yeah exactly like he's just he's just
like back here you know just like
[Laughter]
it is what it is
he is really far back I don't know how
he's moving like does he have the
longest arms of all time
he's like he's like Michael Jordan in
Space Jam
i i i Robert I you have way more
sophisticated references than me I don't
I don't know a whole lot about stuff
right but you've seen Space Jam right
when I was like three or like in in
elementary school God you're forgiven
that yeah I I I wanted to pretend I knew
what you were talking about but I had a
split second decision where I like Could
Have Lied and like you know I don't I
don't I don't lie to the audience
so I don't know man does never Disney
get your references never almost never
yeah don't worry okay I feel like I know
a little bit more than Dania and you
know Daniel will be here later he's
going to take over for the uh for the uh
the the sick Bozo on stream but uh
there's E6 and who knows we might even
get a we might get a win for every guy
see somehow if the pawn gets to E7 and
E8
so he just trades and this is two on one
uh this is an easy oh just don't trade
Rooks sometimes you can trade Rooks and
still draw but the way to hold this game
is you're told when you're down material
probably don't trade yeah this Rook is
just gonna stay on the sixth rank for
white
you know I've seen many GMS just
straight up agree to draws in three on
two end games it's really funny I I can
imagine it really confuses the audience
they're like why are they doing this but
it's because
I know it's a draw this position will be
drawn via philidor technique
unless of course white completely loses
the pawn in which case black will be
winning
but you know rook and games are drawn
even sometimes when there are two extra
pawns yes FHM yeah
but here is the defense of task is so
simple for why just keep this Rook on
the sixth rank okay don't trade don't
trade
might still be a draw no
there are positions where you definitely
can trade
but it's easier just to go like this
yeah yeah don't it's no need
H5 would be the move and you have to be
a little bit careful now because the one
thing you can't afford is all this Rook
to H3 with this Pawn H5 so yep something
to note
yep
but Arjun he's too strong this is a
riveting end game here probably one of
the most exciting chess games I have
ever commentated can't wait to see it in
your recap video oh yeah just listen of
all the games from the round of 64. this
is definitely the one that's making it
in yeah and here it was uh they played
they played 75 more moves and delayed
our break but you know it
did you see that on Drake and Checkmate
yesterday
no oh that's going to be in your recap
for sure game three from his match
against uh around Jacobian sick check
him at the end
I I left the broadcast yesterday and
then I slept and drank hot liquids the
entire day
but uh I will I I will make sure to tune
in Robert you have a long day I don't
know how you do this stuff for like six
hours seven hours
well I'm just energized by the chest
even end games like this energize me
Levy just uh love me a good two on one
same side of the board definitely you
know tons of chances for the side
pressing
I mean listen every guys he has lost a
minute of clock time paravian's time has
stayed the same
aravian is on the grind here
yeah probably needs all the wins he can
get so he's cutting into the time
deficit is a good good start
all right Rook T6
getting F5
um
broke back
anywhere
the thing that white can't do is allow
this black king in and the black thing
isn't going the wrong way so King F4
we've had this position before
Robert you got any plans today
I do I think I'm getting dinner with a
friend later
um you know that is if I'm not
commentating all the way up until dinner
because it seems like there are endless
supply of matches today which is great
because we have some fantastic ones in
I'm really excited for Spindler against
shirov
yes that that one's gonna start very
soon in about 15 minutes as players have
woken up in St Louis
actually more than half of our matchups
that are coming up are playing in the
chess 960 event which is being held at
the St Louis chess club so they woke up
probably got a coffee hopefully ate some
better food than Hotel buffet and are
now going to play this event and then go
shower and they're going to
play uh play this event followed by the
St Louis one yeah and Mama Jarvis in
first place tied with farugia there so
uh he's gonna play in the global
Championship then maybe get a little bit
of rest and go play 960. the good thing
about playing 960 though is there's no
preparation so it's not like he needs to
go sit his computer for hours and study
Lines no he has no idea what he's gonna
get so that's that's cool he'll at least
get some chess in and then he'll get to
play against all the big guys
Rook B3 here there is absolutely no way
uh forward and Eric icy knows it
and
well he's just sitting there and as as
as full of emotion as he ever is
it's literally been his face for like
three hours
he has 30 more moves to make until the
draw so the one thing he can't afford is
the internet to go out but he seems to
be stable for now yep
E3
Rook D5 how many moves
uh
still I think 28 more moves
okay terrific
what about you do you have any uh plans
for today oh no no no no I uh no just
recovering and
hoping that uh hoping that uh you know
sore throat doesn't doesn't get any
worse but what better way to spend my my
day recovering than
watching some chess
what the hell is that what did our
Graphics team just make
Arjun is now sitting much closer but
apparently we have a we actually have an
action shot from inside the arjunary
geyser room
this is cursed man it's freaking me out
a little bit
wow
oh God she's defending very accurately
here three seconds for paravian
I'm sorry I I would have
oh well if anybody's confused why we
just photoshopped extremely long arms
onto
our generic I see it's because about 10
minutes ago he uh was sitting extremely
far back
and
uh
uh he looked like he was way too far
from the monitor to actually be making
the moves on the board
and we said he probably has the world's
longest arms this is the way we have to
amuse ourselves while players are
playing 350 Move games
also like having to explain your joke is
just
if I rookie one go for checkmate yeah uh
actually almost lost some time by the
way he'd point eight seconds left when
he made that move I mean draw our losses
the same result so he might as well just
go out with a bang yeah
oh
Uchi four
it doesn't matter makes no difference
though right
good move good move
yeah oh he arjun's too strong to blunder
check again
also you could take G6 I think Arjun
doesn't want to take on G6 because he
wants to the 50 move nope now he does
what is going is David actually on
ironically gonna play
it out he's got to play tonight he's
playing this out forever
come on David there yes yes play it out
David
can I leave like can I just be the first
co-host in history to just walk off just
for the content
this is so this is absurd man just these
days is all about withdrawing so you
know you should maybe go do your thing
yeah okay I've decided to withdraw from
commentary
um you know if I speak I'm in big
trouble so
um yeah
there he goes
and now it's just me I have the floor he
can't even hear me took his headphones
off so that Levy guy
gosh that YouTube channel nobody should
go follow Gotham chess why would you
just uh stir in the pot
trying to have a good time you know only
recapping the world's most important
chess games and there it is there's a
draw
128 moves later this game is drawn Arjun
arag I see I mean the guy is not even
reacting so
he just moves on here at the chess.com
Global championship and well I guess
it's time to move on because
rajabov and who you found they have to
play their fourth and final game and
we'll be back for more from the
chess.com Global championship in just a
few
[Music]
foreign
to anyone
all around the world the chess.com
Global Championship offers the dream of
playing against the best
and hey have we mentioned there's also a
million dollars at stake the total pot
is a million dollars know that it's not
a typo the prizes are unbelievably
generous we began with thousands of
players now only dozens remain
there it is oh my God Eric Hanson this
is
moves on to the round of 32 in
Armageddon fashion
The cgc Knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and summer here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real
hey one second boom Oh my God
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends it's the cgc round of 64. who
will take the next step to Toronto
welcome back to our coverage of the 2022
chess.com Global championship and here
oh welcome back to our coverage of the
chess.com Global championship and
we've got on screen here Timor rajab and
hoi fun they just played uh an insane
game just absolutely Wild game uh their
third rapid game
and Robert I think we're gonna jump in
and just kind of briefly take a look at
it and all of those final key moments
um I don't know where you want to start
man probably right around here right
just
yeah I mean white was completely winning
that was her job of and this is what
happens when you're in time trouble he
started spending his time at first I
thought it was completely losing pretty
fun but then he mixes with Queen B6 and
Levy that was the first of many blunders
to come
yeah Queen B6 Rook D7 I mean I I okay
Queen F6 was the major question right
when rajaba played this move
um this was this was all it this was the
gamble right here so where where was the
win so Queen D5 was that the win the
simpler win or was 93 completely fine I
think 93 in all this was good but the
problem was at this point she won queen
of five which I was clamoring for so I'm
equally at fault I mean I don't have the
the game in the bounce here but maybe it
was just the Queenie a com Queen E8
defending this pawn and keeping the Rook
defense that's a hard move to play
because queen of five is so tempting but
the issue now is that the Rook is
hanging so you have to spend another
turn this bee Pawn is going up the board
and well then she lost everything
because 93 it looks like black is about
to give a Checkmate on G2 if white
promotes but that's why Timor threw in
the wonderful move Queen I love moves
like that yeah it was always so fun yeah
very very nice move uh Queen E8 Queen D6
really B7 would have been the or what
would have been the win there after
Queen E8 Queen DC yeah Rook B7 yeah Rook
B7 you can even bring the Knight back
maybe 93 or Knight D4 to stop Queen E6
check so the Knight can join the
defensive task and everything is tied
together for black so now she's gonna
have to bounce back she that's actually
completely not she almost won with black
to be up two to one and all she would
have needed is a draw with the white
pieces and uh considering that say more
is a repertoire in that second game was
the Berlin
he would have had to really mix it up to
try to do something else but he is the
winner uh he was the favorite of course
in the matchup but who would have
expected that that's as close of a nail
biter as it would have been uh they
begin oh
um is my favorite opening
you want some Vienna here
yeah if Knight F6 I want to see F4 I
don't want to see none of this bishop C4
D3 stuff but I want to see a nice nice
Vienna Gambit what's her job gonna play
I really like the move Bishop C5 here by
Black by the way
it's a really nice move order to throw
in D6 F4
oh let's see some F4 you think she you
know has your course
no she probably has I don't know I don't
know G3 yeah there is another way to
play though it's still called the Vienna
but this has a different name right is
this like the gleck
or something
says the fault beer mice's variation
yeah yeah whatever but I'm pretty sure
it's called the Glick like I I think uh
let's see gleck chess
oh Igor gleck
let's see yeah or maybe gleck is the
Four Knights with G3 something like that
I don't know I don't know I don't know
openings I know names of openings so I'm
not the person to ask but uh you know
either way she's just playing this kind
of
a position without tension right there's
no trades being offered I think she's
trying to play for in the long run here
uh she is spending time after the move
Knight to C6 I don't think she's
thinking about taking on C6 that would
no probably not be very good I don't
think so either but it's a nice it's a
nice opening you get imbalance and
that's what you need right now you need
to play 92 castles okay Knight F3 is
also reasonable I thought Knight E2 was
quite logical as well but I guess she's
she's doing it this way
is not going to play F5 he's not going
to play Bishop G4 he has to not lose so
he doesn't
he doesn't care about aggression
uh Ruby one as well maybe it's also a
good idea to remind the audience that we
have a bunch of other matches starting
in the next maybe five to thirty minutes
I don't know if we have a Graphic that
we can just quickly throw on but we've
got a bunch of group E matchups today
that are just amazing and those mashups
are Jani bomshi versus Muhammad muradli
shafriya Muhammad Yara versus life
kovalev and Peter sudler versus Alexis
shirov so as Tamor and hoefan are going
to finish their final rapid game
or potentially an Armageddon and
potentially Armageddon I should say
that's what we have coming up as well
yeah no we're gonna have some great
matchups I see
uh the game between Mom and jarov and
kovalev just beginning we will stay here
we'll focus our Attention our attention
in this game because it is potentially
the last game of this match a must win
for who you found and where Java seems
to know what he's doing here he's he's
not spending much time he played through
a rook to B8 that way his Bishop is free
to develop along the diagonal he doesn't
have to worry about spawn he could play
B6 Bishop B7 as well that's where he
refers to have his Bishop but how does
he find like do something of note like
how does she create a threat where do
her pieces belong let me I don't really
know how she just gets a win out of thin
air yeah it's a very good question if
I'm being honest uh
because
she can only make so many improving
moves and then at some point she's gonna
have to move her pawns so she's gonna
have to play D4 A4 C4 maybe move the
Knight and play F4 uh of course now she
could consider Knight to D2 for just for
starters with the threat of Bishop takes
C6 which I don't believe that timura
Java is going to miss but then after
that she might have to play Knight C4
and Knight E4 maybe play F to F4 as I'm
speaking I'm convincing myself that
Knight D2 is maybe the best move like
after rookie one and whatnot but we'll
see yeah it just feels like black is
incredibly solid like Knight D2 as you
mentioned the 96 is hanging you don't
want to blunder that so the bishop can
just go out to D7 and maybe you're right
maybe the Knight does in fact go to C4
um but
yeah I'm not I'm not sold on this
especially based on her clock management
yes exactly
and it seems like she's sort of
improvising but
okay I mean you you play an opening like
this you probably do have to improvise
because this is not something that we
are seeing at top level a whole lot like
we'll just play D5 and get a very very
reasonable position
I don't know if we want to check in on
this Fiddler share of game I believe
that just started
how could you not want to check in on
Peter stridler well because because
shirov doesn't know this is moving
okay there we go Sicilian here we go how
much Theory are we gonna get
well it actually is I was gonna say
shocking sarcastically but it is
somewhat surprising to see the move C5
from sure because he puts a lot of E5 he
plays like the archangels how do you
pronounce that correctly I think I think
that's right but if you wanna you wanna
sound really cool you can say
exactly that and like those really sharp
lines on the black side of the Spanish
but he chooses the Sicilian against
Fiddler and maybe it's because Fiddler's
so wrapped up in 960 that he'll forget
how to play chess with the normal
starting position yeah he's sort of like
wobbling the head I mean the amount of
theory that is inside of Peter Fiddler's
brain about Chess he's there's a very
famous saying you know he's forgotten
more than I could ever remember it's one
of those situations should have coming
in with the uh the invitation to play
probably what was going to be a night or
Bishop B5 check and Peter's Fiddler
looks terrifying okay he looks like the
Undertaker
looks like he's showing up with the urn
with the name you know he's going to do
the whole walkout I mean he just looks
the lighting is facing in the opposite
Direction it feels like but it's giving
me a really cool effect well and sure of
is like he's like blinded by the Sun and
yeah does that make him Kane if uh
sphere is the Undertaker maybe yeah
maybe it does honestly uh C4 is a super
sideline by the way I I think that's
like
oh maybe
this is uh Sam sebians like pet line now
he's been playing this a lot yeah the C4
move in in these online events and yeah
he's played in the rapid Chess
Championship he's with his C4 move for
sure and he's scored some nice victories
yeah Bishop takes D7 has been played
about 40 000 times to one thousand of
the move C4 uh the move Bishop takes B5
cb5 scores 70 for white so it's just
important to kind of show like why
that's even the case why is this so good
it's just very restricting for black
right and white can develop play D4 just
play your sort of standard moves and
black is going to lack development this
Knight on V8 if you want to put the C6
ultimate A6 or something first it's time
consuming
yes exactly and white can
even just play D4 at some point and just
get a a really nice open Sicilian kind
of position and you see shirt off taking
some time
because C4 is very modern style Theory
and
um curious like you know maybe spitler
reviewed some of his files prior
I think the clearest thing of all though
is Fiddler does not want to get into a
tactical Skirmish at least not from the
outset with Shiro because when you've
the author of fire on board well these
two have been going at it for over 30
years so I think he knows Sheriff style
very well
absolutely
if you uh
yeah I think if you go to let me see
their head-to-head score
So In classical chess Fiddler had a 5-4
lead with 12 draws
in Rapid and exhibition it was 6'5 so
these guys are right I mean they're just
so close to each other wow in terms of
in terms of Chess skills separated by
just one game
extremely close matchup also quite a
main decisive games in their head yeah
because usually you see like 20 draws
and then one win a piece at least in
modern chess those two were slugging out
so let's go to uh the game between yonda
Palm Nashi and Muhammad Ali because
Ayan is the top player in his side of
the bracket so we're gonna bring a
beyond the palmistries game here
he is playing maradly and all right this
kind of stuff is very standard fare
these days taking over the C file
yep
uh rook fc1 and was this a Catalan
yeah nepo's been playing a lot of
catalans as of late
probably inspired by the world
championship and also just I think the
whole process of elevating his game to
number one number two in the world
status from just top five or just top
ten
I think adding the Catalan has been has
been you know very very nice for him I
was he much of a Catalan guy prior I
think he was like an E4 guy he was yes
he sorry yes he was the E4 guy he was
not a Catalan player but he started
dabbling and he had great success in the
variations I think it's really helpful
for him because uh sometimes he can he
was criticized for being impulsive as a
player moving too quickly uh just trying
to be a little bit too aggressive look
at this position there's nothing you can
do that is to outside the norm but you
can try to just claim your advantages
along the C file for Queen to A4 just
try to capitalize on having the better
night the knight in C3 versus the 97
that is why he took on D5 when he did
first of all I was under attack but
second of all there's no Knight to C6
coming your way so the Knight is already
committed to a bad Square because the
pawn three squares away from it
completely controls it
it's a very specific type of strategy
that only exists when the Black Knight
has already moved to D7 and that that is
when you're going to make that trade now
in terms of game plans from this point
after Rook fc1 what
love it love it H4 at any given moment
huh any time any place anywhere doesn't
matter that's just for you these days
right just throwing it sit suggest H4
it's probably one of the top three moves
yeah H4 it just seems like it's possible
anywhere in the Catalan I basically feel
like Jan took all his Catalan prep and
was like can I play H4 here okay can I
play H4 here okay like I'm just gonna
play H4 what are they gonna do and by
the way H4 for white is significantly
better than H5 by black
if I mean it's not the same thing at all
I don't really I don't know how to
explain it but it's just it's just true
in some ways H4 is a waiting move and
also creates Loft for the the King on G1
so there's ever some problem in the back
rank uh but it's like it lets you start
an initiative because this bishop on G2
not really doing that much is going to
change diagonals and it's not of the
question that you change to this one and
played G4 G5 as well especially if black
put the pawn H6 so B5 is the choice of
morale he's not going to sit around and
wait for uh Jan to show his cards he
said maybe I'll play B4 maybe I got the
Knight to B6 Rook to see it all this
kind of stuff so he's going for stuff so
let's uh
maybe head on back to the fun game just
because that's the fourth and final game
of regulation in their match so oh gosh
not surprising right Levy yeah not
surprising nearly a four minute time
Advantage for a job of who's sitting
there focused stoic like a boss he looks
like he's a he's attending a U.N
conference he's just like listening to
all the you know I feel like everybody
who attends the unconference they look
like that they just focused they have
the little thing on their ear that might
be translating and then they just they
just look stone-faced and you know he
looks super focused and I don't think he
wants to create another dramatic Moment
On The Board like we had at the end of
the last game
yeah no I think this is a really good
way of putting it he does look like he's
at a conference and uh right now I think
that ifan's looking at his position like
what in the world can I do here like
from the it's an uncomfortable position
to be in to have to win from move one
especially when you're playing a 2750 a
player like rajabo who just showed some
excellent form in the second half of the
candidates and now you have weak squares
see completely under black control A4
hanging Pawn great Bishops and the queen
placement for black so there's not a
single thing wrong in Black's position
who and my job is the better Pawn
structure so this is a nightmare for you
phone
absolutely absolutely the a palm is now
just gonna fall I guess what is there a
knight G5 trick is that what we're
I don't know
that's what she's hoping for but I mean
you can just look at her right she's got
her hand on her head she's not happy
about this whatsoever
I still find it incredible she was just
one or two clutch moves away in time
travel from potentially moving on to the
round of 32. it would have if your
brackets weren't demolished already
after that that would have that that
would have ravaged a few more uh
percentage points of accuracy he just
plays Queen C6
I actually really liked that decision
because you're protecting everything
node Knight G5 tricks you're putting
pressure down the diagonal and you just
trying to trade pieces with your knight
and F3 hanging you might have to move
your Bishop to D2 and the Knight comes
into C4 so I remember job of he knows
how to handle himself in such a dynamic
and I I mean I don't want to say she has
no chance of winning this game but she
has no chance of winning this game
yeah she really doesn't it the
difference in the last game was
we you kind of felt it tilting a little
bit in in the favor of Hawaii fun she
was putting up defenses but it felt like
rajaba wasn't executing the game plan to
finish the game finish the game off
here it really feels like the next punch
that white throws is going to be
countered so viciously it's just going
to be over and the problem is white has
to do that white has to do something
and I don't really know what that
something is
because
Knight H4 I mean I I yeah
just trade some pieces A4 still hanging
by the way over here so we'll go back a
second because she was Bishop B2 Queen
takes A4 this was ephon's one hope and
you see the evaluation actually go up in
her favor Knight G5 threatens a
checkmating attack over here so to show
you that Bishop takes Bishop is terrible
because you get in this position oh
sorry I'm in what ah my bad move the
bishop first I guess and then yeah okay
I was like I was also like what oh I
guess think okay yeah Bishop before yeah
this is why you don't just check for the
sake of checking the king would run away
so uh yeah you can't take on G2 so you
take on G5 and then this position is
exactly what you find would want not
just because the engine says better for
her but this attack looks a little bit
more legitimate G5 is hanging there's an
imbalance that actually is nice for her
to work with let's check in on shaukri
armor mediara versus vladislav kovalev
uh
uh that game is
very solid
Petrov
or what was this
D4 wow wait how did it get to where we
are oh they start trading things like
this yeah they traded everything his
line is wow easy for not Knight D4 but
ed4 what
Mama jar still you know he's warming up
to regular chess again he's winning the
Champions showdown in St Louis the 960
event so Knight takes D4 or like a very
standard move he said now let's take up
the pawn
I agree with you though I I the
symmetrical position here is not really
that appetizing it's really funny how we
just have three people competing at the
moment that are all like maybe staying
in the same building I don't know I
don't know what the situation is when
players travel from abroad to play in
the St Louis tournament but as long as
you know if they don't live there but
they're staying at a fancy hotel
uh it's sort of interesting there I'll
just maybe they're in the same Suite
just in different rooms they got a big
Suite
they get their own rooms there although
thriller's been there for so long that
he might be staying on the chess houses
uh because he was commentating for a
while but kovalev here he's doing the
real chess player thing where your head
gets cut off because it's the forehead
cam
yeah exactly oh this is an epic shot
look at this this is right this is how
you know you're watching a chess event
I mean
you know you know what I you know what I
think would be cool I think if sponsors
considered forehead real estate for
Logos like my forehead is enormous it's
way bigger than kovalev's it I could
easily fit on the entire screen and they
could slap a couple of those bad boys on
there and I mean at least not happily
take the commission
yeah it seems like you really do need
more sponsorship deals these days if
coffee uh companies and you know crypto
and whatever it is you I guess there's
there's always room for more listen
Robert in five to ten years nobody might
be playing chess ever again if companies
are going to pay me to have a logo up on
something I I will happily do it you
know what I'm saying like I uh those
I've I've
who wouldn't you know what I mean I mean
what what do these guys like to put in
their body food you know water sparkling
water I've learned over the last few
years that the categories of advertising
are are split and there's there's
multiple things that you you know you uh
you separate things into
um you know what would actually be a
really good chess sponsor
what a webcam that people could use to
not have their face smushed up against
the screen
[Laughter]
I feel like they would do super well
like a webcam that like adjusts to where
your placement is like auto adjust I
just yeah like you know the the next cgc
or whatever can be sponsored by and then
all the players would receive one and it
would look perfectly cropped they'd be
like yeah you know we you know you know
those presentations they do here's the
problem here's the solution
so
the problem is coming up with ideas what
what would check all your five head is
that right
uh yes I five head is that a that's an
emote isn't it I don't ever pay
attention to chat so I I think that's a
thing he's lying Chad Robert pays Robert
chat loves you you can't say that
I don't care what they think though
so it's a one-way thing it's an abusive
relationship but they just keep coming
back you know what I mean it's just
absolutely beloved uh I think this game
might just be a draw very soon I I don't
know I don't know how Mommy's here I was
gonna try to win this one but
symmetrical structure Bishop pair he has
a couple of things going for him but
that Knight on H4 is
uh I I think he found just blundered so
let's go over to her game because uh
that one is wrapping up this match he
actually did blunder
I saw it off the side of the screen she
would Rook b500 for Knight takes D2 she
takes her the queen she loses the night
she takes the Knight she loses the
bishop so how is this team still going
well evidently it doesn't matter if one
of the players is down a piece as we saw
in the last scramble admittedly right
now they have a lot more time this was
tough yeah
this was this was a tough game always
going to be tough to win with white on
demand
particularly when your opponent is a is
a is a candidate right like
how do you beat these guys ever how do
you beat them on demand
you don't for the most part unless
you're like dingly Ren winning the final
round of the candidates made the white
pieces so that's a big difference but
yeah this is
Bishop takes F3 seems pretty good maybe
D5 will be her response just to not lose
a piece directly ah yeah potentially
potentially yeah yes potentially
trying to uh maybe hmm oh A6 though
oh my gosh A6 is the 90 95 yeah 95.
if A6 is the best move that would just
be wild and I'm just like one of these
calm moves that
okay it does take
she plays B5 I mean D5
I wonder if there's a queen sack
somewhere
I don't know where but
Maybe
some rookie one
[Music]
it's just that simple
why is this minus four
I guess it just takes on A4 it takes on
E1 takes on A4
yep this is minus four it's amazing how
good these nnues stock fishes are yeah I
also am a little bit perplexed I must
say maybe it's rookie one Queen C2
maybe that losing that pawn is
substantial enough
I don't know I feel like there's
something significantly worse here but
it's just also like even if it's not
completely winning there's just no
chance for white to win that's the
problem is yep
some as you were saying with the proving
game like it's worth taking risks it's
worth having a losing position if you
actually have some optimism regarding
your winning chances but here it's just
terrible
604 and
all right well I think it's not
unsafe to say that we think that's
immoral Java will make it to the round
of 32 after a extremely dramatic third
game but a relatively smooth match
overall let's go take a look at some of
our later matchups that have begun Maybe
swiddler
and uh shirov please let's go back there
what the hell
what happened you know why this happened
this is this happened because shirov
played Bishop takes B5 he didn't play it
after C4 but at some point he played C
Bishop B5 and this structure is crushing
for white
it like I like I said oh my gosh she
just blundered a yeah this is a very
common mistake even uh even like newer
players make they they have a little bit
of a blind spot for just advancements in
the center that attack their Knights uh
shirov doesn't have that blind spot he
probably just kind of underestimated
this right that must have been what
happened he kind of just saw this was
like it's not a big deal but it is
this looks horrible for black like you
get to keep this Pawn your knight needed
defense because H3 would have come in
any moment and you would capture on H6
or at least the Rook defense but look at
look at Smither he just pushed his Pawn
up to A6 yeah I know it kind of looks
like a 960 position
it yeah it honestly does it looks like
black black started the game with a
chess 960 position yeah
wow Fiddler just
tip top shape here 92 Knight C4 looks
like the best positional game
just ever Knight C4 is coming H3 is the
is the next move and
okay well I think shirov is never going
to take the bishop on B5 ever again
lesson learned
it really goes to excuse me it really
goes to show you though
knowing Sidelines and the venom in them
even on the fourth move that was a move
four sideline that has been played less
than
three percent of games ever
right like that whole idea of C4 right I
mean that's it just shows you the powers
sure of is an incredible player but if
you're unfamiliar with Sidelines in an
opening as sharp as the Sicilian you
can't just play the Sicilian on feel and
okay obviously also can't play it on
field with 15 minutes on the clock
instead of 90. but
man I mean these openings are just
brutal we saw rajama play that A5 idea
that's barely been played before that
was played in the candidates now we see
the C4 Knight C3 idea the chess has many
many more years to develop I think it's
far from dead
yeah just don't take on f60 and take on
F6 it's how you lose a great position uh
although actually there's so many pieces
staring at this E5 Pawn that maybe
churro was not completely helpless here
maybe he's looking like he's gonna grab
that one
is there an F4 yeah there's also maybe
F3 first because you encourage this
capture and then try to go for F4 at
some point
like C4 Queen C4 looks really good I I
really don't want to let black Castle
right right but maybe it's fine maybe I
don't want to hang on to that too much
because maybe it's completely okay I
just gonna psych myself out
I got four also looks very good yes
after Fe you can put H3 there and kick
this Knight away yes spitler just has
four minutes to work this out and not
overthink it because if he overthinks it
he's gonna mess up
but if he underthinks it he might also
mess up
well you know Robert then we are in a
catch-22 and maybe maybe Fiddler just
won't move at all he'll just
maybe his time will hit zero but he
won't even flag because time is a social
construct
I don't know man
I'm also looking at Queen E4 by the way
yes of course Queen E4 and then
I don't know King F7
96 doesn't quite work but
well I do want to drag your king to F7
because then E6 will hang with check in
many of those positions but yeah it is
sharper than I gave credit for a common
idea in these types of positions is just
like go Queen to B7 yeah and that's it
what is that for now he takes your
advice and he plays calmly he doesn't
need to take any risks here he is a
strategically winning position
completely and should he get his A6
spawn to B7 he also has Knight B6
whenever he wants it
so it's it's a very very bad position
for sure I'm sure if the Queens came off
the board he would resign he would
would not even I mean he would not pull
apart of young although of course
paravian was trying to play and you know
save his chances but
I don't like I don't like the fact that
Peter Fiddler only has three minutes on
the clock he might also not like that at
the same time three minutes is more than
enough here to sort of uh
by the way can we just pull up the
players on the big screen
what is this crop I'm not this is not
our production team this is just two
chess players
who are playing chess online
this is an epic photo they're they're
about to pull it up on the screen for
all of you I'm seeing it here in our in
our loading screen I mean this is
terrifying
smithler looks like he's gonna follow
you home in an alleyway
and and shirov looks like he's ready for
the challenge like you could account for
me bro yeah this looks this is this is
crazy we got yin and yang here right
here it's a good Lord
I mean somebody wrote something
hilarious in the chat they wrote it's
incredible that Peter Fiddler has been
playing moves so well without even
having his monitor on
just staring at a completely black
screen yeah
arjun's actually playing for him from
India with those long arms oh my God I
know that's what
ah this is this is so this is just so
fun you know it's like many storylines
of all the player cams we're gonna have
a little uh
you know a little uh what are those
called compilations when the event is
over
and then we're gonna have somebody
complaining that it's disrespectful to
the players and whatnot yeah they're
also both big dudes
I know Sheriff's a big guy yeah they're
both they're both tall guys so maybe
maybe in the future we can you know we
can have a chess boxing exhibition what
do you think
I think that uh you know they've had two
prestigious of a careers to uh have that
moral degradation
but what if they were each paid seven
figures
yeah no maybe now we're talking yeah I
mean the moral degradation you know
are we talking about a potential mating
attack or is this just completely a
bluff it looks like it looks like a
bluff for sure but anything is possible
we've seen crazier things that
that Queen on C7 is yeah the queen on C7
is uh totally out of commission I think
we have we've been instructed to just
quickly switch over to ah the final
moves of the hoi fun game
she is down a few pawns and she's trying
to play it out but
there's nothing here I think she will be
residing in the next five moves probably
one
let's count them
two It's just sad when you have to win
and you're completely lost but you can't
resign because the match is over yeah
four was that the fourth or the third
I think that was the fourth
I kind of stopped counting and I think
she's about to resign
ah Levy called it
well yeah uh massive congratulations to
timura job of smooth sailing for about
98 of this match right Robert but it got
real dicey toward the end of game three
what uh he he just wanted you know he's
streamed before he knows what it means
to excite the fans
yeah the first two games of the match
were completely level like it felt like
we had two evenly matched players and
then game three she had a pretty good
position at some point after a terrible
opening right that went completely wrong
for her but then rajapa didn't seem to
uh fully uh maximizing then it was
perhaps even worse but she kept that
pawn then it got wild and her job of
ultimately is the one who made his way
through so let's go to actually the mama
jar of game because I looked at the
clocks and covers at 25 seconds yeah
that's another that's another really
tough thing about playing a guy like
Mommy Jarvis he's gonna play very fast
even in equal positions it's the same
thing we saw a job of doing I think
mommy's yarov and mvl might be two of
the fastest players what do you what do
you think about that claim and yawn yes
yeah of course yeah and yeah
um Levon is also quite fast but I feel
like he gets into time trouble a lot as
well so like Levon will sometimes play
super fast but also super slow it's like
a big mix but those three are probably
the three fastest players even in
positions where you can do nothing
they just yeah they're just very good at
doing nothing but very quickly
speed demons yeah bunch and right here
the last move was Knight F5 that night
has been stuck on the side of the board
for a while white has a past Pawn black
has an extra Pawn if you cut the board
in half from the e to the H file I like
Mama Jar's position at first glance but
the problem is if he takes on e4 once
the queen trade happens over here uh
black is going to win back this Pawn D5
so let's show that quickly if we get
this position here takes takes Rook D4
I'm gonna get D5 F5 will be just even
material it's an even game so I think
that Koval is doing everything you could
ask of him
I am worried about his clock
but if he can manage that then he'll be
in good shape with this Knight going to
blockade the past Pawn
absolutely
but I gotta tell you if black holds that
E4 Pawn sturdy
I kind of trust the horse
I mean I I know Bishop is better than
night in the end game
but somehow
I I don't know Knights are very tricky I
agree with you the 96 will be a very
powerful Pony so perhaps mom's yards
thinking do I just trade let's just
trade off the pieces in that position I
just showed so that if he if he realizes
too much risk then oh wait he's just
worse now
like he's obviously worse yeah I I don't
know what that was it's going to be the
pawns are coming F5 King F7 King F6 he's
playing Call of time travel
it's gonna backfire uh yeah does kovalev
have a bar missing
I see four bars
what about mommy's Arif four bars
oh then my my shading on my screen is
slightly incorrect okay I thought I
thought my bizarre had two bars with the
hotel Wi-Fi what is my bizarre doing
he's gone mad he's gone completely C8
give me that open file F4 check King up
to E5 as well okay apparently Rook C8
was not the right move I don't
understand anything about Chess but
no but you understood that allowing
black to blockade the pawn would just be
good news for kovalev here
are they somehow to stand still is that
why this is claiming equality or close
yeah I guess instead of taking the file
he had to get his King faster to the
center I still like Black's chances a
lot I don't understand how my Museum's
gonna try to break out of this I don't
know what he was thinking like why seven
seconds
so b665 maybe but even then what's the
plan I don't see a plan
yeah thankfully for White Mountain
drivers all these squares under control
and C1 included so The Rook can't
exactly do much damage in the open file
and
it's
three do you want to take this Pawn the
Knight takes
is is getting getting a little bit
naughty here he's actually trying to
play this for a win which is crazy FeFe
he has some Rook F1 King E5 like it's
okay there's Knight E4 uh oh
B3 stars get good for what five seconds
gotta go call Love You Gotta Move yeah
he's Gotta Move Gotta Move gotta move
one second
and Bishop D3 now there's Knight C5 so
that covers the E6 square is there B4
here oh my gosh I actually love the
thought of B4
but that's a good move as well and it's
probably time trouble really good place
official C6 and King C4 King B5 yeah was
winning
oh 0.3 seconds where that move was
played yeah yeah kovalev knows that he's
messed it up
non-stop pressure in this game
yeah
I mean there's a decision yeah whoa whoa
whoa Knight is loose in C5 yeah yeah I
thought for a second there was no king
before night Knight D3 but that's it the
pawns have joined you can probably even
take but just no need
B7
me 785 King B3 right easy right let's
take this pawn and now you're up
essentially two pawns this black spawns
a double over here and rookie eight
should oh rookie it's a blunder
because once the tram is Knight C5 takes
B7
yeah Rook E3 and I this is just such a
such a mummy jar of esque game
you know grinding them down in a
potentially equal position taking some
calculated risk the only time this
backfires for chakra is at the highest
level like if you try to mess around
maybe against uh really good Defender
like mvl or uh even even against Magnus
they they will immediately switch the
whole Tempo on you but in this case
online opponent has 10 seconds
we're just seeing the level right which
ultimately we are seeing the level every
matchup has a favorite and there we go
movies are of wins huge win there for
Shakura mamajarov uh we also have two
other games going the one oh my gosh
let's get mated while spiller's Pawn
promotes that's nasty also somehow share
of his opponent G2 as well
yeah both guys here are are creating
Queens except one guy is getting mated
and the other guy's not and there it is
Fiddler wins game one big victory for
Peter let's go to the last game still in
progress is Jan napomnushy taking on
Muhammad muradli and maradly in a losing
position right now a white is can just
take this pawn and go up a pawn there's
a pin over here that looks like nearly
trapped after Knight A5 but there is
Rook D7 and okay Jan's winning it with
the Knight
yeah Rook D7 Knight F5
uh and then Jan by the way winning the
same way
you know what kind of way he's winning
the Argent aragaisy Way
no Jan's winning the yawn way all right
Jan pioneered the way of playing four
minutes ahead and just crushing people
uh and yeah I'm gonna win so all the
favorites have have won uh their matchup
although in the matchup who was the
favorite by the way what was the what
was there a vote between Fiddler and
Sheriff what people thought oh yeah I
can pull up that data
to see it looks like
56 of people chose Fiddler and as Nepal
machine wins his first game but a 56
heads Fiddler over Sheriff that's I
think the closest predictions we've had
thus far
uh that concludes the first rapid game
in
three of our matches that have a
slightly later start today versus
Muhammad muradli shakurai versus
vladislav kovalev and uh Peter Fiddler
versus Alexa shirov a decisive game was
won by the white pieces in every single
game in the nepo game and the swiddler
game it was basically start to finish
Advantage but in the momentar of game it
was topsy-turvy and he tried to you know
squeeze uh
I I don't know the juice from the fruit
for for quite a long time almost got
himself into a little bit of trouble and
obviously from the top matchups that you
see there Eric icing moves on and rajaba
moves on uh Robert before we go full cam
uh maybe we want to take a look at the
bracket just real quick just to see what
uh
what that situation means so now Eric
Garcia and rajabov is officially a
matchup that is done they have played
each other online many many times in
2020 and 2021 and the rest of today we
will figure out whether nepo will move
on to face swindler or verse or shirov I
mean the truth is that nepo is an
overwhelming favorite against more oddly
I think if Bradley scores a couple draws
if if morale scores a win that would be
a gigantic uh upset I mean it would be
Monumental and he should absolutely
celebrate that accomplishment Jesus
needs to he just needs to not get out in
three that's honestly what I feel
yeah and I feel like when we've seen
from the number one seeds of Bruce
dingly rent lost game one against men
and that's what made it a match as soon
as the top speed wins game one and
convincingly
I don't really believe in the Underdog's
chances anymore so with all respect to
Muhammad Ali he's a great player he'll
become even better he's young but
Junior's speech has changed this year he
just won the bill a Swiss tournament so
that's a big option ahead of kariel
lexenko super Grand Master so he has a
really bright future but losing game one
to Beyond the Palm Tree of all people
his chances are not zero but they're
close to it yeah you can kind of
immediately see the confidence level and
uh like the the level difference right
some some first games are Topsy service
some aren't in any case we're gonna take
a quick break and when we return we will
continue covering the games of group e
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
to anyone
all around the world the chess.com
Global Championship offers the dream of
playing against the best
and hey have we mentioned there's also a
million dollars at stake the total pot
is a million dollars no that it's not a
typo the prizes are unbelievably
generous we began with thousands of
players now only dozens remain there it
is oh my God Eric Hanson this is crazy
Eric Hansen moves on to the round of 32
in Armageddon fashion The cgc Knockout
phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real hey one second
boom's Gonna Fly
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends it's the cgc round of 64. who
will take the next step to Toronto
I'll do it and we are back here at the
2022 chess.com Global Championship you
see two of our competitors on screen
Peter Spindler and Lexi share of Legends
of the game and speaking of Legends I am
joined by I was gonna say Levy Roslyn
but in fact it is Grandmaster Daytona
raditzki Dania thanks for stopping by it
is love your husband I just changed my
name this morning I'm back from the name
changing office but it's great to be
here nothing like starting off a day the
extended weekend with a heavy dose of
cgc
and if anyone knows you it you're
somebody who reveres the Legends The
Luminaries and Peter Fiddler and Alexis
sharov they really don't need an
introduction to our long time chess
playing audience but for some of our
newer fans and people have joined in
recent years Donna why don't you tell
everybody who these two players are
well all I'm gonna say about Alexi
shirov is that he published a memoir a
collection of his best games and he
called it fire on board and it's not one
of those cases uh you know if somebody
you know calling themselves something
that they are not when Alexi shirov
touches the chess pieces the board
explodes he was top 10 in the world for
many many years he played Gary Kasparov
dozens of times and Peter svidler Robert
if you don't know who Peter Sidler is
where have you been what rock have you
been living under
uh well some people like SpongeBob
SquarePants and there is a rock that you
live under there so you know teach their
own but of course Peter's filler a
renowned commentator but before he
worked on his commentary shops he was
one of the best players in the world He
Still Remains one of them and he has a
one-nil lead against his esteemed
opponent Alexis shirov
wow and uh sureov he can win with either
color the dangerous thing about playing
him is that he plays for a win equally
with black as he does with white and you
have to be very very careful not to get
his type of position in the opening
well it looks like shirov I'm not sure
he's aware that it's his turn the clocks
have started uh we'll see what happens
here pondering the complex position
s
in case you didn't know that he played
the Sicilian after like a bit of a thing
so it is possible he's just trying to be
frustrated you think it's frustrated
because he lost game one well he just
kind of shook his head there I think he
might have
you know been too focused on reflecting
on the meaning of life
but now he's going to have to having to
reflect on the meaning of the grunfels
he can expect that because you're
playing one of the world's leading
experts in the group of Peter swindler
it's his tried and true opening we've
seen a lot of H4 in recent months
against this grunfeld setup but sure of
he's a classical player he is playing
the long time main line
yeah Bishop B3 and Knight F3 one of many
very reputable variations uh quite often
black puts his Queen on A5 in these
kinds of variations white responds with
Queen D2 and then we get this end game
after C takes d4c takes D4 the grundfold
is a very multi-faceted opening you get
a lot of end games you get a lot of
middle games uh and it all depends on
the line that white chooses
and I wonder what shirov is aiming for I
think Fiddler's he's pondering the same
thing because he does play Queen A5 as
you were just mentioning Diana there's a
queen trade being offered on the D2
Square here and you may say shirov and
games just because he prefers tactical
chess does not mean he's not a superstar
in the end game especially when you have
a strong Center in fact I've told this
story before I'll say it again at the
end of one of the U.S Chef School camps
with GM Gregory kaidanov he gave
homework assignments to all of the
students in the camp and everybody was
getting really fun assignments uh put
together a collection of Mikhail tall's
Queen sacrifices look at morphy's best
wins then he gets to me look at Alexi
shirov's best end games what sure off
end games why do I get the lamest
homework assignment I'm gonna find three
of them in his career I ended up riding
a chess.com article on it I had some of
the best times of my life putting
together that collection of sure of's
end game brilliancies you will not
believe the amount of tactical end games
that he has played and how he's managed
to carry over his style with a queen's
absent from the board and I ended up
producing an article on it and uh I
changed my mind on it completely he's a
beast of an endgame player he also is
one of the most famous end games of all
time is win over vestling to paulov with
that actually I won't say the move go
look up that it's a it's a puzzle
everywhere I won't give you the solution
but if you haven't seen it you're about
to be wowed and well speaking of wow the
light Square pawns here for sheriff in
the center for those who are not
familiar with the grunfeld this looks
overwhelming for black to deal with but
Dania we know that Fiddler can be
trusted uh you know you play The King's
Indian which is kind of like a more
aggressive cousin of the grunfeld in a
way but when you see this type of
dynamic do you think that Spiller he's
right at home here or sure of doing the
right thing trying to punish Thriller in
his main repertoire well there's no
denying that optically it looks like
white is better there's this Pawn on D5
it's protected by two other Pawns
but the thing is the groomfield is kind
of built different
um very often the pawn structure and the
Greenfield is deceiving because white
has these long-term Trump cards in the
position but black is a very clear
system of putting serious pressure on
White Center and here you often see
black going B6 then in the long run
maybe getting a knight to D6 putting the
bishop on A6 and pressuring C4 and with
the center clogged up like this it is
very difficult for white to make
progress in the center yeah you have the
pawn on D5 congratulations well what are
you gonna do with it and you often see
White's initiative kind of withering
away
uh very quickly as as we enter the end
game phase
yes it's true I mean it does look like
it should be almost winning for white
because of this Pawn structure uh but
black can also fight against it with B5
at some point especially if it's the
king taking on D2 so we see shirov he's
taking his time here uh I don't know if
this means he's unfamiliar with the
specifics it's like he's the one who
chose to play C4 but he's just trying to
remember decades-old Theory and work
that he's put in in this variation uh
but yeah what did I prepare for Valeria
Saul up in the 1990 linars tournament
I was not expecting to hear that name
today but I can trust you to hit us with
the legends of the past and some of the
top players and you know when John Elvis
and I when we duked it out in the PCA
rapid tournament
no that's exactly right but King takes
you to Knight takes you to both I think
entirely viable Knight takes C2 has the
benefit of opening up a path for the F
Pawn
their first game between these two was
the Arnold cup in 1991 and Sheriff won
that game but the second game that they
would just decisive that sheriff also
won was played in tilburg of course it
was it was tillberg 1996. yeah yes
they're over here to tell some stories
about that particular game
I honestly just went to chess games.com
to see their history and that's what I
found he does stick with the bishop
which surprised me because that Bishop
was
attacking this opponent C5 and you
mentioned that Knight could have
recaptured I also thought The King was a
feasible way to take that Queen but he
takes to the bishop so what's his plan
I think you might want Bishop C3 to
exchange the dark scored Bishops
now it doesn't immediately strike me as
self-evident that the exchange of
Darkseid Bishops benefits white because
again in the end game it's not like
you're going to orchestrate an attack on
Black's King although maybe you are I
mean maybe you will play H4 H5 at some
point later on
not totally out of the question but yeah
my guess is he wants Bishop C3
well Bishop C3 you know trading off the
Bishops he does have the Fantastic punch
over here so
doesn't want to sit and do nothing he
needs to figure out his Queen set over
here none of these pieces are developed
the bishop D7 who cares it's not a good
developing Square you mentioned the
positive of a B6 move
um and that's what Spiller chooses so
what's the what are the next three moves
for Schindler what's his setup exactly
yeah well I guess Bishop A6 to pressure
the C4 Pawn
then maybe Knight I mean don't have too
many options for where the Knight goes I
guess Knight D7 I'm gonna make a go out
on a limb here and actually your idea
looks interesting Bishop A6 Knight D7
but the problem is Rook AB8 can be met
with A4 white can stop a move B5
whenever he wants to so maybe the knight
from D7 jumps into E5 or maybe it moves
on to F6 in order to put pressure on the
E4 pawn and provoking E5 Robert in these
situations can be very very good for
black because that can cause White
Center to implode
that's true and I think that many people
would refrain from playing a movie like
Bishop A6 worried that after d takes E6
F takes E6 there's an isolated Pawn but
this Rook on d8 is the happiest piece
once this D5 Pawn leaves so it's worth
saddling yourself with an isolated Pawn
that could be vulnerable at some point
because the opening of the file and this
Knight gains access to the C6 square if
this Pawn is not in D5 so I think that
for a large part of this game sheriff is
going to want to keep this Pawn right
there blunting Black's forces
yeah this is an end game structure that
Peter spitler has had for over 20 years
and he just seems a lot more comfortable
than Alexa here Alexi has already spent
over five minutes trying to figure out
how to arrange his pieces
and in an end game this complicated you
don't want to drop to five minutes you
know before you've even finished
developing your pieces
true and so as shirov continues to think
maybe we should take a look at some of
the other games that have just begun we
have janapamshi taking on Muhammad
muradli so I think we'll switch on over
to that game between the number one
player in his group Beyond the Palm
Street by rating taking on Muradi who
Diane I mentioned he won the Beale
tournament ahead of Korea lexenko they
tied for first the Swiss tournament
that's held famously in Bill where they
also have uh around Robin of with rapid
and uh 916 classical with the some of
the top players but he's a great player
in his own right but he's playing John
de palmistry who's determined as ever he
won the candidates he won the rapid
Chess Championship it seems like more or
less every event he plays in he's vying
for first in the syncful cup he tied for
first place right with um alireza
farouza so yeah nepo's in great form
he's on a roll right now he's in one of
those phases where every tournament he
plays and you're just expecting him to
be in the top three
I mean and and the way he's playing he's
always playing
with a great deal of confidence you know
no matter
what kind of a role he's in what kind of
a momentum he's on you know nepo's style
is nepo style but after the candidates
he has been an absolutely Unstoppable
Force he's playing so quickly he's he's
playing with such intensity he's putting
so much pressure with both sides that
it's it's become just almost unbearable
to play him for a lot of people
and the clock 14 minutes 57 seconds for
a young apology they're 12 moves into
this game there is the two second
increment but he has lost three seconds
from a starting time whereas morality
he's trying to figure this out there's
an isolated Pawn here can I remove the
guard of the isolated pawn put the B2
Pawn will fall at the end of the
sequence so this is known theoretical
territory at least it's known to yonda
palmshi from muradli who lost game one
Donya if he doesn't win this game he's
thinking well my chances might be behind
me
yeah and D4 is potentially coming
everything is nicely positioned for
black I think nepo has already
mostly solves all of his opening
problems
and Muhammad muradli cannot afford to
make a quick draw with the white pieces
here after losing game one like you said
he takes an F6 I mean Eon doesn't allow
this decision without knowing his stuff
Knight takes D5 is a fork of the queen
and this bishop of B2 is hanging so it
looks like young the Palm should he's
feeling good about his chances right now
so while we have a moment and while
morale is thinking whether or not to
take this Pawn we should go to our third
match in session the game between
chakriar mamajarov and vladisoft kovalev
you were in the process of joining the
show and getting ready for that but what
happened down the stretch of that game
was mamajarov he took a huge risk in
fact he made some moves that led kovalev
to have a borderline winning end game
but it's because krobo did not have much
time so we're going to switch to that
game uh between Mom and jarov and
kovalev now
so
we see that it's already in an end game
where black is upon ahead Dania but this
Pawn E4 may not be so long for the board
and well what do you make of all this
I mean it's pretty clear to me that
white is not worse here I think because
the white Bishop is coming out to F4
and it's going to attack the D6 pawn and
The Rook is very quickly joining the
game from D1
so it doesn't seem that white is risking
being worse but I don't think black is
honestly risking that much too let's say
black plays Bishop F5
white plays Bishop F4
attacking D6
then let's say black plays even like
Rook d8 maybe there's a more accurate
way of arranging your pieces here Rook
D1 but even this like 96 Bishop takes D6
and this is opposite card Bishops black
and stick in H5 maybe to discourage G4
maybe white is a little bit better in
the way that I in the line that I showed
but
I think that something like this should
give black
virtually virtually no problems
I agree well let's look
I was distracted by trying to recognize
the brand of sparkling water that
Cavalia was drinking
I know what it is actually anyways what
is it it's nabaglavi it's a a Georgian
sparkling water brand
and it's a distinctive green bottle
anyways continue I would have had no
idea I was gonna take us back in time to
the opening where look at this Donya I
haven't seen this since like childhood
Bishop C5 Knight G5
and take on F7 like this is what I
learned when I was like seven years old
where you can give this check win this
bishop on C5 but I remember learning
that it's a whole bunch of nothing I
don't think D5 is something that I
remember so I won't like pretend like I
know every single move here but look at
this position just like Ridiculousness
how do you teach a beginner this
no you you can this is something that
comes
directly out of experience and out of
preparation but what most people don't
understand is that GMS are often just as
Clueless and positions like these are as
beginners are they actually feel like
beginners these types of situations
yeah because it's like you're on your
own like you haven't looked at this for
years and years and years but Mama Jara
plays the sensible Queen D6 trading off
the queens and as we saw in the game
position you weren't too concerned with
Black's position I mean the eval bar
does say they would plus one after the
move Rook to E8 so I'm sort of wonder if
there's like a bishop E3 Knight B5
because Knight C7 is a fork and D6 will
be hanging
yeah that's it's entirely possible that
that's what it is and if black snipe
jumps to F5
there there is the possibility of
playing G4 at some point
to dislodge that night and after I take
C3 the F Pawn captures with a check but
I don't know when you can use that card
or whether you should use it at all I
agree maybe Knight B5 and Rook C1 go
down the C file and exploit Black's lack
of development
and this A7 Pawn is hanging in some
variations as well D6 will be loose so
kovalev I mean I think he's doing a
smart thing when you need to win a game
and here he's just coming up with
something that Mama drove could not
possibly have looked at recently and
he's well ahead in the clock
yeah he is
he is and
he has as good of a position as he can
really ask for against someone in my
media's caliber
serious chances here to win this game
out of right out of the gates
for sure so I like what he's doing here
it looks like a good attempt and
yeah I like his possibilities relative
to some of the other people who have
lost their first game so should we head
on back over to one of the other games
yeah maybe we should look at sure of
again real fast am I seeing this right
does he have how much time does Alexi
shirov have on his clock
not a lot so I'm moving over to this
thing here four minutes
all right there's a reason his whole
Center is collapsing and no
but everything's falling apart he's
getting destroyed look at his Center
and black has a past Pawn on C5 and the
Knight on A6 is now perfectly positioned
I wonder how Peter Fiddler ended up
setting up his pieces to Grant himself
this
incredible position how did this happen
can we can just rewind like five or six
moves it's only move 18 like we've left
off it's crazy right here on move 13 so
five moves ago B6
Stiller immediately took and apparently
look at this no CD's bad here allowing
F5
yeah the bishop trade and then the quick
F5 and now White's much worse but Dania
when we teach people chess we say
capture towards the center ed5 is not
really capturing away from the center
but having two unopposed Pawns in the
center would sound like a good thing but
black is able to just challenge it so
quickly with F5 and now Spiller is much
better
no ripped to White Center and
this is you know you you awaken the
Beast by going into a grunfeld with
arguably along with mvl the leading
world's expert on the grundfile then
you know I'm I'm pretty shocked that
that sure I've recaptured the C Pawn
this F5 idea is really as old as the
hills Robert so there was clearly some
sort of
complete you know mental breakdown here
for Alexian he's now down to two and a
half minutes he might just end up losing
this game within five moves that's not
an exaggeration if you drop the D5 Pawn
you're busted I mean that three on one
on the queen side goodbye and the clock
obviously doesn't help matter so Fiddler
who won the first game with white and
that was a really nasty game now in game
two he plays his pet line and used it
with great effect so Sheriff's on the
verge of being eliminated from this
tournament
oh man Alexi yeah losing with white here
he'll go down zero two
and he will need not only fire on board
but a miracle on board to pull out two
more victories against Peter spielder
apparently Jana pomichi I heard is also
winning
can we check if that is fake news
let's see if it is the truth and we're
gonna go to this game and Beyond the
Palm she it is not he's not just winning
he's completely winning he has two
Bishops
and upon for Rook how did this happen we
left off here and at 13 minutes on the
clock laughs
oh my gosh oh no
no so this Rook went to B1 because if
the other one Rook went to B1 Rook takes
D5 still works but also the queen and
Bishop were lining up against this Rook
so just Rook takes D5 as a blender and
Rook C5
do you think that's what he missed Rook
C5
because he he played Quincy for pretty
quickly
and there's no other moves I guess he
spent a lot of time at The Rook C5 so he
didn't realize that what do they I mean
it's like crazy pieces but there's like
a specific well my friend calls it
Renegade Rook okay that's actually I
like that a lot of renegade Rook
distracting the queen away from the
defense of the bishop 182 and that's
exactly what happened and now nepo just
mopped up material and he's I'm gonna go
up 2-0 as well
no this is over
he's got two Bishops two pawns on the
queen side the d-pawn is safely
restrained
12 minutes and 42 seconds only nepo has
that amount of time after like 20 moves
I think white can simply resign here
young just playing out of this world
like I'm not just saying in this
particular game just in general the
class he has shown in recent years it is
in new yawn for sure
can you explain to me why you didn't
just go Bishop G4
sorry to derail the conversation
G4 Queen C6 Rook C8
was there a reason or am I crazy
I think he's just playing quickly he
like knows he's completely winning so he
yeah I guess he's just trying to you
know signal to morale right get on with
it just resign resigning man
yeah great Bishops covering the pawn but
the longer you give someone chances
usually the better it is for the side
that's worse but I think Jana is
look at him he's moving instantly don't
take this because the queen be a check
the one blunder to actually you can
still do that can't you
no you you just can't I thought you were
saying
yeah no no it's one of us I was saying
but at first it's like oh if this Rook
gets distracted then the E1 work is
hanging but Jan is just gonna boop boop
boop boop
yeah now Peter is in the chat and making
me credit him for Renegade for inventing
Renegade Rook
all right hats off for this amazing car
I wouldn't have been able to explain
this concept without that term
there'd be no way to refer to it
no not at all well let's uh move on from
this game because it's very clear that
young Palm she's gonna take a 2-0 lead
uh shirov you know he's trying to fight
back he's down to one minute so we'll go
to that game here uh it's oh yeah yeah
really bad the Knight can survive and
come back towards the center if needed
and our three extra pawns on the queen
side enough
no I think you need a deep one on an
epon I don't think it's Fiddler is
really known for being able to win with
three extra pawns on one flank
wait did he play Knight A2 or did he
capture a pawn there that would be
pretty Savage if you played Knight A2
idea Knight c394. he did take a pawn
there so
uh he grabbed it
no Bishop F4 Alexis only faint faint
chances to keep the D6 Pawn alive and
try to go after the the F5 Pawn Robert
was something like Knight H4
but you can just tell by his body
language that's not going to happen
after Knight E4
you can essentially sign the death
warrant
nope and then the eight or nine oh
that's nice because the bishop you trade
you win the pawn the visual goes to G3
F4 is push D6 Falls this means two nil
for svidler so uh honestly it's kind of
surprised by how lopsided this match has
been done you weren't on the call for
game one but it was just a really an
obliteration
yeah no and this one is as well even
Bishop D6 and Rook takes Bishop takes C5
and Rook takes D6 you can give up the F5
pawn and just start pushing the a pawn
that should be plenty plenty sufficient
you can even potentially sack the Knight
on D5 but I'm sure Peter will
probably take his time and try to find
the most clinical option perhaps it's
rookie eight perhaps it's the immediate
A5 but the result of this game is not in
question
no so Spiller he is going to take this
one you see him in the hello darkness my
old friend but it's getting a little bit
brighter in his room and I'm sure it's
gonna brighten up his day as he plays
some 960 later in the Champions Showdown
but these two legends always glad to
have them on screen in the tournament by
the way Jana Palm she has officially won
his game so let's go to the mama jar of
game against kovalev because kovalev had
a nice opening he was giving Mama jar of
some fits uh to some extent and now
we're in a position where Mom and Jarvis
suddenly completed winning a second game
by the way Donna where two minor pieces
look like they're gonna be one for a
rook but I think what vladislav has
forgotten is that Mohamed Arab can
sacrifice The Exchange
and amass a totally devastating
Pawn failing so in the center just plays
D5 bcbc how did this happen I mean once
again
a total breakdown here for a lot of slaw
Bishop Chief Bishop D7 wow
Mama jar look at this so I think part of
it is that when Bishop takes E7 to
realize the backwards capture takes away
right you would think King takes you
said of course but Mom and jar of the
situational awareness taking away all
these Knights Retreats and then after
Rook here Bishop C6 cutting off the
circulation of rook and I die this is
gorgeous geometry
yeah the top player is really firing on
all cylinders this tournament some
caution is still required I would say
that compared to the sure of game this
is a little bit more double edged
but in such positions like it's just a
matter of time Black's gonna go D4
and then either you're gonna push all
the pawns C4 C3 or you're going to
activate the Knight through D5 and
there's too many entry points there's C3
there's F4 one way or another white
trucks are going to get overwhelmed
yeah nice to have win King of the Hill
and have all your pawns around it so now
this is
really wonderful tactical awareness by
Mama Jara I'm very impressed by that
sequence because you know kovalev did
not see it coming
no no and he's trying to do whatever he
can to slow down this process but chakra
of another guy who is not very familiar
with time pressure
and here as well he has managed his time
excellently and he's got
over seven minutes uh to nail the final
Nails in the coffin
and he goes see so that's kind of odd
because now yeah yeah you have the field
goal posts over here you know going on
and it just looks odd right normally you
want your pawns to travel together but
maybe a c-force first D4 is next and the
King's coming to D5 you win King of Hill
that way
yeah normally you want to avoid this
formation if white is a minor piece to
stick on D4 especially at night
but here yeah white can play Rook D1 but
his control over the D4 square is purely
temporary black and play C3 or black can
involve the Knight on C6 or F5 and it's
only a matter of time before he's able
to play D4 as you're saying
that's right
and
those past pawns uh Spiller had three
unopposed past pawns on the queen side
Mama jarov now has a bunch of them in
the center and on the C file here so for
kovalev it's one of these moments Donnie
I feel like you consider not resigning
exactly but you know you're lost and
you're just like how do I confuse my
opponent
yeah it's a terrible Temptation because
you know that you know 99 times out of
100 the result of the game is not in
question but you're you're hoping
against hope and waiting for your
opponent to make a move
in these cases is an excruciating
feeling that we're all very familiar
with
and you look at mamajarov he's not
entertained he's just like okay so
another day in the office yeah he's
leading the champion Showdown he's four
and a half out of six in uh Fisher
random just 960. so Mama jar of yeah oh
he's in St Louis
so rapid and Blitz
sweater on I think I think I recognized
the sweater there yeah that's that's
definitely a wrapping in Blitz sweater
the logo the logo is unmistakable
it's in the form of an art of the arch
yeah and we we had a off screen a
close-up of him you could see this at St
Louis so it's definitely a stainless
rapid and Blitz uh sweater there and oh
he's looking focused he's also looking
like he's about to go up to nil the king
went to E2 but the king's not going to
help out very much I'm tempted to go D4
bring the Knight into the game how can
black not win this weird question maybe
weird framing but how is black going to
spoil this if is all possible
I think the only way is for somehow
White's King to reach D4 no it's
impossible you just go D4 the thing is
it's impossible to lose any of your
pawns maybe D4 Rook B4
but for example after work before if you
play D3 check
and then after King D2 all of a sudden
you have some hard you have a hard time
defending the C4 Pawn but even here
there's tactics you can play
all right maybe C3 Rook takes C3 that's
how you spoil it C3 Rook C3 works you
think oh I'm gonna go Knight D5
and you forget about the Intermezzo Rook
takes C4 check
that's this is one way I'll always find
a way trust me it's really important
because the king wouldn't have to attack
The Rook so then the Rook will take the
Knight and then it's going to be an even
end game as you see based on the
evaluation bar so that's actually a good
thing to note because Rook before was
just played and if you're getting
careless by just throwing your pawns
forward that's how you don't win this
game so I
honestly it's important to point that
out because even though we're not
playing once you are in a game like that
you want to be aware of what tricks and
traps your opponent has
by the way after D3 King D2 if you go
King D5 White's gonna go King C3
and again I think all of a sudden black
has a bit of a hard time figuring out
a a proper arrangement for his pieces
because he's tied down to the C4 C4 Pawn
refraining from D3 and going King D5
straight away which probably is the
wiser option
you can even block with his Rook here
because these two pawns are going to
keep going up the board but one thing
that white would love is to trade these
pawns I think because right now it's
like a two and a half on zero because
this Pawn will protect the D3 square but
if you're able to trade these here uh
let's like just sort of
have this happen right if you trade
these off it feels like black has some
chances to go wrong here whereas if you
just leave all three of them here I
don't know how you're gonna stop all
these pushes
no it's over
the game is over and I think the idea of
going King I think he's going to go King
D6 here
so that after a rook before he can go D3
King D2 C3 and there's no Intermezzo
check on e4 so the same line we looked
at if white goes Rook D4 and you can
even go King C5 or an id5 yeah
well it's a very important distinction
so the King on E6 a lot of Rook takes E4
with check the King on D6 you can even
play this as Daniel's pointing out uh
you have a winning king of Pawn in game
up a pawn so that's really important mom
and jarov he plays King to D6
I mean the guy is just playing out of
his mind right now
yeah not a chance here is granted to
Cavalia
C3 and D3 is coming and
he will have to win two in a row
in order to stay in this match and two
in a row against chakra Muhammad yarov
is
a feat that very few of us have ever
managed
good luck if any
it's interesting though because you know
when you think about certain opponents
like David paravian was down two nil to
Arjun earlier and you know David is
going to play for you know you could
play all out right he doesn't mind if he
loses the game he's going to try to win
some players you know when they're just
gonna mail it in they're like okay I'm
down to nothing I'm black in the next
game just make a draw whatever I know
I'm getting eliminated so we'll see if
kovalev has the fighting Spirit
necessary to even put up a challenge to
Mom and jarov I mean it is possible you
know it's a rapid time control
anything can happen if you can unbalance
the position at the very least to give
yourself a chance
but yeah it is just so hard to convince
yourself that you have any chances
whatsoever
of staying in the match
right and two pawns and a knight for The
Rook I mean that decision where was it I
was gonna go back again this like right
here just the awareness tactically to
understand that this bishop G5 move
looks annoying if it's by Rook D7 your
Rook is blocking your Bishop he says no
let me play Bishop to D7 you take my
Rook I take your knight and attack your
rook in F1 that's a bad trade for white
so Knight C7 just what a sequence now
look at that taking a rook for a bishop
as a blunder that doesn't happen very
often but he needed to just move his
night out uh save his piece but instead
what happens is this Knight does
everything it protects this Rook very
important it took away the D5 Square
yeah and now protects the Rook so Knight
B5 takes
unfortunately for white it's protected
so that was a really cool sequence as we
get to the kind of final touches of this
game King E5 played Knight F4 check is
available Knight C3 check at some point
C3 D3
oh gosh
yeah what did you mentioned is another
calling card of top players the fact
that they just almost never punish
tactical or almost never
uh permit you to get away with tactical
blunders at a slightly lower level you
do see moments of mutual tactical
blindness like the same resource being
missed by both sides but if you watch
the games of these top players
they literally anytime you make any sort
of tactical blunder they exploit it
regardless of who they are
and we saw that again here
you know how we were saying that
sometimes you're worried about your
opponent using the D4 Square this black
king can just jump right into D4 play C3
check for sure but the king is joining
the party and it's a party for one
because kovalev is not invited
and one more Push by these pawns is
gonna end the game I would play C3 and
then King D4
yeah in order to be able to meet Rook A4
check with uh Rook C4
just to keep all of your piece although
then maybe Rook takes oh
Rook takes C3 no but this is just a lost
end game right King E5 for science
yeah good try vladislav but it ain't
gonna cut it
certainly not these two pawns here and
yeah yeah I wear this
so after F3 just don't take on F3 yeah
that's the only truck yeah whatever you
do
so we can show you after this game
concludes I think Blossom might just
resign and the next few moves
he played A4 and resigned but without a
waiting for his opponent's response if
you take on F3 look at the evaluation it
goes to zero so that's the thing you're
told to trade when your head material in
the end game but you're gonna lose this
D3 Pawn after just G takes so that's why
King E5 is so important A4 now you can
take because you have King F4 winning
this Pawn so you still need to be
precise you still need to calculate the
end game but Dania we have three matches
in all three matches have a two to
nothing leader
yeah and if we see even one comeback
that would be absolutely miraculous to
win two games on demand but Robert we
have already seen in the first two days
of the cgc crazy comebacks we have seen
quite a few on-demand wins with the
black faces and you know if that is any
indication of what we're about to see
and you should not go anywhere because
some of these players they have the
heart they have the passion they have
the opening preparation
uh in place to make a crazy comeback I'm
particularly interested in how Alexi
Shira is going to handle his Monumental
task that sits in front of it
it'll be interesting to see and we will
find out just a few here at the 2022
chess.com Global championship
[Music]
foreign
to anyone
all around the world the chess.com
Global Championship offers the dream of
playing against the best
and hey have we mentioned there's also a
million dollars at stake the total pot
is a million dollars know that it's not
a typo the prizes are unbelievably
generous we began with thousands of
players now only dozens remain
there it is oh my God Eric Hanson this
is
Eric Hansen moves on to the round of 32
in Armageddon fashion The cgc Knockout
phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and summer here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real okay one second
boom Oh my God
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends it's the cgc round of 64. who
will take the next step to Toronto
is the talk of the Chess World he's won
the candidates twice in a row Dania I
mean he is just a superstar
he is a superstar indeed and he has been
for many many years but ever since he
started playing in the candidates
tournament he has been John upanishi on
steroids he has been at Force Major in
tournament after tournament and just
when you think that his form is finally
going to be broken
he outdoes even himself he's up 2-0 on
muradli he's spending an average of
three minutes out of his 15 and he is a
nightmare pairing for one and all
yeah he is looking determined he won the
rapid Chess Championship Finals uh he
looks Stellar in the process he didn't
lose a single match there and he won the
candidates he didn't there's a single
game there so there's a certain theme
here that he's difficult to beat
and did you lose a single game in the
singfield car
he did he lost two magnets before Magnus
of the Drew
oh in round one
yeah oh what a scrub
yeah that's it I don't think he's got
any chances in the world championship
match
no none at all no but he beat otherwise
in that tournament and maybe Levon Ronan
so let's go let's go to the game between
yawn the Palm machine and Muhammad Ali
and okay King's Indian you should be
okay
and muradli has a dilemma now because
nepo could take on E5 if he wanted to
like if you really want to make a draw
you can play The Exchange but you know
that's what I like about Yan he he needs
to draw to win the match but he's not
going to
you know he's not going to change his
lines he's going to play this for a win
he's going to try to finish this match
in style bayonet because sometimes when
you play for a draw you just get in the
positions that you're not that familiar
with or comfortable with and Jan is
saying I know the king's Indian is
better for white objectively according
to the evaluation it's very tricky but
done as you know from experience there
are plenty of lines where white can just
like bail out and like just say I'm
gonna Force some trades and not take the
riskier approach
yeah
um but these top guys are so confident
in their preparation
that
you know they're not even thinking about
you know should I play a drawish line
should I try to you know play something
that's that's going to give me more of a
probability making a draw to Beyond this
is just another day in the office he has
absolutely no doubts that he's going to
win this match
but from Muhammad Ali
I think uh you know the best possible
choice that he could be making because
you know for a fact that you're going to
get an unbalanced position with the
mainline King's Indian
that's right and A4 just played by Jan
his Bishop can follow the pawn with
Bishop A3 try to play for C5 all that
good stuff but morale is doing what he
must he is playing the black side of a
king's Indian he has put his Pawn on F5
uh Dania how should white meet this push
because you definitely don't want to
take that's clearly out of the question
uh but how nervous should I be about a
potential capture on e4 what's kind of
the vibe yeah so you rarely so generally
when black plays F5 the Knight already
isn't on F3 so that you can push the
pawn to F3 that's sort of the classic
King's Indian situation now if you've
left upon an F3 you can jump to G5 which
I think is exactly what Yan has done
here and of course the point of this
move is to jump into E6 and Force black
to give away one of his main attacking
pieces of the light Square Bishop once
the pawn repositions onto E6 Robert you
get a very complicated type of situation
where
the pawn on E6 is both a weakness and a
strength black needs to try to surround
that pawn but in doing so there are tons
of tactical Tactical
traps and tricks that can allow white to
keep that pawn alive
traps that can allow you to give that
pawn alive for example the one you're
showing Knight D5 here exactly although
is defended so you got that going for
you but normally Knight D5 is what you
immediately do and after Queen takes E6
here uh I think there are many options
for white to continue here you could
probably even just take it by Queen D5
check off the B7 Pawn but white is much
better at this point even though black
stole the E6 Pawn
yeah without the light squared Bishop
Black's attacking chances on The Kinks
that are exactly nil
and Jan has already managed to open up
the queen side sufficiently
C5
but
yeah I don't know what to think about
that move
I have
a desire to take and place C5 same
exactly what I was about to say
but yam plays the very calm Rook to B1
which now make 96 even more of a
powerful threat because the bishop will
no longer be defending B7 dude this
isn't even close yeah it's just blowing
morale out of the water of this game in
this match
really just an uphill battle for morally
you know just to qualify for this that
was a big accomplishment and that's not
to uh say that you know we're surprised
that he's here but considering the
amount of Grandmasters who didn't make
it like Gregory o'parin who's 26 85 feet
a right all these strong Grandmasters
couldn't make their way through the
field so for Morality to be here in the
first place is a great accomplishment
but now he is looking like he's about to
be bounced quite quickly and
um oh gosh I'm looking at this I think
96. 96 subscribe but I was looking at
the Spindler shirov game if we can hop
over there because let's do it good good
luck trying to beat Peter Fiddler with
the black pieces when he plays like this
oh look at this so shirov plays a very
enterprising style he wants to take this
Pawn but he can't do that because of the
check that's available in the elephant
Sicilian as well so castles and just
Queen C2 so spiddler is playing the
driest game possible so Sheriff will
have no attacking chances yeah this is
kind of a Toria attack structure
um and after DC White's going to
position the dark scored Bishop my guess
would be on G5 and he's gonna play
Knight bd2 and like you're saying
White's position would survive in
Apocalypse I mean there are not only are
there no targets but white controls the
key entry and exit points the D4 square
and B4 Square which would immobilize a
potential Knight on C6
yeah I mean this is a such an astute
opening Choice uh by Peter Fiddler
I feel like Fiddler's the last person
I'd want to have to win again so if you
give me yeah even opponent who's higher
rated than he is but someone like Mama
Jara for example I feel like Mama jarov
even though he has been the number two
player in the world well over 2 800.
sometimes the guy just likes to play
chess he doesn't want to make a quick
draw he's not trying to shut it down but
swither on the other hand is like well
this is the result that gets me to move
on you are never going to beat me
no no this is this is way way way too
solid of course Alexi is going to try
and if there is someone
who is equipped to unbalance the
position then it is Alexi shurov but
I am very very pessimistic
yeah so slight Advantage for Spiller to
start this game we'll see how it
continues uh let's check in in mamajarov
versus kovalev because
needs to win that game and All Things
Considered Dania I like codeless
position the best out of the three
people down to nothing
out of the people who need to win with
black no doubt that I think kovalev has
managed to unbalance things
and he has done so while preserving an
objectively decent position unlike
Muhammad muradli
on the other hand Robert after the queen
moves White's gonna go E3 and sorry to
cut you off there but
I think White's still very very solid I
agree but I also like kovalev's clock
management I feel like that gives him
some chances in addition to the position
E3 is going to be annoying I acknowledge
that but with so many pieces remaining
it feels like that optimizes the winning
chances
yeah I mean he's managed to keep all but
one of the minor pieces still on the
board the bishop on B7 concerns me a
little bit it is currently biting on
granite there's two ways to try to solve
that problem you can play Bishop C8
which uh was sort of my intuitive Choice
as you're indicating dropping it on G4
or maybe on F5 or you could try to
engineer the B5 Pawn push uh and and
blast your way through White's Pawn
chain both options I think should be
seriously considered
for sure although E3 as you're
mentioning will be White's next move it
would appear but that doesn't tell the
full story the game doesn't end just
because white plays E3 for instance just
to put these few moves here this is just
a position black will try to play H5 H4
things of that nature and it looks like
the really just a situation where the
players have to figure it out by
themselves
yeah but hard agree that or as Danny's
population of greytown
a great town population too that a lot
of stuff kovaleo has has by far the best
chances here in the early going of game
three and we see him dropping the bishop
back to C8
good stuff by by Cavalia gets exactly
the kind of position you want to get in
a must-win situation
yes and sure of
speaking of players trying to mix up the
waters here mud of the waters he just
played with F5s going over to shirov's
game because he just decided to strike
with the move F5 and move ten Donya we
see the evaluation bar Sky High and
White's favor likely Bishop C4 check
connected G5
but at some point you have to do
something if you need to win the game
and this is essentially the only Pawn
lever that black has what else are you
going to do to contest White Center at
least this poses several decisions to
White the first is how are you going to
resolve the tension between the enf puns
there's E5 you can leave the pawn on e4
and the second major dilemma Robert is
where White's going to Castle because I
would be seriously considering Queen
side Castle here but that wouldn't be
very consistent with Peter Fiddler's
strategy this game nonetheless I think
in order to punish the flimsiness of
Black's approach you might have to give
yourself the ability to attack
on the king side without having to worry
about exposing your king
I understand why Bishop C4 check was a
mistake so I'm just going to take us a
step back here so it says plus two and
change e takes F5 first there's no
Bishop takes F5 it comes with Tempo but
you have Queen B3 check and then G4
winning a piece so that's why Bishop C4
check is technically inaccurate because
in the event of King h8 you can't take
here and you want to force black attack
with the pawn on F5 to open up the king
but here the bishop could in fact take
on F5 because the king is out the way
but either
uh either way this was played castles in
F4 and now I'm starting to appreciate
Shiro's Edition a bit more even if I
think white is better
yeah because the king side has somewhat
dried up of course if white goes G4 then
black buys himself a bunch more time by
taking on passant
and you might ask well what is black
buying himself time to do well obviously
black is trying to attack on the queen
side we might see a quick B5 by Alexi as
you're saying Rook B8 B5 maybe Queen A5
B5 maybe even B5 sacrificing the B Pawn
is not totally out of the question to
open up the B file for The Rook either
way that you could not
ask for a better type of position Knight
G5 by Peter good move just going after
the weak in light Square so you know
while we're saying that black has
chances to play for win we're not black
is better right black is worse black is
still worse no for sure and ig5 was an
excellent move by the way
covering those key Center squares
okay just keeping an eye out on all the
games here I think we can go back to the
Yana pomsha game it's been a a little
bit of time since we've been there and
oh my goodness
how did this happen where did it it
almost seems like black is made
five or six Moves In White or like seven
or eight moves and white is made two or
three make White's position hasn't
changed and black now has a knight on D4
and the biggest tell is Jan's clock he's
ahead on time but normally he's ahead by
four minutes let's go back so what
happened over here so C5 Rook D1 Rook
takes A5 and then Queen B3 so apparently
that was the first inaccuracy I'm
wondering if it's just 96 it was yeah it
suggests 93 very strange move I mean
isn't that why you put the Rook on B1 to
play 96
and then 96 was stopped by Black's
pieces
but now you have to play it anyway
because you're in too deep
yeah but now the Knight is in too deep
in White's position
yeah Queen B3 was a very very strange
move by Yan
black is obviously much much better
Queen B3 what that does 96
yeah 1960 Knight D5 is coming
exactly what he was setting up
from the perspective of having to not
lose this one's basically over I mean
White's not losing this game
that's nearly plus three so a very
strange decision by you on the palm tree
and if he survives this game it's not
going to be easy look at Black's attack
building up over here
so I guess Bishop C1
is essentially for us because to me
taking on D4 oh no is virtually out of
the question allowing a recapture with
Tempo it's just
just visually looks terrible and this
fishery is in the mix the bishop becomes
better all of a sudden if you take it
with the e-pawn so yeah and you free up
the E5 square that looks bad
and Jan is trying to figure out what to
do he must be disappointed with himself
I like that he's still yeah I mean the
last thing you want is
a situation where you lose with white
and then you have to and he does take on
D4 but I guess he just didn't see he
thinks that's the Lesser evil but the
last thing you want is the situation or
suddenly you have to hold with black and
your opponent is full of confidence
because once you break that initial hump
once you win a game with black you know
then you're incredibly hopeful and
hope does a dangerous man make
especially someone like muradli that's
true trying to like quote
you know remember a quote that isn't
actually a quote I liked it anyway and
this Pawn A4 is loose Black's not even
down material for all the positional
advantages he has
no he's not but now black has to decide
exactly how to proceed because D3 is a
major candidate move you run the risk of
losing that deep on robber but in return
you give yourself a lot more real estate
in the center for your minor pieces
maybe bishop d495 and if you want to
check my whites King that might be a
worthy investment to make
it's a great example of a clearance it's
not a tactic but a clearance idea where
D3 so you can use the D4 Square for
either your knight or your Bishop you
sacrifice a pawn to help your minor
pieces but F3 G3 we'd love to go in here
for a Checkmate the bishop is going to
stay on F1 uh
made for the rest of the game
yeah so it's it's not totally over I
mean black will have to massage this
position for quite a while before he can
get
White's defenses to collapse I still
really like the prospect of D3 Bishop D4
but when murali starts smelling blood he
also might get nervous because he might
start
smelling some hope he had a the real
forehead cam going on he was pretty much
head on the table but he's looking at
this position trying to come up with in
a plan that leads to a check many attack
he goes Knight to E5 maybe D3 is in the
near future Queen D5 quickly played by
John the palmishi get these Queens off
the board I do not want to face an
attack this queen Donna might go to H5
with Knight G4 to follow but I still am
not seeing The Knockout there
yeah you'll have to I mean that's
already three moves and even after
Knight G4 white can play H3 so the
bishop on F1 is an amazingly resilient
defensive piece
it's fantastic A4 at some point can be
captured that doesn't look so impressive
profession on the clock I think that's
part of his defensive plan exactly what
I was going to say he's already sensing
it because six and a half minutes he
knows that if he can erase another
another two or three minutes off Black's
clock that's going to start to become
a major concern I still think that Jan's
probability of drawing this game
or even winning this game Robert exceeds
the probability of him losing
yeah I'm with you just because there's
no clear path forward and opposite
colored Bishops have Josh Tendencies but
let's go to the game between kovalev and
mamajaro because we were praising the
way that vladislav was dealing with the
opening stage and in a must-win game
Dania he might win with black
amazing I mean and he's gotten the best
of all worlds he's got an A6 B5 and as
we had indicated earlier he has pressure
on Mama Dr of C4 Pawn and he's got a
major advantage in the end game I mean
he's got Mama jar of really on his heels
so like passive passive Rooks The Rook
on e4 is perfectly placed
and if there's somebody who does not
like passive positions it's Shakira
mamaturove the guy has been a tactical
Beast ever since his you know Junior
years when he won the world junior
Championship I think twice if I'm not
mistaken yeah so
yeah he's passed 20 hundred the guy has
been around for a long time and still
one of the best this game has so this is
just miserable because white would like
to Target something in Black's position
he can't do that he would love to put a
rook on that four trade pieces no luck
for you so when there's one kind of open
file and your opponent controls it
completely and is pressuring your pawns
this just feels like you're gonna suffer
yeah you you are and kovalia with a very
patient move taking F7 realizing that
white has no way to improve the status
quo I mean shocker are is basically just
gonna have to shuffle his Rook back and
forth Rook E2 Rook D2 and
you know black can improve his position
in a million different ways you can
bring your king up you can push some of
her King side pawns up you can play G7
G5 maybe you don't want to overdo it
though right you want to hit the sweet
spot where everything is optimized
and then at some point you're actually
going to have to try to win the game
but for now chakra is suffering big time
and at any moment code can take on C4
and open the B file so maybe you start
with Rook B8 just to make Mom jar think
is BC coming but uh whether it's B takes
D4 as you're mentioning Palm pushes on
the king side King even going to E5 this
Rook can figure out does it want to go
to B8 E8 do you want to go to h8 so that
when you play G5 H5 H4 your Rook is
going to be an open file so many options
for black and white as you were
mentioning is forced to shuffle it and
one other thing is I wouldn't play B4
like I know it looks great if you get
your Pawn A4 as well but as soon as you
play B4 white might play A3 and Rook A1
nope there's a one and Ctrl d a file
and that's the absolute last thing you
want in fact that results in an
immediate draw the moment you let one of
the white sharks get active
and get around the pond cover upon shell
and into black side of the territory
into Black's territory then
Black's Advantage evaporates almost
immediately you're absolutely right you
want to keep White's Rooks at Bay and on
his territory at all costs and that move
apparently has left Black's Advantage
grow Rook C1 just to reinforce this Pawn
on C4 I think it's time that black just
starts pushing the pawns I don't know if
rookie first or the reason I'm thinking
of rookie is just to force white to
defend this Pawn but G5 King G6
H5 you have so many moves to play here
Dania and one idea that I'm just
thinking about is if this king is on G6
maybe even play F4 of course The Rook
needs to be on E8 let's just bring up an
analysis Port here so we can show this
um how this might go is that you have to
protect your Pawn so how are you going
to do that Rook
Rook City Rook C3 and I'll play G5
what's Rook C2 or something some random
move Rook C1 I'm just not seeing moves
and I could consider playing F4 just
because when all is said and done the
square my king gets active and you see
that if exactly this position were to
happen black is crushing
yeah I mean at this point you're just
tearing white apart Rucka for the other
Rook infiltrates to E2 and you end up
just taking all of White's Pawns
so
yeah the narrowest of of threads now
separates White from
this reality of chakra tries to keep his
Pawn cover intact
but it's six minutes on the clock
a lot of sloth still has quite a bit of
work left to be done
and I think the evaluation bar isn't
very helpful right now because black can
more or less Shuffle it's not about what
the bar says is that does white have an
option at some point to make a move like
B4 and start trading pawns even if it
costs you a pawn heading into the end
game or like a one Rook end game you
might still have chances but for now Mom
Jarvis is going to sit passively and
Shuffle and we'll see if he's able to
make this work but let's uh check in on
our other games here because we haven't
looked at Spindler and shirov in a row
yeah let's look at Fiddler's game
because it continues to heat up but not
necessarily in a good way for Alexi oh
my gosh
seems like Peter's having all the fun
here look at his position
I don't even know what movie suggests
it's like Knight H4 going for some kind
of sacrifices
ah the point of 97 by the way I think is
to prepare H6 which does to be fair trap
the night on G5 but there are so many
ways to deal with that like they D4
Knight H4 yeah
oh Knight D4 looks great attacking E6
speaking of attacks
what if Knight F5 just take it
ah okay let's take it and control the D
file and these pieces are having a
really good time over here
I think it's over
this has been
a ridiculously one-sided match
and you know we were talking about this
Fiddler is the last person I'd want to
face when you give me these three
options Jana pomshi number three in the
world by rating Mama jarov higher
riddance Fiddler winning the champion
Showdown that's Phil is also playing in
St Louis the chess 960 event but
Spindler is just the guy who's not going
to give you opportunity and if you look
at this position it looks like Spindler
is just dominated the entire board
yeah it looks like he's made
you know five or six extra moves like
you said Alexi's entire Queen side is
still lying dormant
and Knight F5 is on the board but Peter
he's gonna take it like you said and
Alexis days are numbered here
you know this game oh goodness
that's so sad that also gives the Knight
and Escape Route on F7 with the movie
six oh my gosh keep pushing the pawn
hi he's 61's Queen E7 actually
okay and the queen moves like E6 the
queen goes up and the queen just slides
to D2
okay then I resign
then then I resign I'm gonna make you
find the difficult Queen D2
Queen if you follow my Rook D7
easy peasy lemon squeezy
I can't really yeah maybe maybe Sheriff
will like resign in a couple turns uh so
from that vantage point it might be
worth saying oh mama jar if we gotta go
back there because just just what I want
to see just what I was asking about has
happened so we'll switch games we'll
keep you updated on the cheer of result
but look at this B4 was in fact the
choice by Mama jar of here giving up one
Pawn to open up this was who he found's
mistake is she kept material but then
got a passive position mama jarv had a
passive position he gives up material so
that he has some activity and we see the
evaluation still in Black's favor but
Dania I think you'd agree with me that
this feels like white has far more
chances oh a hundred percent and just
like a fish is always going to find
water the fact that shock has managed to
get active in this position Robert is
nothing short of a miracle and
psychologically dealing with this change
of circumstances in time pressure is
incredibly difficult because put
yourself in Cavalli of shoes he's got
carte blanche he can improve his
position whichever way he wants all of a
sudden he's got to deal with this
upstart peace activity all sorts of
threats against his own King and he's
got to do it within two minutes I think
you can tell by his body language that
he's getting nervous
this is
a tremendous decision by Shakira and I
think it might allow him to save the
game
and for a couple of it's so frustrating
to go from a position where your
opponent can barely find a move
definitely not finding any ideas to now
it's like black trying to figure out are
these Rooks about to barrel down and you
see ooh that move the evaluation down to
0.6 from 2.5 to about 0.5
so the point of rookie five is after C
takes D6 Rook takes D5
Cavalia wants to surround the pawn on D6
and also the pawn helps him out because
Rook C6 is no longer a check
but the problem is that Rook C6 attacks
the a pawn Robert and if you play A5
here I actually think you lose
or no I guess you don't lose
but because after D7 King E7 Rook C8 you
have Rook B7
and I forgot that the Rook on D5 is
stopping promotion yeah that's an
important fact
this is happening beyond the problem she
oh excuse me sorry I look at the wrong
game there Peter swidler has won the
game so he wins three to nothing and we
still have this game going but maybe
it's possible that Mama jar missed the
same thing
yes there's no D.A wow
can you just go for this Pawn
I think you have to
but then
yeah exactly
hmm all right Rook G8 Rook takes D7
Brooke takes you seven King F6 forces
The Rook trade
oh but this is now all of a sudden what
was the move here if not for Rook G8
um Rook A8
and then A4
and what's the follow Rook B1 Maybe
oh I'm so focused you know when you have
this Pawn on D7 you're always looking at
what to do with it but is it that simple
it is you're correct Rook bead won
winning this Pawn because that these
pawns are more dangerous the queen Side
Pawn so that's actually a nice variation
what's happening in the game with Rook
G8 a very I understand that move it's
what I suggested it's what I would play
uh given the time situation but now
after Rook takes G7 the king moves out
the way and you have three on
can you fix a mistake somehow
wow is it because after Rook G8 there's
an additional check on C6 that could
potentially be nasty
God it's so hard to navigate your way in
such end games because there's always
like two or three candidate moves and
they all look the same right but sure
every hour is just
he's making mistakes but I was watching
your commentary yesterday with uh David
Navarro against Michael Adams that night
in game where you see the evaluation bar
going up and down but to actually find
the correct path was immensely difficult
in every single turn as it is here I
think he wants to take on H7 and go Rook
B7
but no Black's gonna get connected
connected passers
and nine times out of ten when they're
this far Advanced it's really only a
matter of time
that's right even if material is even
it's not about the quantities or the
quality of blacks pawns are too fast
hey this is not a great end game by
shock he got himself a lot of chances
and maybe he rushed it just a little bit
he still has an eternity left on his
clock
okay well let's look at the other game
while this end game looks great for
kovalev uh we're not going to
necessarily trust him the result is in
the books but yonda palmistry's game
against morale morale is checkmating
this is Maiden 14 off the side here
so you need to find a way to get that
Rook onto H7 he's got 24 seconds
and he's looking intently trying to
figure out the mate
is King G6 the move followed by Rook H7
it's a player but he's probably the
nerves
[Music]
he goes Knight E7 which still keeps him
with a huge advantage that's an
excellent move eliminating White's
strongest piece
and then you put G4 yeah how can white
possibly get out of this it feels
prominent
it feels permanent and there's no
counter play against black scene that's
the main thing
White's Queen is totally out of
commission
considering is foreign
[Laughter]
I'm getting hungry thank you Alexa for
reminding me of my Hunger oh oh
seven why is that he didn't want to get
checked that's the thing when you have
no time you get nervous about little
things like this
John has to find a way to get his Queen
active but that's the wrong movement G4
Queen A4 Queen A4 oh gosh
Jan's not losing this game it's minus
Queen G4 no but now we named four Bishop
G3 Queen E8
oh my goodness this queen
is venturing over here
whoa whoa yeah oh
[Music]
he might win this game even oh he
totally might win this game he's better
oh my God
how did he pull
up Pawn is gone it's like his King was
never in danger to begin with
wow Bishop G2 is such a sick move
that's it he's out of the woods
he's could trade Queens but I think that
could be a difficult oh is this a forced
thing
well now Bishop H5 I think he's just
winning
or queen A4 doesn't look so bad your
move from earlier
he just wants to repeat moves I'll go
Queen F3 now
King g798
Bishop B6 goodbye 98
how'd the advantage go away
yeah now all of a sudden now it's equal
oh Queen H1 Queen E4 repetition
that is beautiful he sees it oh
he just sniffed that repetition out
immediately
and that is all she wrote Yana promise
she holds the fort and he shakes his
head he's like I had to go through a lot
to hold that position
but all's well that ends well for Yan he
moves on but it wasn't without some
serious problems great game by Morelli
and right here Dania look at this after
Queen D1 Bishop takes G3 was the winning
move Bishop G2 was the one that held for
white oh Bishop G3 would have won for
black because the queen of D1 was loose
oh morale is going to be kicking himself
for that one but he had five seconds
left
how are you supposed to see that on
demand
you can see on his face he's very upset
by the way a lot of stuff kovalev did
win it means we have more action here on
day three of the global Championship but
more oddly oh gosh you see it look at
that that's heartbreak he's like he's
just so upset that he couldn't put that
away and it was in this moment he's
devastated
it said Mateen 14 or something like that
around here and he went uh Knight to E7
which honestly looked like a good move
because it was scary but I guess those
Bishop takes G3 here as well
I mean it's oh Bishop takes you three
and probably the idea here is somewhat
different from
its idea on the preview yeah Rook A2
just with overwhelming threats but
that's so difficult to find when you
have no time you're so worried about
your king and all sorts of checks and
things like that so I think 97 from a
practical point of view made sense but
missing it the second time that's where
brutal Bishop takes G3 yeah this is the
one but I didn't that did not occur to
me at all
and just leave it to yawn Leave It To
The Top GMS to never die regardless of
the position it's like
to bring them down you just need
you know to beat them over and over and
over again
an amazing everybody on that's what I
say blood of soft cobal has to do he
needs to beat mamajarov over and over
again because one time is in the books
he needs a second in a row and well Mama
Gerald might be a little shaken after
losing game three to nalid but Donnie
and I will take a short when we return
it is game four for Mama jar of Roscoe
live here at chess.com
foreign
[Music]
we are back here at the 2022 chess.com
Global championship four matches of
today's round of 64 action in the books
one match remains Dania Shakura
mamajarov and a two-nil lead is now two
to one but one side of the bracket has
already filled out for the round of 32
we saw the top four players
seated in group E win their matches
yeah no upsets as of now I mean talk
about players on a total Rampage Arjun
aragai see yet another confident win the
guy is over 27 30 feet a and I think
he's got a great chance of making it
into the final eight and of course we
just saw Jana palmistry and Peter
svidler in incredibly convincing fashion
making it through to the next round
where they'll be facing each other
another match that I'm very much looking
forward to
yes Fiddler while he is the lower seed
in this field against Nepal machine he
looked very impressive today and our
generic I see he's a fan favorite but
team over job of it was a shaky first
two games against uh how you find well
not shaky but just very solid draws and
then game three was topsy-turvy but he
ultimately made it through and in group
b where Shakira mamajarov and vladislav
kovalev reside they will have a tough
group ahead no matter who makes it
through because John Duda sits atop that
one
yeah and he is
a king of rapid
he is incredibly consistent but he's has
a pretty tough first round matchup is a
great online Blitz player he's a solid
experience GM and we have already seen
that there is no such thing as an easy
cgc match
no there is not in my favorite first
round matchup that I mentioned before
this got underway is vidit Gujarati
against Alexis Serrano because they're
playing all the time online they're both
super strong but both of these players
could also make the top eight now I'm
not just saying that to you know say
everyone can make it no Alexis Arana is
a sick seed so dangerous
no I mean he's proven himself again and
again in the RCC
he has proven his ability to compete
with the very top players in the world
including Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so
and uh he's just one of those guys that
nobody wants to face and another guy
that nobody wants to face right now is
vladislav kolio because he won the
previous game on demand of the black
pieces what do you think's going through
his mind how hopeful is he that he can
pull off the miracle comeback after
which by the way he still has to win the
Armageddon
he will have to if he wins this game and
by the way we had Peter fridler in the
chat apparently saying what do you mean
no upsets Alexi's higher rated than I am
oh come on that's a four or five matchup
there's no such thing as nothing yeah
also you were the fourth seed in your
feet a rapid rating is very high yeah
Peter Spiller won a match what a
surprise yeah get out of here people
would have thought no we love Peter
we're so glad to have him in this event
while he's you know multitasking in St
Louis so congrats Peter really really
excellent display of chess
now I'm obviously a big fan of his
commentary and his chess
and his grunfels course Anna's class
Peter's awesome so thanks for popping
into the chat
and the night popped into F6 before
dropping back to G at a developing was
fun but I think I've had enough of that
I think in reality it's rerouting
through E7 uh the two fives to put
pressure on the D4 Pawn what a decision
here because you you always see this
Knight go to E4 but Mama jarov goes back
to G8 so okay do you think he's avoiding
kind of Mainline preparation from
Cavalia of what's the idea Dania yeah
and my Blitz game is against shock I
think in the rapid and Blitz time
control he likes to play E4 E5 and then
to play offbeat variations against most
mainstream openings now one other thing
I'll point out Robert is that Bishop E2
the retreating move Bishop B2 is to my
knowledge a lot more Uncommon than the
main line Bishop B5 so maybe Knight G8
is more normal against Bishop in fact
I've never seen Bishop E2 so I can't
really speak for
you know what's the theory here
I'm already forgetting which was it
pancratov against Vichy I think that was
the game where Bishop E2 was played if I
am remembering my games correctly but
either way it's cavolio of here who is
deep in the think tank first well not so
deep but uh maybe he's trying to figure
out the ins and outs of this position 97
made perfect sense and well for a lot of
slow can you just Castle
yeah I think he has to develop maybe
he's thinking about Bishop G5 too
make it difficult for black to put the
Knight on F5 but I don't really like
that move after H6 Bishop H4 black of
course has the prospect of going G5 and
that may make matters even worse for
white on the king side
and this D4 upon
D4 is being hunted so quickly here so
yeah I'm with you that allowing HSN G5
expansion seems to be a mistake and but
I think I already I know I'm jumping the
gun here already but I already think
that the opening has been a success for
chakra because he has exactly the kind
of position you want very solid clear
plan of attacking the D4 Pawn
and I just don't feel like Gladys love
likes you know these kinds of slow
dry maneuvering positions
and H3 speaking of slow dry types of
moves taking away the G4 Square so a
great decision by vladislav what he
doesn't want to have happened and now it
can't is all these pieces going after D4
but if Knight F5 he might just play
Bishop to E3 and even though that looks
wrong to play maybe your Bishop G5 move
now comes first because you don't want
to play Queen D7 but I was going to say
that in a position like this where you
take on E3 this looks like a problem
with double pawns but what you've gained
is an open file and you can just Castle
Queen side and go after the black king
which is going to G8
yeah this particular structure I think
is very unpleasant for black you're
absolutely right because the problem
with the D4 Pawn will have been
permanently solved
so now it's shock's turn to take
a little while and think about how he
wants to arrange the rest of his minor
pieces when he wants to play Knight F5
or whether he wants to play it at all
and he doesn't he puts his Bishop on F5
interesting
maybe bishop E4 is a viable option with
Knight F5 to follow just try to get rid
of the Defenders the D4 Pawn
so he is just fully invested in putting
pressure on that pawn that is his
singular goal in life right now
although white can play Knight A4 at
some moment probably after castling
first but can go uh to remove the
attacker of the pawn and black will then
play castle on F6 which is a thematic
Pawn break here
yeah instead of a lot of Slough castles
and there's that Bishop B4 moved by
shock
yeah how are you going to defend D4 apps
or Bishop b395 you might end up having
to make that Knight A4 move but it might
already be too late you know Mom and
Jarvis like his body language tells me
he's like yeah I've already equalized he
looks so at home okay oh yeah totally
he's comfortable
yeah he didn't look that way in the last
game no he did not and he's not at home
because he's in St Louis so he's at the
hotel there but he's looking like he's
looking ready for what's about to happen
because Knight F5 is his plan and D4 is
loose and like what are you gonna do to
stop Bishop takes F3 at the end of that
yeah Bishop B3 staves It Off But Here
Comes Knight F5 and I'm quite surprised
that the eval bar is actually not giving
a slight Edge for black what is the move
here is it Bishop B5
do you have to play G4
[Music]
you know
also G4 Bishop takes F3 file by Knight
takes D4 doesn't look so bad no but G4
Bishop F3 I thought maybe GF
ah you're getting spicy
I am getting spicy I think Cavalia might
be getting spicy as well because I don't
see any other choice
well G4 is such a risky move to play but
when a draw is equivalent to a loss you
have to take risks to win the game so G4
does make sense to me your other move
was Bishop B5 if I'm not mistaken
but there might be some kind of Bishop
takes F3 in those positions
yeah Knight takes D4 and of course the
fact that
it's interesting the fact that black
only needs a draw really does change the
actual way that the game is played it
basically changes the rules of the game
because certain options that otherwise
you would seriously consider are totally
out of the question
Mama charm he's just relaxing over here
um he's got so much chess to play today
so he's been in this match for a few
hours now and then he's going to play
three games of 960 in a rapid show
against you know just
kind of random players yeah amateur Asia
and Nakamura and carwana Kasparov all
those types and no nobody pretty strong
yeah so it just sounds like a pretty uh
pretty non-rigorous chess schedule today
for chakra are pretty relaxed
okay Bishop B5 but now I think after
black simply castles yeah you can
eliminate the Knight on C6 but that
actually creates this typical Pawn
structure on the queen side
which could enable black to push c65
later on in the game and the pressure on
the D4 Pawn remains
tremendously punishing
can never take on e4 because then the
queen joins the fun against the D4 Pawn
yeah I don't envy kolio's task before
the game but I certainly don't envy it
now
yeah I think if Checker our Castle's
here and
I don't see why he would do anything
else I think the only other thing to
consider Robert is the immediate Bishop
takes F3 Queen takes F3 Knight f64 but
getting into those tactics and allowing
Knight takes D5 in my opinion is
completely unnecessary would be
a shocking no pun intended
decision of mom and daughter goes for it
yeah this looks pretty tragic
uh foreign
I
liked it so this was more of me just
like all right it's in the Rhythm it
didn't feel like when you make it wasn't
hard it was a four so when you make good
puns now I don't always have to react
because I can appreciate them as like a
a common occurrence rather than
something special okay touche
I just really just came up with that out
of my tush like I just really just tried
it
no your explanation was like worthy of a
dissertation
uh so can I have my PhD now in BS thank
you very much
yeah I've already earned one there's a
limited amount yes well you know I just
want to join your Club
so he does take on sisu sorry take on C6
Pawn goes there F6 still a possible move
for Mama jar of next what does white
play here D4 is defended enough times
but Bishop takes F3 is a pretty big it's
a huge threat it's a huge threat because
Bishop F3 GF is totally out of the
question a tradition by 3gf Queen H4 you
can basically resign
and after Bishop F3 Queen F3 Knight
takes before you can wave goodbye to any
winning chances
so how exactly does white even prevent
that threat like is there a move here
Knight G5 doesn't work because of Knight
takes E3 cutting off the defender so
Knight D2 so I just took your idea
uh then maybe rookie won
and maybe then you basically claim that
you cannot take the pawn on D4 because
the minor pieces get in trouble
is that true although I'm not convinced
of that
this is even
or Bishop wait a second though if you
get this position though I could see
white being better here because this
Knight goes to C5 the queen goes to D4
and even though blacks up a pawn it's
dark Square domination and blockaded
uh double Pawns
wow
that's actually a pretty odd line it
looks like black is dominating
dominating that all of a sudden When the
Smoke Clears White's the one you know
Black's Thorn was getting the shorter
end of the stick here
yes and we see some of these featured
chats with people talking about their
brackets someone's lucky enough to
predict a handsome win is that lucky or
is that skilled
hmm
85 of people Dania picked mamajarov to
beat vladislavier
well right now their predictions are
looking pretty good this has been a
perfectly played opening by shock and
now he's developing a huge time
advantage to boot
I mean you need you need a crazy
turnaround for this game to not go and
shuffle your favor
Nike one C5 immediately because you can
take on E3 after DC and the bishop
is alive what about C5 Knight takes C4
C5 Knight can take on D4
then Bishop G5
oh I blundered nice find
but I think Knight takes E3 and D takes
E4 gives black
sufficient activity in the center
because Queen G5 here
aha yeah
lpdo
exactly
is that exactly and I think Chuck has
played C5 without it has played any
hesitation
and the point is that what dc5s if my
knight takes E3 and then the bishop gets
to recapture on C5 you've removed the
defender of that square so it's minus
about one in this position and just the
way Mama jar has been sitting and
playing he's been confident the whole
way through completely and this decision
to play Knight G8
that has worked to to say that has
worked to Perfection as an
understatement I mean it has given him
the ideal opening setup really just a
textbook
attack on the D4 Pawn exactly what
you're supposed to do in this opening
a lot of slav really never got off the
ground here
so I've mentioned this on Plenty of
previous broadcasts but Mom and jar of
series on a chess.com of his best games
I I watch it it's awesome the guy first
of all is super nice like you can just
tell but every interaction with him he's
very polite he's a kind of guy but like
he he is both making it seem like it's
nothing to beat vishyanin and carwana
and those guys in games but he also
explains his thoughts super well so big
fan of his Series yeah in general I
think the the greater access that we now
have to the best games collections of
top players in video form
is you know it's such a such a great
privilege to be able to
to be able to have courtside seats as
they explain
you know their greatest victories on
demand
sure and also what I really appreciate
in this series and then we could talk
about the game here is a lot of things
is he does what any good
um content creator does is he like
pauses and lets people try to figure out
what the tactic is so it's uh it's very
sweet
and it is that interactive component in
video series is is so important just to
keep to keep you engaged and to really
Hammer home the most instructive points
in the meantime vladislav has spent
an eon of time he takes on e4 oh 93
Queen G5 just ends it
this kind of thing mom and giraffe does
not miss you you can't really miss it
because you've given white these
beautiful Palms in the center and your
Pawn structure is horrible so yep what
else are you gonna do right and that's
the worst right when there's literally
nothing else to be found otherwise why
on Earth or do play C5
and we have a future chat here from none
other than Mr smidler
I pay in dog picks
it's irresistible
well
I guess can he get paid in dog picks
because he has at least ten thousand
dollars coming his way from this
tournament so I'm sure Danny if he were
on the call he would say all right Peter
that's how you pay that's gonna be
payback Danny would be more than
amenable with that arrangement
is this totally over
can you imagine any reality in which
water sloth pulls out a win here
this reality okay
alternate reality but that's all the
rage these days virtual art alternate
yeah exactly just put on your Oculus
headset and get that Knight to C4 so
what do you think the evaluation would
be with the United States plus three
if the Knight literally was would be
able to go for me one to C4 on this move
yeah plus
probably plus three yeah that's a good
call
and there's like Queen D2 rookie it's
just gross it's over I mean with that
Bishop on B6 yeah what Bishop yeah
exactly that was smooth
[Laughter]
but in the meantime you're dropping at
least one of your pawns
um Rook d8 comes after C6 Bishop C7 go
for checkmate
yeah I don't like this
I think it's over Red Rover and also
look at the clock situation eight
minutes down and Counting is vladislav
kovalev
it was a valiant effort I mean he won
with black but
never really gave himself much of a
chance in this game
up and down here what's Mama jar of
doing
he's drinking water
I think he's just he's so relaxed right
now he's just like waiting for the clock
to take down he knows how the game is
going to end
looking to the side he's bored
he's been pondering what he's gonna play
in his fish are random games today he's
like oh do I need to shave before then
you know just uh scratching the beard a
little bit but no Mama jarov He's obese
he actually has a very tough first round
opponent here so he's a two seed in hit
in duda's bracket and vladislav is the
seventh seed but vladislav played every
single rapid Chess Championship so he's
in form he's gotten all the practice in
and valessa was over 2700 a few years
back
yeah that's crazy to think about he's he
has drops a little bit but he's still
still a very dangerous player as he
proved in the RCC
and that alternate reality is going to
become
our reality the problem is that white is
going to have a
less pawns on the board just a few you
mean missing the E5 and D5 part of the
equation is going to be bad for what
yeah that's not that important I mean
you still have a knight on C4 that's the
important part this is a really bad
Bishop so I would play C6 foreign
you can play it whenever you want to
you have two pawns even if you lose upon
playing C6 you have another extra one so
that's the good thing about being up a
point in a match
you can give away two pawns and be equal
and then still move on yeah I mean and
you don't even have to play C6 you can
just play
HC you can do whatever you want here
Rook D3 I mean
the bishop on B6 is happy to chill for
the time being
because in order to keep it out of the
game white must keep the Knight on C4 at
all times
it's true
yeah Rook D3 looks great just quick
double
jar of small thing about it is we know
how good he is when tactical positions
but I think he's underestimated just
because like it's a comparison thing
right he is Elite of elite when it comes
to tactics and sometimes people think oh
he's not that good in positional games
and uh kind of winning without giving
his opponent chances now he's great at
that too
yeah a lot of people still don't I think
fully conceptualize the idea that to be
at the top
you know in 2022 you cannot have any
clear flaws in your game you you have to
be able to play literally in any style
does that mean that players don't have
preferences obviously they do that's I
think what we are talking about there's
areas of the game where players
basically play like engines
but everyone is well-rounded at the top
right now no such thing as a clearly
defined style in the sense that you try
to avoid certain types of positions
it's true and what Mama Joe needs to
avoid his A4 A5 trapping this bishop I'm
going to call it a bishop once again but
B3 is hanging in many of these positions
you can always play C6 to get your
Bishop out of there so I don't think he
needs to be overly concerned maybe now's
the time for C6 but he starts with queen
E7
the eval bar creeps up a little bit as a
result of that
but this Knight is so important because
if you ever take here you lose E3 at the
end yep
57.
stopping C6
yeah A4 is really White's only only idea
although now it can be met with A5
although The Bishop's hanging on B6 that
is true
a little bit pin over here
hmm
still needs an accurate move in this
position
I didn't say queen G5 is that the
blunder the E4 Pawn that would not be a
good start
oh six weight up weight up A4
A4 please and thank you
what is shock's response to that move
all right
if you loses this I will be
Beyond shocked
same
time I'm looking for his reaction
I thought maybe he wanted an A5 Knight
takes B6
Rook takes B3 but then there's Knight
the obvious Knight D5
I mean it was obvious the queen B7 is
setting up A4 and all of a sudden
Cavalli was the one drinking water yeah
he's realizing he has a chance and Mama
jarov he looks that is he's got that
unbelievably cute oh there it is there
it is I was waiting for that kind of
full reaction of what am I doing here
no this is this is unbelievable all of a
sudden shock actually might have to give
up his Bishop
for a bunch of Pawns that's the good
news is that he's still
very much okay even if he does that
maybe Rook takes B3 Robert allow A5 and
a b and just basically chill with your
four Pawns
but in that situation Anything is
Possible
it's easy to forget that in game one
Mama jarov took a Monumental risk to
play for a win and he plays Rook oh my
gosh it was A5 C6 because the Queen's
under attack his Bishop can so maybe ah
but if white goes Queen C6 that black
goes A5
and maybe that's why the position is
almost strong but that would be very bad
news for white
yeah if the oppong is pushed there for
sure uh what it's gonna say is that you
know Cavallo he was right there in game
one and he lost because he just was down
the clock so he has proven to be a very
worthy competitor for mamajara and
chakra has to find a way to deal with
Queen C6 A5 being the threat so after A5
for black here that looks like it solves
the issue right if you ever take it like
this sure you'll win all these pawns but
you can see the Evo bar blocks even
better here but I would say black will
never be worse
no there's no way black will ever lose
that so after A5 is there some sort of
move we're missing
a gives white
significant counter player do you have
to take on B6 is there like a rook F4
perhaps
at this point and black and AKO F5
because the G6 Pawn hangs with check
right this Pawn is needed where it is
covering G6 so Rook F4
will be an option after A5 mom and
Jeff's thinking so besides A5
what does he have here
what are the move candidates kind of
mine Queen G5
is there anything to be said about that
move oh my goodness
oh he wants to push C4 or at the end of
the line
ah
that's actually genius I wasn't even
thinking about the moon because I
thought you was giving up an exchange
yeah and after Knight D6 Rook D6 why
does it check on A8
but the Rook drops back to d8
essentially forcing repetition
Queen B7 there's C4
yeah you can also Play Just King G7
there's no more A5 threat the knight's
gone
wow a lot of love refrains from taking
it
this has been a very interesting battle
back to D7 so what else can he do
because 885 is met by C6 very
successfully the bishop gets back to C7
and then the white king is gonna be
mated
no this is the terrible thing about
having to win
the objectively best decision here the
only viable decision is to repeat moves
he's also down under a minute
so sadly despite his Valiant efforts I'm
afraid that
let us love time at the cgc might still
be coming to an end here
and you know while he'll be upset that
he didn't make it to the next round
he'll take five thousand dollars
home with him so a very good Payday for
the strong player from Belarus former
2700 and what now for white how can even
pretend to play for a win
you cannot I mean your your dark scores
around your king are also
and
and in disaster shape as you're
indicating Queen H4 Queen G3 just might
end it here and now
and there's nothing seconds that white
can do to stop that okay Queen F6 is
your best move just trade put this
bishop here and deliver a back ring
Checkmate but Bishop G3 y goes King F1
yeah but I trade Rooks to go Rook B1 I
mean this Pawn is
yeah yeah
again the important thing not to forget
is that shock is satisfied with the draw
here
so I wouldn't overthink it
and what else can be considered besides
this
I think he's not thinking about this
move he's considering his follow-up it
totally you want to put your opponent on
the clock
yeah and with this amount of time left
on the clock
you want to keep making moves that pose
decisions to your opponent
I mean you could play Queen E8 here it's
I would say that even after that move
black is in fantastic shape but when you
have the possibility of trading queens
and eliminating any risk
you know why not
and look at my major of
head
sinking a little bit in his hand over
here
trying to calculate
whoa what is the immediate Bishop G3
he didn't want to give his opponent any
counter play whatsoever no Rook on F6
for you no Rook trying to get over to
the queen side and with 17 seconds left
it's not looking good for a lot of love
no peace I think Mama darf is going to
get control of the default he can play
Rook D3 again if he wants but this
version is inferior I think after take
Stakes Rook D1 you have a bit of a
harder time defending the D3 Pawn
that's right but still
the way vladasov just he let out a Psy
he knows that he's in bad shape here
yeah I think we're gonna see
Rook e D7 takes takes King F1
Rook D3
and it's all over
going after this Pawn over here
goes for it F5 Rook C3 RX C2 also
possible I was gonna F5 G5 F4 just start
sending them
yeah
your face was like nope don't want to
look at this
yeah this is
it's kind of crazy this Knight on C4 was
amazing it has been amazing okay now it
has a score to go to but I was about to
say it can't go anywhere
yeah now A5 C6 last attempt by kavali
the the depressing thing is Knight A5 if
you want to be totally safe can be met
with Rook D6
I think you're about to show that as
well so Shakura can safely continue
pushing his Pawns
but I like what Mom year was doing not
just on the board but the way he's being
deliberate he's not just trying to flag
his opponent or assume that he's winning
he knows he's winning so he just wants
to play the best moves
yeah he's he's an artist he pursues the
truth in any position
you know and he wants to play as
accurately as possible it's just second
nature to these players they can't help
it you might say I just make a move it's
obvious you're not going to lose that's
not how they're thinking about it
for sure not and I saw the feature chats
people saying the clock is you know
another piece that is true and B4 played
trying desperately to get this Rook to
the B7 square and go after this Pawn on
A7 so Mama jar once again taking his
time he is not rushing his decisions
yeah however this game ends this has
been a valiant effort by Caballo even in
this game to create the chances that
he's that he has
uh after a very difficult open and look
at that move by Mama Dr of C takes B4
zero chances Rook takes before Rook
takes E3 get back to B1 and then the
Rook swings to A3
and the A6 Pawn is one as well
take everything and there's not even a
rook B8 check in any position because
the bishop covers the diagonal
yep Bishop C7 is possible
and Bishop B6 F4
choose your poison
if you're a Cavalia
I I just keep having to give Mom and Joe
credit he's not playing bullet here he's
four minutes on his clock he's
completely winning so he's just every
single turn trying to ensure that vlado
has no chance at a comeback
yeah he's taking 30 45 seconds a move
this is such a a good lesson especially
for younger players
who think that when they get a winning
position you know they can just Blitz
everything out I think Jana Palm Desi
would be playing very quickly here with
black there's different ways of
approaching this
but I I like the old school method don't
rush find the most precise of option
precise of precise option
and uh give your opponent exactly zero
chances
precise and decisive right precisive
it's something that yeah it's something
that's both precise and decisive at the
same time
I like it I'm here for it a shark
shouldn't drop to like below a minute
here
this could probably give us one second
also
now uh Bishop B6 anybody
Rook D3 and Bishop B6
okay resign exquisite
and even Bishop B6 which is incredibly
obvious he still spends a few seconds on
and there's the resignation Mama jar of
is through to the round of 32 and his
day is only just beginning you see St
Louis rapid and Bliss he has the St
Louis Champion Showdown up next later
today he's leading the field along with
alarisa faruga but congratulations are
in order to shock your mama jar of one
of the finest players on the planet
absolutely and that was such a
convincing final game
doesn't panic doesn't get frustrated
with himself he lost with white
so hats off to vladislav for giving him
a major run for his money you mentioned
in game one which I didn't have the
pleasure of covering but it was a close
game
two was close as well and it was only
decided on the strength of that blunder
work of olive trapped his own Knight so
it was a close match but in the Yen
chakra a mamadir's class his precision
and his tactical prowess carry him
forward to the round of 32. I'm bringing
up that first game just because I think
it's really important for people to
understand that uh where was it around
here mama jarov could have forced a draw
you look at the clock he had five
minutes and 48 seconds his point 25
seconds he could have forced the draw
immediately with Bishop E4 just a series
of simple trades The Rook takes on e4
Here pawn takes on F5 and then Rook D4
just sign sign the proverbial score
sheets is done but what he did in this
game was he traded Queens played King F1
you're about to see the evaluation go
down and so objectively this is what you
could consider bad chess right like he's
making bad moves but it's one of 24
seconds and he knew that he wanted to
continue this game and Cavallo has no
issues over the board his all of his
issues were on the clock mama jar was
able to win this game
what an incredibly risky gutsy decision
this end game looks terrible for white
but somehow Mahmoud yarov provoked
weaknesses in Black's position got his
Bishop to a better square and ultimately
got his King to the promised land
breaking through with B4 and A5 an
amazing effort and that is just what
these top players do they manufacture
winning chances out of nowhere because
you do the same thing and his wife came
against Muhammad muradli he was dead in
the water and yet he turns it around at
the drop of a hat
and it's important to do that in game
one we saw what happened I'm gonna
mention it time and time again with
dingley Wren and Min late Min one game
one he was able to steal that one from
the number two player in the world and
that gave him the confidence and the
chances but if we look at our scores
from today we start off today with Arjun
aragaisi taking down David faravian that
was a smooth victory for the Indian
teenager rajaba was in a tight one
against hoi fun I was two draws solid
play from both and then game three was
just an absolute debacle both sides
making blunders and time travel over job
off came out on top of that one we saw
Jana pomshi and Peter Sidler win in just
three games uh swither looked especially
impressive and then mama gerv he wins
two loses the third game when you think
he might get nervous no he was cool as a
cucumber played some great opening uh
play with Knight to G8 The Retreat and
then he was able to in fact win the
fourth and final game so
Dania looking forward in group E what do
you think about these top four duking
out for a spot in the round of 16.
I mean there's so many matches to look
forward to and matches that have not
happened before that to me is one of the
big the biggest calling cards of the cgc
in general you get to watch players from
different Generations battling it out
for the first time in their lives and
maybe even the only time in the careers
of some of these players we're going to
see Arjun era geisi and see what we're a
job of nepos Fiddler is a perennial
matchup they have played over the years
dozens of times but this time they are
meeting on perhaps the biggest stage yet
with 200k and a trip to Toronto soon to
be on the line but even the players who
still are in the round of 64 who still
have to win their first match I'm
talking JKD I'm talking Vida gujarathi
they have a difficult match in front of
them as well if they want to join the
round of 32 they're gonna have to bring
their absolute a game to the table and
look at these matchups mouth-watering
Wong how against Peter lekko their
friends their long time not Rivals is
that there's a specific rivalry between
them but they played over the board
Peter leko of course famous for
challenging Vladimir kramek's title Wang
Hao 2750 plus player playing the Candace
retired because of some health issues
and then he unretired this year we're
happy to see him back over the board
Vedic Gujarati the Indian Superstar
beloved in the host country of this past
Olympiad he played a match in front of a
thousand plus people against Anish giri
and he takes on Alexis Serrano and Donna
you may know Alexi better than anybody
yeah Alexi has proven himself again and
again in the RCC I mentioned that
earlier he is also known as an opening
specialist and you know when he's
playing confidently and he's on he can
beat absolutely anybody we see a lot of
players in the 2650 feet a rating range
who have that capacity to Duke it out
successfully with the top players in the
world so a very unenviable matchup for
the Indian phenom yeah it's all tough
here in the chest icon Global
Championship tomorrow's matchups will be
more fun ones because the fun doesn't
stop just because today's action does
you see the three matchups that we were
just talking about in group b those are
the early matches Duda cannot look ahead
UHA is a very strong player who's
performed admirably online and then Wong
Hao versus Peter lekko to me Donya
that's a bit of a toss-up and who do you
have is the favorite in that match
I think I have Wang Hao but only by a
little bit I mean we know how solid
Peter leko is and he brings to the table
some good opening preparation
it's a total toss-up I agree with you
completely as is vetted against Alexi by
the way but it is obviously the favorite
on paper but like we just discussed if
Alexi brings his A-game we might see
some Shockers tomorrow visit against
Serana you will not want to miss that
matchup not that you want to miss anyone
but I really think I circled that one in
advance I didn't know who to choose
because I believe that no matter who
wins in that matchup they can take down
mom and jaro mom and your will be
favorite but those two players are super
strong Alexi Serrano plays in time
Tuesdays Rapid chess championships
bullet chess championships you name it
he's there he's all over the place and
he's nearly 2700 himself and as you
mentioned he is an opening theoretician
renowned around the globe all the top
players have mentioned Alexi Serrano
they know how strong he is wouldn't be
surprised if he's a second of one of
these top players I just don't know that
so Daniel man gotta thank you for
joining me today I know you
came onto the show later but we'll be
partnered up again tomorrow
we will indeed uh this was
a pleasure Robert you are a trooper for
covering the entire show
I am very excited to continue to watch
the cgc matches the first couple of days
have more than lived up to their promise
and you know I really hope that people
are just taking the same breathing it in
because like I said we might never see
some of these matchups ever again some
of these generational matchups some of
these top players taking on young hungry
talented players
seat belts fastened and mandatory as the
cgc draws closer to the round of 32. I
am getting more and more excited what a
great way it will be to start the
weekend tomorrow for sure we do have any
Armageddon matchups today you can blame
the players for that but we still had
great chess we had legends playing
Spindler vs sure of how could you
complain well if you're Sheriff you
might complain about the final result
but still it was amazing to have them
both in the field and Fiddler moves on
some top players made their way through
to the round of 32 and you all were
treated to great chess all around so
we'll see you tomorrow for more from the
chess.com Global Championship on behalf
of my partner here for master Daniel
naroditski and myself Robert Hess we
will see you tomorrow enjoy the rest of
your Friday
foreign
[Music]